CALL THE SENATE COMMITTEE ON
RULES FOR FEBRUARY THIRD TO
ORDER I'M GONNA MAKE A FEW
COMMENTS IN THE BEGINNING
BEFORE MADAM SECRETARY CALLS
THE ROLE. YOU'RE GONNA HEAR ME
WITH THOSE OF YOU THAT TUNE
INTO US REGULARLY YOU'RE GOING
TO SAY SOMETHING THAT I'VE SAID
BEFORE SO. I'M GONNA MAKE
SEVERAL ANNOUNCEMENTS TODAY TO
EXPLAIN THE PROCESS SEES WE'VE
DEVELOPED TO CONTINUE OUR
ESSENTIAL WORK DURING THE
PANDEMIC FOR THOSE OF YOU
FAMILIAR WITH THE PROCESS WE
APPRECIATE YOUR PATIENCE WHILE
I GO THROUGH IT AGAIN FOR THOSE
TUNING IN FOR THE VERY FIRST
TIME. SO LET ME COVER THE
TECHNICAL SIDE OF THINGS FOR
TODAY. IN RESPONSE TO THE CODE
NINETEEN EMERGENCY AND TO
PROTECT THE PUBLIC SENATORS AND
SENATE STAFF WE MUST LIMIT
NONESSENTIAL GATHERING TONIGHT
HERE TO SOCIAL DISTANCING. IN
COMPLIANCE WITH STATE AND LOCAL
ORDERS THE SENATE WILL BE
HOLDING THIS ESSENTIAL HEARING
AND IS MADE NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL
PRACTICES. ORDER TO ENSURE THAT
THE PUBLIC HAS ACCESS TO OUR
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS WHILE
CONDUCTING THE HEARING IN A WAY
THAT PROTECTS THE HEALTH AND
SAFETY OF OUR PUBLIC AND OUR
EMPLOYEES. WE'RE HOLDING OUR
COMMITTEE MEETING HERE IN THE
CAPITAL WITH ONE OF OUR
COMMITTEE MEMBERS SENATOR BATES
PARTICIPATING IN THE HEARING
REMOTELY WITH THE USE OF VIDEO
CONFERENCE SYSTEM. I SENATOR
BATES IF YOU WERE THERE CAN I
ASK YOU TO IDENTIFY ANYONE THAT
IS IN THE ROOM WITH YOU. YES I
HAVE MY EXECUTIVE ASSISTANT WE
STOPPING HERE WITH ME TODAY
THANK YOU SENATOR. ARE
RETURNING BACK TO OUR HEARING
PROCESS- TO ALLOW THE PUBLIC
ACCESS WE HAVE ADMITTED MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC TO TWO HEARING
ROOMS TO THE EXTENT THAT SOCIAL
DISTANCING REQUIREMENTS ALLOW
WILL BE USING A TELECONFERENCE
SERVICE FOR THOSE INDIVIDUALS
WHO WISH TO TESTIFY TODAY. FOR
INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT THE PARTICIPANT
TOLL FREE NUMBER AND ACCESS
CODE IS POSTED ON OUR COMMITTEE
WEBSITE IT'S GOING TO BE
DISPLAYED ON THE SCREEN RIGHT
NOW BEFORE US. AND THAT
PARTICIPATE TOLL FREE NUMBER IS.
844-291-6364 THE ACCESS CODE IS.
NINE TWO FOUR ONE FOUR FIVE
EIGHT ONE MORE TIME. EIGHT FOUR
FOUR TWO NINE ONE SIX THREE SIX
FOUR. ACCESS CODE. NINE TWO
FOUR ONE FOUR FIVE EIGHT. WHEN
WE MOVED TO THE PUBLIC COMMENT
A MODERATOR WILL IDENTIFY YOU
INDIVIDUALLY OPEN YOUR LINE AND
AT THAT TIME YOU MAY ADDRESS
THE COMMITTEE. NOTE THAT IN
ORDER FOR US TO HEAR YOU
CLEARLY AND TO AVOID FEEDBACK
YOU MUST BE USED THE DEVICE YOU
ARE WATCHING THE HEARING ON
PRIOR TO GIVING YOUR TESTIMONY
OVER THE PHONE. IF YOU DON'T
WILL WE WILL BE ABLE TO HEAR
YOU. IT'S IMPOTANT WE HEAR
FROM YOU SO WE AGAIN THANK YOU
FOR YOUR PATIENCE. SO I WILL
REMAIN DECORUM MAINTAINED
DECORUM EXCUSE ME. DURING THE
HEARING AS IS CUSTOMARY IN ANY
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE DISRUPTIVE
MAY BE REMOVED FROM THE REMOTE
MEETING SERVICE OR HAVE THEIR
DISAPPEAR THEIR CONNECTIONS
MUTED. WHILE EVERY EFFORT HAS
BEEN MADE TO STREAMLINE THE
HEARING PROCESS AND CONDUCT OUR
HEARINGS IN AS CLOSE TO THE
SAME MANNER AS IS CUSTOMARY.
THERE MAY BE SOME LAG TIME FOR
PARTICIPANTS ADJUSTING TO THE
NEW ONLINE TOOLS SO AGAIN BE
PATIENT AND I THANK YOU FOR
THAT. MOST IMPORTANTLY. ON
BEHALF OF OUR STENOGRAPHER I'M
GOING TO ASK OUR THAT ALL
SPEAKERS MY COLLEAGUES IN
WITNESSES ALIKE SPEAK SLOWLY
AND CLEARLY SO THAT SHE IS ABLE
TO- HERE YOU AND TRANSCRIBE. SO
HAVING SAID ALL OF THAT MADAM
SECRETARY LET'S ESTABLISH A
QUORUM AND MEMBERS REMEMBER
YOU'LL NEED TO TURN YOUR MIKES
ON- FOR THE ROLL CALL AN OF
COURSE EVERY TIME WE VOTE MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
IF YOUR NEEDS HERE HERTZBERG.
HERE LAYERED HERE OR HERE WELL
FROZEN WILL PRESENT ATKINS HERE
ATKINS HERE COLLEAGUES LET ME
SEE IF I CAN ESTABLISH- GET
SOME OF THE ITEMS OUT OF THE
WAY COULD I HAVE A MOTION ON
ITEM NUMBER ONE THE BILL
REFERRAL. THANK YOU MR MAJORITY
LEADER- ANYONE MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ON ITEM
ONE. BATES RIGHT THESE AYE
HERTZBERG ALL RIGHT HERTZBERG I
LAYERED HI THERE I WILL HI LOOK
AYE ATKINS HI HOW CAN FIVE FIVE
TWO ZERO FIVE TWO ZERO THANK
YOU MADAM SECRETARY LET ME SEE
IF I CAN GET A MOTION ON ITEM
NUMBER THREE GOVERNOR'S
APPOINTEES NOT REQUIRED TO
APPEAR ITEMS HE LARA RAM BEEN
MEMBER OF THE BUILDING
STANDARDS COMMISSION ALSO AARON
STOCKWELL ITEM F. MEMBER
BUILDING STANDARDS COMMISSION
HOW MOTION. THANK YOU OUR
SENATOR EARLIER HAS MOVED MADAM
SECRETARY. TURN ON YOUR
MICROPHONE TH. BATES BY THE AYE
HERTZBERG AYE HERTZBERG AYE
LAYERED HI AYE WILK HI I ATKINS
HI ATKINS I HAVE TWO ZERO FIVE
TWO ZERO THANK YOU THOSE
APPOINTMENTS WILL BE.
CONSIDERED DONE. AND CONFIRMED-
BECAUSE THEY DON'T GO TO THE
FLOOR- LET ME- IS THAT CORRECT
MADAM SECRETARY. THEY'RE
CONFIRMED. THEY ARE. NOW THEY
DO GO TO THEY GO TO THE FLOOR
OKAY SO- WE ARE MOVING THAT TO
THE FLOOR THANK YOU- OKAY WE'RE
GONNA GO BACK TO THE GOVERNOR'S
APPOINTEES ITEM NUMBER TWO WE
WILL MOVE. TO A AND LET ME JUST
THANK THOSE WAITING IN THE
QUEUE AND WE QUITE A PEOPLE ARE
WAITING TO BE HEARD TODAY- BUT
WE FIRST GOING TO TAKE A- MISS
CARLA K. WHO IS CHIEF TO
DEPARTMENT OF DEVELOP SERVICE.
AND I AM GOING TO SAY TO YOU-
OFFERED THE OPPORTUNITY TO MAKE
SOME OPENING COMMENTS RECOGNIZE
ANY ONE THAT MIGHT BE WITH YOU
YOUR FAMILY SUPPORTERS AND THEN
WE'LL GO RIGHT TO MEMBERS FOR.
CHRISTIANS AND COMMENTS ARE
WELCOME. THANK YOU. AFTERNOON
MADAM CHAIRS SENATORS MY NAME
IS CARLA BECAUSE THEN THE OTHER
WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES AND I AM
THE CHIEF CHIEF DEPUTY DIRECTOR
FOR OPERATIONS JOINING ME TODAY
ARE MY SISTERS LUCY JESSICA AND
BARBARA AS WELL AS MY NIECE
RACHEL AND MY GRANNY SO LIBYA
WILL BE ELEVEN MONTHS OLD A FEW
DAYS. JOINING ME REMOTELY AS MY
FATHER AND MY NEPHEWS DEPENDING
ON THEIR SCHOOL SCHEDULES- I'D
LIKE TO THINK THESE FOLKS AS MY
SUPPORT AND STRENGTH WHEN TIMES
ARE TOUGH BUT THEY DON'T
HESITATE TO KEEP ME HUMBLE WHEN
TIMES ARE GOOD- I I'D ALSO LIKE
TO THANK MY- DAD SPECIFICALLY
FOR. HIS LIFELONG EFFORTS TO
TEACH ME- THE IMPORTANCE OF
HARD WORK AND PERSEVERANCE AND
MY MOTHER WHO ALTHOUGH SHE'S
BEEN GONE. ABOUT TEN YEARS-
DEFINITELY TAUGHT ME TO LOOK AT
THINGS FROM ANOTHER PERSON'S
PERSPECTIVE J. ALTERNATIVE
POINTS OF VIEW. I'D ALSO LIKE
TO THANK GOVERNOR SOON
SECRETARY GALLEON DIRECTOR
PARCHMENT IN THEIR CONFIDENCE
IN SELECTING ME FOR EVERY
APPOINTMENT CHIEF DEPUTY
DIRECTOR OF OPERATIONS. AND OF
COURSE OUR STAFF WHO JUST ARE
SO AMAZING AND A DILIGENT IN
ALL THE EFFORTS TO CONTINUE TO
SUPPORT OUR MISSION. IN
MAINTAINING SERVICES AND
SUPPORTS FOR INDIVIDUALS WITH
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES.
WHEN I BEGAN WITH THE
DEPARTMENT THIS SPRING AT THE
BEGINNING OF THE PUBLIC HEALTH
EMERGENCY. I WAS AMAZED AT THE
EFFORTS AND THE COLLABORATION
AS WE EVALUATED HOW TO FIRST
AND FOREMOST KEEP INDIVIDUALS
SAFE. NOT JUST THE INDIVIDUALS
WE PROVIDE SERVICES FOR BUT THE
STAFF TO SUPPORT THEM AND THE
COMMUNITY AROUND THEM THE
FAMILIES- SOME OF THAT WAS
LIMITING VISITATION TO REDUCE
EXPOSURE. BUT AS AS WE CONTINUE
TO EVALUATE WE LOOKED AT MAYBE
FINDING WAYS TO ENSURE SERVICES
CONTINUED BY AUTHORIZING REMOTE
ACCESS OR ALTERNATIVE.
LOCATIONS TO DELIVER SERVICES.
AS THE NEW FOR THIS SO CNTINUE
FROM THE STATE'S RESPONSE WE
ALSO EXPANDED CAPACITY UNDER
DEVELOPMENTAL CENTERS TO
SUPPORT INDIVIDUALS WITH
DEVELOPMENT DISABILITIES. AS
WELL AS INDIVIDUALS IN THE
COMMUNITY WHICH WAS OPERATED BY
OUR SISTER AGENCIES- THIS WORK
DIDN'T END THERE AS AS THE-
PUBLIC HEALTH EMERGENCY
CONTINUES WE CONTINUE TO
EVALUATE BASED ON STATE.
STAKEHOLDER FEEDBACK AS
INFORMATION BALLS- MOST
RECENTLY SOME DIRECTIVES HAVE
OFFERED ADDITIONAL RATES FOR
ADDRESSING IN ADDITIONAL
ARTISTS FOR DIRECTED SUPPORT
DIRECT. SUPPORT I'M SORRY- AND
THEN AND THEN IT. AS WELL AS
NEW RATES FOR HELPING PEOPLE
PORTANTINO MORE SAFELY WHETHER
THAT'S- INCLUDING ONE OR TWO
STAFF TO STAY WITH INDIVIDUALS
IN SUPPORT OF LIVING- I LOOK
FORWARD TO OUR ON GOING EFFORTS
AS WE EVALUATE OPERATIONAL
EFFICIENCIES OF OUR DEPARTMENT
STAFF ALSO LOOKED AT
ALTERNATIVE WAYS OF COMPLETING
THEIR TASKS TO ENSURE THAT IT
OPERATIONS CONTINUE AND THAT WE
CAN SUPPORT IT ABOUT OUR
SERVICES SYSTEM- AS WE GO
FORWARD IN THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET AND BEYOND THE PUBLIC
HEALTH EMERGENCY WE ARE
EVALUATING. THINGS THAT WORKED
WELL THINGS THAT NEEDED
ADDITIONAL. NO EFFORTS AND WERE
TAKEN WHETHER NOT SEEKING
FEDERAL AUTHORITY OR CHANGING
SOME OF OUR REQUESTING
STATUTORY OR REGULATORY
CHANGES- BUT OUR OUR LONGER
TERM GOAL WILL BE ENSURING THAT
INDIVIDUALS WITH DEVELOPMENT
DISABILITIES. HAVE BETTER
ACCESS IMPROVED ACCESS. TO THE
SERVICES. THAT WE'RE DELIVERING
THOSE IN A CULTURALLY AND
LINGUISTICALLY APPROPRIATE
MANNER TO HELP THEM LIVE
INDEPENDENTLY IN THE
COMMUNITIES OF THEIR CHOICE.
THANK YOU FOR CONSIDERING MY
CONFIRMATION TODAY I'M HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH I AM GOING TO GO TO A
SENATOR BATES FIRST OF.
REMOTELY SENATOR BATES. I THINK
I AM I AM I NEEDED NOW YES.
CONGRATULATIONS ON YOUR
APPOINTMENT TARA DIRECTOR
AUGUSTINE YOU GOT- AND- THANK
YOU FOR YOUR SERVICE SO IT'S A
VERY VERY IMPORTANT ASSIGNMENT
THAT YOU CAN OUTSIDE WAS A
SOCIAL WORKER MANY YEARS AGO
AND- I WAS ACTUALLY IN CHARGE
OF THE AGE OF THE DISABLED
PROGRAM WHEN THAT WAS ALL. PART
OF BOND ON THE- CATEGORICAL
AIDS THAT WERE ADMINISTERED BY
YOUNG THE COUNTY AND CERTAINLY
IN THE STATE SO WHAT SHE DID IS
SO VERY IMPORTANT IN A- QUICK
QUESTION FOR YOU BECAUSE MOST
OF ITS COVERED IN THANK YOU FOR
THAT INTRODUCTION. BUT I WAS SO
INTERESTED IN THE AND THE SELF
DETERMINATION PROGRAM- THAT WAS
ACTUALLY INITIATED BEFORE I WAS
IN THE LEGISLATURE BUT A VERY
INTEESTING AND I WONDERED. HOW
IT'S GOING SINCE THE LAUNCH WAS
SCHEDULED EARLIER BUT THE
PANDEMIC KIND OF GONE IN THE
WAY SO COULD YOU GIVE US JUST A
LITTLE. LOVE- HI OF. CAN BE A
WHOLE WHATEVER WENT ON HOW THE
GOING WHICH EXPECT A WITH SOME
SEEING LIGHT AT THE END OF THE
TUNNEL MAYBE MORE PEOPLE FIND
ONTO IT. YES WE'RE WE'RE ALL
EXCITED TO OFFER NEW NEW
SERVICES TO HELP OUR
INDIVIDUALS- THE ORIGINAL.
PROGRAM WAS DESIGNED TO
HIGHLIGHT WITH TWENTY FIVE
HUNDRED INDIVIDUAL UP AFTER THE
PILOT THERE WAS ACTUALLY
ANOTHER WAIVER TO SUPPORT
TWENTY FIVE HUNDRED
INDIVIDUALS- THERE HAVE BEEN
BARRIERS IDENTIFIED AND WE
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH REGIONAL
CENTERS IN STAKEHOLDERS. TO
IDENTIFY WHAT THOSE BARRIERS
ARE WHETHER IT'S ABILITY TO
HIRE STAFF HOW TO GO ABOUT
MAKING THAT AS MORE
STRAIGHTFORWARD PROCESS- ALSO
LOOKING AT IF THERE ARE
TRAINING OPPORTUNITIES FOR
COORDINATORS AND FOR
INDIVIDUALS AS THEY'RE
DEVELOPING THEIR BUDGETS. AND
TO UNDERSTAND WHAT THEY HAVE
AVAILABLE AND HOW THAT MIGHT
CHANGE AS NEEDS CHANGE. SO
THERE'S MORE WORK TO BE DONE.
IN THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET WE
KNOW THAT WE WOULD LIKE TO
CONTINUE TO EVALUATE THAT GOING
ALL RIGHT AS THE WAIVER IS UP
FOR RENEWAL. ARE YOU. INTEREST
IT SEEMS THERE ARE FILES SLOTS
FROM TWENTY FIVE HUNDRED
ORIGINALLY I BELIEVE AND THEN-
I THINK ONLY THREE HUNDRED OR
SOME SIGNED UP PRIVATE PRE COLD
IT. ALSO I'M ASSUMING YOU'RE
DOING SOME OUTREACH ON NOW AND
THEN THERE THERE'S INTEREST
THAT'S BEEN EXPRESSED I THANK
YOU FOR YOUR PRESENTATION. YES
DEFINITELY I'M GOING INTERESTED
WE HAVE MADE PROGRESS OVER THE
LAST FEW MONTHS- I THINK WE'RE
APPROACHING FIVE HUNDRED. I'M
STILL TRYING TO ADDRESS IT AS
AS BE CANONIZED AS INDIVIDUALS
IDENTIFY WHERE WE MIGHT MAKE
SUPPOSED IMPROVE. OKAY WELL
THANK YOU AND AGAIN
CONGRATULATIONS AND THEN YOU
WILL HAVE MY SUPPORT STRUCTURE.
THANK YOU SENATOR BATES-
SENATOR LAYERED YES- IS IT JUST
SENATOR BATES BASICALLY ASKED
THE ONE QUESTION I WAS GOING TO
ASK IT AND MAYBE I'LL MAKE
COMMENTS BECAUSE- OF I'M VERY.
GRATEFUL FOR YOUR SERVICE AND I
REALLY LOOK FORWARD TO
SUPPORTING YOU IT'S JUST A
THIRD OF IT AND I DON'T WANT
THIS ONE ISSUE TOOK TO CLOUD
THE FACT THAT YOU HAVE AN
OUTSTANDING CAREER AND YOU'RE
DOING GREAT AND WE'RE GONNA
LOOK FORWARD TO ARE MOVING THIS
AHEAD. BUT THAT BILL WAS
ENACTED IN TWENTY THIRTEEN A.
N. D. OF FEDERAL APPROVAL TO
START DOING THE SELF
DETERMINATION WAS THREE YEARS
AGO AND THAT IS A NEW NUMBER
BECAUSE WE HAD AS SENATOR BATES
SAID THREE HUNDRED FIFTY SIX OF
THE- OF THE TWENTY FIVE
HUNDRED- HAD ACTUALLY BEEN
APPROVED AND- THERE ARE OVER
TWO THOUSAND WANT TO
PARTICIPATE I DON'T KNOW A
NUMBER OF US THAT ARE SITTING.
HERE BY PEOPLE. OUR THAT WANT
US TO DO LIKE. TO YOUR TO GET
THIS. AND SO I WOULD JUST SAY
THAT WHILE WE MAY STILL
CONSIDER THAT THAT IS JUST A
REAL PRIORITY AND IT'S TAKEN A
LONG TIME TO GET THERE
ADMITTEDLY THE PANDEMIC HAS
BEEN WHAT IS SPEND THE LAST TEN
MONTHS SO. I DON'T WANT THAT
THE CLOUD THE OVERALL DIRECTION
TO JUST SAY THAT- I'M GOING TO
DISASTER COOLEY SUPPORTER-
CONFIRMATION AND JUST HOPE TO
WORK TOGETHER WITH YOU ON THAT
ONE ISSUE. THANK YOU SENATOR
TOM. IT DIRECTOR I WILL I WILL
DO THIS RELATED TO THAT BECAUSE
I HAD A SIMILAR QUESTION BUT MY
COLLEAGUES I HAVE ALREADY BEAT
ME TO IT AND WE'VE GOT TWO MORE
TO GO WHAT WE HAVE DONE IN THE
PAST AT THE RULES COMMITTEE-
WHAT I MAY DO IS REFER THIS TO
STAFF- MISS GRIFFIS HAS WORKED
TO. PUT TOGETHER LETTERS ON MY
BEHALF TO FIVE DIRECTORS OF
DEPARTMENTS TO PUT IT ON YOUR
RADAR SCREEN AND WE WILL COPY
THE ARE BUDGET SUB THREE-
SENATOR EGGMAN I THINK THIS
FALLS UNDER HER- CATEGORY AND
WE WILL HOPEFULLY GET FOLLOW UP
I'D GLADLY WERE STILL IN THE
YEAR IN WHICH IT IS DIFFICULT
YOU'RE HAVING TO OVERCOME
CHALLENGES AND BARRIERS RELATED
TO CO BID- BUT LIKE MY
COLLEAGUE I. HAD A RECENT
CONVERSATION WITH DR EMERSON
WHO WAS THE AUTHOR OF SB FOUR
SIXTY EIGHT WHO WAS CHECKING IN
WITH ME AND SO IT WOULD BE GOOD
TO PEN A LETTER AND DIANE WILL
HELP DO THAT SO THAT WE PUT IT
ON YOUR RADAR SCREEN AND
PROBABLY WITHIN THE NEXT YEAR
WE MAY ASK YOU IF YOU WOULD BE
WILLING TO RESPOND TO THAT TO
GIVE US AN UPDATE. THROUGH THAT
PROCESS. THANK YOU. SHE IS NOT
IN HER HEAD I TAKE THAT IS. YES
MR VICE CHAIRMAN LET ME GO TO
YOU. THANK YOU MAYOR PRO TEM.
FAULT LAST WEEK THE DISABILITY
ADVOCACY GROUPS ON AN EMERGENCY
TOWN HALL TO DISCUSS THE
DISABILITY COMMUNITIES ACCESS
TO THE COVERT VACCINE. AND THE
CONTINUED CONFUSION REGARDING
ACCESS THOSE HOPING YOU COULD.
HELP US UNDERSTAND WHAT EFFORTS
THE DEPARTMENT IS MAKING TO
EDUCATE CONSUMERS FAMILIES AND
PROVIDERS. ABOUT THE VACCINE
AND HOW DOES THE DEPARTMENT
PLAN TO TRACK VACCINE
ADMINISTRATION FOR CONSUMERS.
THANK YOU FOR THAT QUESTION WE
ARE CONTINUING TO APPROACH THAT
ON BOTH FRONTS HEARING FROM OUR
CONSUMERS AND FAMILIES AS WELL
AS THE PROVIDERS ABOUT
CHALLENGES AS THEY'RE STICKING
THEIR VACCINATION BUT ALSO
COORDINATING INTERNALLY WITHIN
THE ADMINISTRATION ON WHAT'S
AVAILABLE AND WHAT INFORMATION
IS. HOW IT'S CHANGING- I
BELIEVE THIS MORNING THERE WAS
AN ANNOUNCEMENT ABOUT THE
ADDITIONAL VACCINATION SITES
AND SO THERE THERE ARE ONGOING
EFFORTS TO EVALUATE. THE
AVAILABILITY- AND THEN
PRIORITIES GIVEN NOT LIMITED
QUANTITY. SEP SIMILAR TO THE
TESTING AVAILABILITY BACK IN
THE SPRING- AS AS- SUPPLIES
WERE. INCREASED AND THAT WAS
THAT. THE ABILITY TO DO MORE
TESTING AND INCREASED AND I
EXPECT THE SAME WITH
VACCINATIONS INITIALLY WE HAVE
A SOME STRUGGLES AS WE'RE JUST
TRYING TO. SORT OUT THE
DELIVERIES MAKE SURE THOSE
ADMINISTRATIONS ARE ALLOCATED
EQUITABLY AND THEN ALSO AT THAT
THE INDIVIDUALS HAVE TO
APPROPRIATE CONSENTS SO IT IS
WHAT IT WILL BE AN ONGOING
EFFORT- AND EXPECT MORE MORE
AS- INFORMATION IS HERE. K.
RESHAPE THAT ANSWER LOOKING
FORWARD FORWARD TO SUPPORTING
YOUR CONFIRMATION COMES BEFORE
US HERE IN A FEW MINUTES.
SENATOR HERTZBERG. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MA'AM BURKE CHEN THE
WITH MY QUESTIONS WERE WERE
LAST WELL I JUST WANTED TO-
THANK YOU FATHER FOR HIS GOOD
ADVICE AND FOR YOU TAKING IT
AND- WISH YOU WELL IN THIS-
VERY HARD WORK. YOU KNOW IT'S
QUITE CHALLENGING JOB AN IDEA.
YOU WILLING TO TAKE IT ON HAPPY
TO SUPPORT YOU TODAY. THANK YOU
SENATOR- I ONLY HAD ONE OTHER
QUESTION AND IT'S RELATED TO
SERVICES FOR HIGH NEEDS YOUTH.
AND UNDERSTAND THAT THE STATE I
HAVE BEEN KEPT ABREAST OF THIS
BY MY STAFF IN THE PRO TEM'S
OFFICE. THE STATE DECERTIFIED
ALL OUT OF STATE PLACEMENT
FACILITIES FOR FOSTER PROBATION
YOUTH. INCLUDING A DOZEN YOUTH
WHO WERE ALSO DIAGNOSED WITH
THE DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITY.
BOB WHAT GAPS DO YOU FEEL
REMAIN IN THAT CONTINUUM OF
SERVICE YOU WANT TO SPEAK TO
THAT JUST A LITTLE BIT AND IT
IS ON MY RADAR SCREEN AND JUST
WANTED TO PUT IT ON YOURS. SURE
THANK YOU- SO FOR THE OUT OF
STATE YOUTH WELL WHAT WE HAVE
DONE IS IN COOPERATION WITH
DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICE THE-
SOCIAL SERVICES AND COUNTIES IS
IDENTIFYING THE YOUTH AND
IDENTIFYING WHAT NEEDS THEY
MADE- WHAT WOULD HELP SUPPORT
THEM IN CALIFORNIA- FOR
DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES WE-
ASSUME THAT WE MAY NEED TO. TWO
TYPES OF SERVICES THEY OPERATED
AS WELL AS REGIONAL CENTERS IN
ENHANCE BEHAVIORAL SUPPORT
HOMES- WE HAVE TO INDIVIDUALS
AS OF LAST WEEK THAT WERE BEING
SERVED IN OUR STATE OPERATED
FACILITY- ADDITIONAL
EVALUATIONS ARE ONGOING. SO NOT
NECESSARILY GAPS AT THE MOMENT
FOR MORE IDENTIFYING. WHAT
SERVICES THOSE YOUTHS MAY NEED
AND WHERE THEY MAY BE
APPROPRIATELY SIR. OKAY WELL
THANK YOU FOR THAT AND I KNOW
THE PANDEMIC CAUSED BY COST OF
A PRO FIVE ACTION TO GET THOSE
KIDS SO YOUNG PEOPLE THE YOUTH
HOME. TO CALIFORNIA SO I
APPRECIATED AND I CERTAINLY
WANT TO SEE HOW THAT. CONTINUES
TO GO SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
COLLEAGUES ARE ANY FOR
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. PLEASE
WILL I GO TO PUBLIC WILL WANT
SOMETHING LIKE AND THEN I JUST
WANT TO MAKE SURE TO FOR US.
IT'S ALL GOOD- SO WE'RE GONNA
GO TO OUT MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
IT WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT. I'M GONNA START RIGHT
HERE IN ROOM THIRTY ONE NINETY
ONE. AND SEEING NO ONE STEPPING
FORWARD TO THE MICROPHONE- MY-
TO COMMENT IN SUPPORT LET ME GO
TO ROOM ONE TWELVE. AND TAKE A
LOOK A THAT ROOM I SEE NO ONE
APPROACH IN THE PODIUM OKAY SO
LET ME INTRODUCE A MODERATOR
WHO WAS WAITING IN THE WINGS
TO- LET ANYONE WHO WANTS TO
TESTIFY- VIA TELECONFERENCE.
THANK YOU IF YOU ARE IN SUPPORT
OF THIS BILL YOU MAY PRESS ONE.
ZERO WE WILL GO TO LINE OF
SEVENTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THANK YOU- AUG SPEAK SLOW FOR
THE- PERSON DOING THE
TRANSCRIPTS MARTY AMODIO I'M A
FAMILY MEMBER OF AN OLDER
SISTER WHO HAD DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES AND ALSO EXTENDED
FAMILY TO A PERSON ADULT WITH
DOWN SYNDROME AND- EXACTED
DIRECTORS HE CAN TELL TWENTY
DISABILITY SENIOR COMMUNITY
ACTION NETWORK ALSO. A MEMBER
OF THE DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES
TASK FORCE THE MASTER PLAN
PREACHING SUB COMMITTEES AND
NUMEROUS OTHER STAKEHOLDER
GROUPS JUST ONE OFFER MY
STRONG. SUPPORT FOR CARLA I'VE
KNOWN HER FOR YEARS AND NO FROM
HER WORK THAT SHE IS COMMITTED
SHE HAS PROVEN THIS COMMITTED
TO WORKING TOWARDS MAXIMISING
RESOURCES. WHILE REDUCING
DISPARITIES UNMET NEEDS LIKE
TREATING EQUITY DURING
DIFFICULT TIMES WITH PERSON
CENTERED OUTCOMES THAT WE SHARE
WITH HER AND THE DEPARTMENT AND
INCLUDING A TWENTY TWO A
SHADOWED HER FAMILY AND HER DAD
I'M I'M A FATHER MOTHER DAHLE.
DAUGHTER WHO I'M VERY PROUD OF
AND I JUST WANT TO KNOW THAT
FROM BOTHER TO BOTHER WE
APPRECIATE AND ADMIRE CARLA
VERY MUCH SHE MAKES. A
DIFFERENCE IN OUR LIVES THANK
YOU. THANK YOU MUCH MADAME
MODERATOR NEXT WITNESS. NEXT
WE'LL GO TO LINE OF LINE AT
THIRTY NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HI MY NAME IS DOUG PASSED OVER
WITH IMAGINE THE SUPPORTED
LIVING. SERVICES- THANK YOU AND
WE SIR WE CAN'T HEAR YOU NOW-
YOU FADED OUT. NO I NOT NOT
MUCH. OKAY OKAY I'VE BEEN OR-
YOU'RE IN SUPPORT OF MISS
CASTANEDA THANK YOU SO MUCH.
MADAME MODERATOR I'D NEXT
WITNESS. THANK YOU AND WELCOME
TO A LINE OF WITH TWENTY THREE
AIRLINES OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON
MY NAME IS SHELLY DIMOND I AM
THE PARENT OF AN ADULT WHO HAS
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES
NORTHEAST REGIONAL CENTER
SERVICES. I AM ALSO THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF CHANCE
HOUSING WHICH IS A NONPROFIT
AGENCY PROVIDING COMMUNITY
BASED AFFORDABLE AND ACCESSIBLE
HOUSING ASSISTANCE TO PERSONS
WITH DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES.
AND LASTLY I SERVE ON THE
STATE'S DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES
TASK FORCE AND SEVERAL OF ITS
WORKGROUP. I CALLED IN TODAY TO
REGISTER MY SUPPORT FOR THE
CONFIRMATION OF CHIEF DEPUTY
DIRECTOR KARLA CASTANEDA TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF DEVELOPMENTAL
SERVICES. THANK YOU- DEPUTY
CASTANEDA'S GO AHEAD GO AHEAD
MA'AM I'M SORRY. AND FOR PEOPLE
WITH DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES
AND HEREXPERIENCE AT THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE FIND JUST
THE RIGHT BALANCE FOR US MOVING
FORWARD AND I BELIEVE THAT-
PEOPLE WHO RECEIVE SERVICES
WILL BENEFIT FROM THAT BALANCES
WE DEAL WITH THE SYSTEMIC
CHANGES TO COME. I WANT TO
OFFER MY CONGRATULATIONS TO
DEPUTY CASTANEDA AND I LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH HER IN
THE FUTURE ON HOUSING ISSUES
THANK YOU. THANK YOU AND THANK
YOU FOR YOUR SERVICE AS WELL
MATTER MODERATOR NEXT WITNESS.
THANK YOU AND NOW GO TO LINE UP
FORTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS BACK BIRD
I AM THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR FOR
THE AUTISM SOCIETY AND THEN
EMPIRE THE PRESIDENT HAVE
AUTISM SOCIETY OF CALIFORNIA
AND MOST IMPORTANTLY THE PROUD
PARENT OF TWO YOUNG MEN ONE OF
WHOM IS THE REGIONAL CENTER
CLIENTS. AND WE ARE VERY
EXCITED AND WE LOOK FORWARD AND
SUPPORT WHOLEHEARTEDLY THE
CONFIRMATION OF KARLA CASTANEDA
HAS THE DDS ST DEPUTY DIRECTOR
WE LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
HER AND GREAT THINGS FOR OUR
COMMUNITY TO COME. THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAME
MODERATOR NEXT WITNESS. THANK
YOU KNOW FROM LINE TWENTY SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THANK YOU MY
NAME IS VICTOR LARA DIVISION
PRESIDENT OF ARYANA HEALTH CARE
REGIONAL CENTER SERVICES
PROVIDER- WE WORK STATEWIDE- I
ALSO SERVE ON THE DEVELOPMENTAL
SERVICES TASK FORCE AND I'D
LIKE TO EXPRESS MY SUPPORT FOR
THE CONFIRMATION ABOUT KARLA
CASTANEDA AS CHIEF DEPUTY
DIRECTOR OF GDSAS WELL THANK
YOU. THANK YOU SO MUCH NEXT
WITNESS. THANK YOU ARE NOW COME
FROM LINE TWENTY TWO YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS AND DISTINGUISHED
STAFF- THIS IS RICK ROLLINS THE
FORMER SECRETARY OF THE SENATE
AND TODAY TESTIFYING AS THE
LEGISLATIVE ADVISER THE ARK OF
THE SITUATION A REGIONAL CENTER
AGENCIES. ON BEHALF OF ARCA I
AM HONORED TO ADD OUR VOICE TO
THE OTHERS TODAY IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF CARLA FOR
CONFIRMATION TO THIS CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT POSITION WITHIN DDS.
WE HAD OUR COULD HAVE WORKED
WITH CARLA FOR MANY YEARS
INCLUDING THE TIME SHE SERVED
AS AT THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
WHEN SHE HAD THE DVD SYSTEM AS
PART OF HER RESPONSIBILITY
WE'VE ALWAYS FOUND CARLA TO BE
WELL INFORMED A PROBLEM SOLVER
ALWAYS ACCESSIBLE AND JUST
GREAT TO WORK WITH. THE
ADDITION OF CARLOS- TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF DEVELOPMENTAL
SERVICES TO ALREADY TALENTED TO
THE DEPARTMENT DEVELOPMENTAL
SERVICES IS IT IS REALLY GREAT
NEWS FOR OUR SYSTEM I WE
STRONGLY URGE YOUR SUPPORT OF
CARLA TODAY. THANK YOU SO MUCH
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS. AND THAT WILL COME
FROM NINE THIRTY ONE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
HI MY NAME IS VERY JOURNEY AND
THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR AT THE
CALIFORNIA DISABILITY SERVICES
ASSOCIATION- WE'RE STATEWIDE
PROVIDER ASSOCIATION
REPRESENTING OVER A HUNDRED-
PROVIDERS THROUGHOUT THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA. GOING TO NEED TO
REGISTER OUR STRONG SUPPORT FOR
THE CONFIRMATION OF. CASTING IT
TO THE ROLE OF CHIEF DEPUTY
DIRECTOR OF OPERATIONS- SHE'S
AN ABSOLUTELY CRITICAL AS WE'VE
ALL KIND OF MUDDLE OUR WAY
THROUGH- THE PANDEMIC AND IN
THE DEVELOPMENT OF. A CREATIVE
ALTERNATIVES TO SERVICES AND-
JUST RECYCLE OUR REGION OUR
WILLINGNESS TO WORK WITH THE
COMMUNITY AND HER CLEAR
CONVICTION TOWARDS- DELIVERING
ON THE MISSION OF THE
DEPARTMENT HUGE CHOOSE A GREAT
ADDITION AND WE ARE LUCKY TO
HAVE HER AND- THE STRONG
SUPPORTER NOMINATION. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SO MUCH. MATAMATA
RAIDER OTHER WITH. THANK YOU IF
YOU ARE IN SUPPORT OF TODAY'S
BILL YOU MAY PRESS ONE ZERO.
ONE ZERO IF YOU ARE IN SUPPORT.
MADAM CHAIR WE HAVE NO- OTHERS
IN Q. OKAY THANK YOU WE WILL BE
BACK TO YOU IN A FEW MINUTES.
OKAY HAVEN'T HEARD FROM ALL OF
THE SUPPORTERS WILL NOW FOLLOW
THE SAME PROCESS IN HERE. FROM
ANYONE IN OPPOSITION WE WILL
COME BACK INTO ROOM THIRTY ONE
NINETY ONE. AND SEEING NO ONE
IN ROOM THIRTY ONE NINETY ONE
LET ME GO TO ROOM ONE TWELVE. I
SEE NO ONE IN ROOM TWO ONE
TWELVE- SO MADAM MODERATOR I'M
COMING BACK TO YOU FOR MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC. VIA
TELECONFERENCE IT MAY WANT TO
REGISTER THEIR OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU IF YOU WERE IN
OPPOSITION OF THIS BILL YOU MAY
PRESS. ONE ZERO. AND ONE ZERO
IF YOU'RE IN OPPOSITION. MADAM
CHAIR THERE ARE NO ONE IN THE
QUEUE THANK YOU SO MUCH MATTER
MODERATOR SO I WILL BRING IT
BACK ON TO MY COLLEAGUES. AND
IF THERE ARE NO FURTHER
COMMENTS I THINK SENATOR
LAYERED YOU I WAS GOING TO MOVE
APPROVAL OF THIS NOMINATION
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- MADAM
SECRETARY WILL YOU CALL THE
ROLL. PLEASE TURN ON YOUR MY EX.
I IF HERTZBERG AYE HERTZBERG
AYE LAYERED AYE I WILL HI LOOK
I CAN SEE HI I CAN SORRY FIVE
TWO ZERO FIVE TO ZERO THE
APPOINTMENT IS APPROVED THANK
YOU AND CONGRATULATIONS. VERY
MUCH- BEFORE WE GO TO THE
MEDICAL BOARD LET ME CHECK IN
WITH OUR STENOGRAPHER I KNOW.
I'M GOOD THANK YOU THANK YOU SO
MUCH OKAY SO WE'RE GOING TO GO
TO THE APPOINTMENT OF THREE
MEMBERS OF THE MEDICAL BOARD.
WE HAVE WITH US TODAY- DR DEV
GONNA GIVE- I HOPE I SAID THAT
CORRECTLY OR AS CORRECTLY AS I
CAN DR ASIF. MAHMOOD AND DR
RICHARD THORPE SO LET ME SAY
WELCOME TO ALL OF YOU AND THANK
YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE. WE WILL
BEGIN WITH INTRODUCTIONS ARE
FROM EACH OF YOU- WILL START
WITH. A DOCTOR COULD NOT A DEV
AND THEN WE'LL GO TO DOCTOR MY
MOOD AND THEN FINALLY TO DR
THORPE EACH OF YOU CAN
INTRODUCE YOURSELF MAKE OPENING
COMMENTS THE KNOWLEDGE ANYONE
THAT MIGHTBE WITH YOU ODD THAT
YOU WOULD LIKE TO AND THEN. I
WILL GO TO MY COLLEAGUES FOR
QUESTIONS AND COMMENTS SO WE
WILL START WITH YOU- DR-
KANNADA DEATH. REPORTER CHAIR
AND MEMBERS OF THE SENATE RULES
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS DR DALE
GONNA GIVE. I AM TRIPLE BOARD
CERTIFIED VASCULAR GENERAL
TRAUMA AND CRITICAL CARE
SURGEON PRACTICING FOR FORTY
YEARS IN SAN MARINO CALIFORNIA.
MY ENTIRE FORTY YEAR CAREER WAS
SPENT A DEAL YOU PUBLIC
HOSPITAL IN THE COUNTY OF SAN
BERNADINO THERE IS THE ATTITUDE
MEDICAL CENTER- THE FORGET. THE
ONE AS THE CHAIR OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF SURGERY. I WAS IN
LOGGING IN THE TRAINING
HUNDREDS OF DOCTORS NURSES AND
OTHER HEALTH CARE PROFESSIONALS.
WORKING WITH THE BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS OFF MY COMPUTER WAS
INSTRUMENTAL IN CREATING
MULTIPLE COMMUNITY BENEFIT
PROGRAMS. LOOTING FREE A GROUP
OF ALL OF PROGRAM FOR JUVENILE
OFFENDERS MOBILE MEDICAL CLINIC
TO PROVIDE HEALTH CARE TO
PATIENTS WHO HAVE DIFFICULT
TIME ACCESSING SERVICES IN A
LARGE COUNTY. AND KILEY COULD
HAVE LOOKED PROGRAM FOR HEARING
IN HIS IMPATIENCE. THIS IS MY
TENTH YEAR ON THE MEDICAL BOARD
AND THIS ISMY THIRD AND FINAL
APPOINTMENT TO THE MEDICAL
BOARD OF CALIFORNIA. I DO WANT
TO THANK A DONOR I JERRY BROWN
FULLER LIFE ACCORDINGLY TWICE
BEFORE I'M GONNA NEED SOMETHING.
TO FIND HIS TIME. AS THE
PRESIDENT OF MEDICAL IN TWO
THOUSAND SIXTEEN AND EIGHTEEN I
WAS INSTRUMENTAL IN GETTING
MEDICAL. OF CALIFORNIA BECAUSE
SUNSET TREE HILL. DURING MY
TIME THE VOTE TOOK ACTIONS TO
PORTUGAL MANDATED TRAINING FOR
BOARD MEMBERS AND STAFF ON BOTH
EXPLICIT AND IMPLICIT BIAS
TRAINING. AND ALSO TOOK ACTIONS
TO MITIGATE THE BY. THE BOOK
CREATED AN IPHONE THERE THE
CONSUMER CAN FOLLOW MEDICAL
BOARD ACTIONS ON HIS OR HER-
ALL OF HIS OR HER DOCTORS. THE
BOARD. IMPROVE THE QUALITY OF
CARE BY THE TRAINING REQUIRE
FOR DOCTORS THE GUITARIST FROM
ONE YEAR TO THREE YEARS THE
ONLY ONE IN THE COUNTRY THEN
THERE WAS A STALEMATE IN THE
LEGISLATURE ABOUT HAITIAN
NOTIFICATION REQUIREMENT FOR
LICENSEES ON PROBATION I WAS
ABLE TO WORK WITH MY BOARD AND
MEMBERS ARE BELIEVED THERE
SHOULD OF THE BNP COMMITTEES ON
THE ASSEMBLY AND SENATE.
COMPROMISE LEGISLATION PASSED
THE BORDER CALIFORNIA IS THE
FIRST MEDICAL BOARD TO ADOPT IN
THE COUNTRY GADHAFI'S THESE ARE
A FEW EXAMPLES OF APPROVED MARA
BY THE SENATE I WILL CONTINUE
TO WORK HARD- TO PROTECT AND
IMPROVE THE HEALTH OF
CALIFORNIANS THANKS FOR TAKING
CARE OF MY LIFE TO. I'M MADAM
CHAIR I'LL BE HAPPY TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY THANK YOU VERY MUCH
DOCTOR- DOCTOR MAHMOUD. YOU
NEED A MUTE. GOOD AFTERNOON
MADAM CHAIR THANK YOU AND-
MEMBERS OF THE SENATE THANK YOU
FOR TAKING ME ON THIS THING AND
I REALLY APPRECIATE THIS
OPPORTUNITY AND TANK- GO THE
NEWS SOME OF FINDING ME AND
GIVING ME THIS OPPORTUNITY TO
SERVE THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
MY NAME IS DOCTOR SAYS MAHMOUD
I'M A PRACTICING PHYSICIAN HIT
IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA. MY
LIFETIME. ON PASSION AND-
DESIGN HAS BEEN TO HELP AND
SERVE PEOPLE. AND THAT'S WHAT I
DO EVERY SINGLE DAY. NOT ONLY I
HELP PEOPLE TREATING THE
DISEASES BUT I. GOT INVOLVED IN
EVERY SINGLE CHALLENGE DAY FREE
IS EVERY SINGLE DAY. MY
PRACTICE COMPRISES OF MILLION.
MOST OF MY PRACTICE COMPRISES
OF MINORITY PATIENTS AND THAT
IS BY CHOICE BECAUSE I WANT TO
HELP MORE DOES SCHOOL REALLY
NEED HELP. THAN THOSE WHO ARE
PRIVILEGED. I HAD BEEN TRYING
TO FIGHT FOR MY PATIENCE WITH
THE HEALTHCARE PLANS AND- IDEAS
AND- I TROUBLES AND- MANY OTHER
PROVIDERS WHO ARE GIVING A HARD
TIME TO MY PATIENTS AND- I
BELIEVE- HEALTHCARE IS A RIGHT
NOT A PRIVILEGE. I ALSO BELIEVE
NOT ONLY HEALTHCARE QUALITY
HEALTHCARE HEALTH GET RICHER
THAN ACCOUNTABILITY AND THAT
WAS THE REASON I WANTED TO MOVE
ON FROM ME AND I AM. TO THE
STATE LEVEL AND BEYOND BOTTOM
MEDICAL VOTE. BECAUSE THEY- THE
REAL JOB OF MEDICAL VOTE IS TO
PROVIDE A QUALITY HEALTHCARE.
IT IS AN ACCOUNTABILITY THERE
ARE CHECKS AND BALANCES. I
WOULD D MY JOB IF CONFIRMED AS
FAIRLY AS TRANSPARENTLY. AS ALL
MY LIFE HAD BEEN DOING. NOBODY
WAS BETWEEN ME AND CONSUMERS
AND PATIENTS WHO NEED
DESPERATELY HEALTHCARE AND
QUALITY HEALTHCARE. WE KNOW
THAT MOST OF THE POSITIONS AND
PROVIDERS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA ARE DOING THE JOB IN
A TREMENDOUS WAY. NO PROFESSION
IS COMPLETELY OUT OF PEOPLE WHO
ARE CALLED BAD APPLES. AND IT
IS MY JOB AND MY DUTY TO MAKE
SURE THAT NO NEGLIGENCE
HAPPENED BECAUSE- TWO THINGS
ARE THE MOST IMPORTANT THINGS
IN LIFE HEALTHCARE AND LIFE.
AND IF SOMEBODY IS NEGLIGENT
AND HIT A PATIENT INTENTIONALLY
UNINTENTIONALLY RATHER
DIFFICULT TO USE A DIFFERENT IF
THEY'RE NOT APPLYING THE
STANDARD OF CARE TO THE
PATIENTS I THINK WE NEED TO
SHOULD WE SHOULD HAVE. ON THE
ACCOUNT. AND THAT IS REALLY ALL
ONE WORD EVERY SINGLE DAY LIKE
I HAVE BEEN DOING EVER SINCE I
WAS APPOINTED TO TAKE EVERY
DOLLARS BUT HE SERIOUSLY AT ALL
WANT TO ESTABLISH A TRUST
BETWEEN PEOPLE OF CONSUMERS AND
MEDICAL BOARD. I WANT TO HEAR
FROM PEOPLE THIS STATE OKAY WE
TRUST THIS MEDICAL BOARD I WANT
TO MAKE SURE WE HAVE A
COMMUNICATION ANY PATIENT ANY
CONSUMER WHO IS A CONCERN
SHOULD BE. EASILY ABLE TO REACH
MEDICAL MODE AND MEDICAL BOARD
SHOULD HAVE. THE RESOURCES TO
ACT ON THAT. IN A- FOR. AND THE
CONSUMERS BE GIVE THE- AND ALL
THESE CASES WOULD BE TAKEN IN A
TIMELY MANNER. I AM A LITTLE
PASSIONATE PERSON AND I KNOW
BOARD HAS THE RIGHT DIRECTION
BUT I THINK THERE'S A LOT MORE
TO BE DONE. I AND I ALSO WANT
TO THANK MY FAMILY WILL GIVE ME
A LOT OF TIME TO DO ALL MY
WORK. AND I AGAIN THINK YOU AND
I WOULD BE HAPPY TO. ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS THANK YOU AGAIN.
THANK YOU DR MEMBER DR THORPE.
WELCOME. THE MEASURE- MANAGER-
SENATORS. THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO ADDRESS YOU
TODAY I'M LOOKING FORWARD TO
THIS YEAR AND I ARE AND I- I AT
I ALSO WANT TO THANK GOD FOR
THIS OPPORTUNITY TO. TO BE HERE
AND BE IN THIS POSITION. I'M
GRATEFUL FOR MY PARENTS WHO-
GAVE ME MANY OPPORTUNITIES AND
OTHER EARLY IN LIFE. THE NUMBER
OF LIMITS ON MY DREAMS- MY
FAMILY IS- ONLINE TODAY. AND I
WANT TO THANK MY WIFE VICKI OUR
SONGS. SHE HAS BEEN THE WIND
BENEATH MY WINGS FOR OVER
THIRTY YEARS. AND WITHOUT HER
SUPPORT WE ARE TODAY- I'VE BEEN
A CHAMPION OF QUALITY
HEALTHCARE- MY TIRED. AND IN
THE END AND I AM. COMMITTED TO
THAT. SORRY I JUST LOST MY
NOTES. I AM A COMMITTED TO
THAT- BEING SHIPPING CHAMPION I
BELIEVE THAT THE BOND BETWEEN A
PHYSICIAN AND THEIR CLIENT IS
SACRED YEAH I AM IN AWE OF THE
TRUSTED PERSON PUTS IN A
POSITION A GREAT RESPECT FOR
THAT RELATIONSHIP. PEOPLE
TRUSTED IS A POSITION FOR FOUR
YEARS I RECOGNIZE HOW MUCH
MEDICINE I'VE ACTUALLY LEARNED
FROM THEM. AND THIS IS WHY I
WANTED TO CONTINUE SERVING THE
PUBLIC I IN THIS CAPACITY ON
THE MEDICAL BOARD- AND I AM
LOOKING FORWARD TO YOUR
CONFIRMATION TODAY. I LOVE MY
PATIENTS IN MY ENTIRE CHARISMA
DEDICATED TO SAVING LIVES AN
ADVOCATE FOR QUALITY CARE FOR
THEM AND NOW ALL PATIENTS IN
CALIFORNIA- I BELIEVE THE
SUPPORT WILL ALLOW ME TO BRING
MY EXTENSIVE CLINICAL
ADMINISTRATIVE. AND LEADERSHIP
EXPERIENCE TO THE CONSUMERS OF
CALIFORNIA. AND I COMPLETELY
ENDORSE THAT ROLE AS A CONSUMER
PROTECTION ADVOCATE. AS THE
PRIMARY PURPOSE OF THE MEDICAL
BOARD. EVERY DAY MY STAFF AND I
ENSURE THAT EVERY PERSON WE
SHOULD WE SEE. RECEIVE THE CARE
THAT THEY NEED REGARDLESS OF
THEIR ABILITY TO PAY. JUST THIS
MORNING AT THREE FORTY FIVE. I
WAS TOLD. BY MY ANSWERING
SERVICE. TO TALK WITH A
MENTALLY CHALLENGED ELDERLY
WOMAN WOULD FALL AT ALL. HER
FIRST THOUGHT WAS TO CALL ME
HER DOCTOR BEFORE SHE CALLED
NINE ONE ONE. OR ANYONE ELSE
THAT COULD HELP HER. IN TWO
THOUSAND THREE I WAS APPOINTED
BY THE MEDICAL DIRECTOR OF A
SINGLE REAL HEALTH CLINIC THAT
WASINSTRUMENTAL. IN PROVIDING
CARE TO PEOPLE WHO OTHERWISE
WOULDN'T HAVE ACCESS TO CARE- I
THOUGHT TIME CONVERSING
APPROACHING TWENTY THOUSAND
BUSINESS YEAR. IN PART I WAS
RESPONSIBLE FOR THE EXPANSION
OF THE CLICK SYSTEM. TO OVER
FOUR CLINICS ONE OF WHICH WAS A
FORTY THOUSAND SQUARE FOOT.
STATE OF THE ART MULTISPECIALTY
CLINIC. OTHER PROVIDED
EXCELLENT HERE AND NOW WE SEE
APPROXIMATELY. WELL BEFORE THE
FIRE SUBCOMMITTEE THOUSAND
VISITS PER YEAR. I BELIEVE
STRIVING FOR EXCELLENCE IN CARE
FOR ALL PATIENTS. IT'S TRUE
CONSUMER ADVOCACY. I SPOKE WITH
THE FIRE NUMBER EIGHT TWENTY
EIGHTEEN IS A DAY I WILL NEVER
FORGET- I'VE GOT A VERY VIVID
MEMORIES OF THAT DAY- THE
CAMPFIRES AND CAME TO BE KNOWN
AS RESPONSIBLE PHILOSOPHY HE
LIVES MAKING IT THE DEADLIEST
WILDFIRE IN UNITED STATES. OVER
A CENTURY. AFTER ESCAPING THE
FIRE AND RELOCATING TO CHICO I
IMMEDIATELY TOOK INVENTORY OF
MY FAMILY MY STAFF. AND
ORGANIZED BY PARTNERS ABILITY
TO SET UP A TEMPORARY CALL
CENTER. YOU CARE FOR PATIENTS
WHO WERE DISPLACED. WHICH WAS
OVER. FOURTEEN THOUSAND HOMES
WERE WERE DESTROYED. IN ROLE AS
THE MEDICAL DIRECTOR THE WORLD
HEALTH CLINIC I PARTNERED WITH
THE FEATHER HOSPITAL
INADMISSIBLE. DEMAND PHONES
ENSURE THAT MY MEDICAL STAFF
WAS AVAILABLE TO- DID TO TAKE
CARE OF PATIENTS THAT WERE OUT
OF MEDICATIONS ARE NEEDED.
ADDITIONAL CARE. SOCIAL YOU
PARTNER WITH BLUE SHIELD OF
CALIFORNIA AND TELLER AND OF.
HI HERE TO TELEMEDICINE
PLATFORM THAT WAS DEVELOPED SO
WE CAN WE CAN. MANAGE THESE
PATIENTS DREADED DISTANCE AND
COULDN'T FIND PRIMARY CARE
WHERE THEY HAD AND WERE A
DENTISTRY TO. I WE HAVE BEEN
FORTUNATE TO BE BACK HER
CURRENT LOCATION WORK IN
PARADISE SINCE AUGUST OF TWENTY
TWENTY. ONE FIVE OR SIX
PARTNERS INCLUDING MYSELF HAVE
LOST EVERYTHING THEY POSSESSED
THE NEXT SOCKET THEY HAD WAS
HOW DO WE TAKE CARE OF OUR
PATIENTS. NATURAL CONSUMER
ADVOCACY. I BELIEVE ALL
AMERICAN BOARD OF PHYSICIANS
ALONG VERY CAREER. EXPERIENCE
IS A PRIMARY CARE DOCTOR
SPECIALIST. INSURER OF
NONINVASIVE CARDIOVASCULAR AND
OSHER STUDIES SURGICAL
ASSISTANT LEADER MEDICAL GROUP
FOR TWENTY YEARS AND MEDICAL
DIRECTOR OF A REAL HEALTH
CLINIC FOR FIFTEEN YEARS. I
HAVE HELD LEADERSHIP POSITIONS
ARE HOSPITAL IN COUNTY STATE
AND NATIONAL ASSOCIATIONS ON
MANY LEVELS ALL OF THESE
EXPERIENCES HAVE GIVEN ME GREAT
INSIGHT INTO A PHYSICIAN'S
ACTIVITY AND BEHAVIOR AND THE
ABILITY TO MAKE DIFFICULT
JUNCTIONS. I LOVE BEING A
DOCTOR ANSWERING MY PATIENCE
AND I JUST WANT TO SERVE MY
COMMUNITY AND I WANT. TO
ENCOURAGE THE BEST AND
BRIGHTEST YOUNG MAN'S. ON YOUNG
MINDS OF SORRY CHIU JOINED THIS
FOR. IN THE EIGHTEEN MONTHS ARE
SURE ON THE MEDICAL L. I LEARNT
A GREAT DEAL THAT WAS VERY
STEEP LEARN CURVE IS BEGINNING.
BUT ALSO ON SEVERAL OCCASIONS
ADVOCATED- I'M GENERALLY AGREED
WITH THE ATTORNEY GENERAL'S
RESPOND BUT THERE'S BEEN A FEW
CASES WERE ADVOCATE FOR MORE
SEVERE DISCIPLINE. I VOTED FOR
A FEE INCREASE FOR ALL
LICENSEES MEDICAL BOARD
INCLUDING PHYSICIANS AND VIABLE
REVENUE THE REASON IT COMES
FROM PHYSICIANS. IF YOU
INCREASE IS CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT AND NECESSARY FOR THE
WORK OF THE BOARD TO PROTECT
THE HEALTH. OF CONSUMERS AND TO
ENSURE THE LICENSING AND
REGULATION. POSITIONS IS NOT
APPROPRIATELY. I AND WILL
CONTINUE TO ACT WITHOUT BY
JUDGE FAIRLY. PROTECTIONS AND
DISCIPLINE PHYSICIANS WHO FAIL
THEIR NATION'S. I THINK MY TIME
ON THE BOARD ALONG WITH MY
RECORD OF SERVICE IN THE TRUST
OF MY PATIENTS HAVE PLACED IN
ME. FOR OVER FORTY YEARS SPEAKS
FOR ITSELF. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR I LOOK FORWARD TO
ANSWERING YOUR QUESTIONS. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH DR THOR. I'M
GOING TO GO TO SENATOR BATES
WHO IS PARTICIPATING REMOTELY
AND START WITH HER. NINE
MILLION. THERE WE GO WELL THANK
YOU DOCTORS FOR US- REDUCE THE
VERY VERY IMPORTANT BOARD THAT
YOU SERVE ON AND THAT WE ARE I
THINK THE CONSUMER ON OF
CALIFORNIA REALLY LOOK TO THE%
MEDICAL BOARD TO SOLVE SOME OF
THE PROBLEMS THAT EMERGED
DI<c.cyan> THE LAST A DECADE OR SO</c>
AND- ONE FOR ME AND MY DISTRICT
SOMETHING I'VE BEEN VERY
FOCUSED ON IS CERTAINLY THE
OPIOID EPIDEMIC. FILE WE HAVE
LOST OUR SO MANY ARE YOUNG
PEOPLE FROM SOUTH ORANGE COUNTY
OR SAN DIEGO COUNTY ARE DUE TO
OVERDOSES ARE CERTAINLY DOUBTS
WILL BE. ONE OF. A PROBLEM
AARON JIM OF THE FIRST. WE
PROGRAM HIS VERY ODD INTEREST
TO SEE THAT YOU ARE BEGUN I'M
VERY VERY IDEA DIVE INTO. WHAT
OR LIKE STAFF. AND PROBABLY
MANY DOCTORS WHO HAVE BEEN
OVERPRESCRIBING- THANK YOU
LADIES AND JOB CERTAINLY BILLS
ON GET INTO THE HANDS OF THE
WRONG PEOPLE IF EVEN IF THEY'RE
GOING TO THE RIGHT PERSON WE
FOUND THAT OUT SO. I'D LIKE TO
KNOW- WHAT WHEN YOU FIND THE
DOCTOR STATURE REALLY ARE OVER
PRESCRIBING US THROUGH THAT
PROGRAM THAT YOU HAVE LOOKING
AT THE DEATH CERTIFICATES. WHAT
STEPS ARE YOU TAKING AS WE GO
FORWARD- IS AN EDUCATION
PROGRAM WITH OUR PHYSICIANS
ARE. IS THAT SOMETHING THAT'S
RELATED TO ENFORCEMENT BECAUSE
IS IT PROPOSAL AS A SIGN OF
FINANCIAL GAIN THAT'S INVOLVED.
I COULD YOU GIVE US SOME
COMMENTS ON THAT ALL THREE OF
YOU IN TERMS OF WHAT YOU SEEN
IN YOUR LONG PRACTICES AND IN
YOUR OWN AREA. AND WHAT WE
WOULD LIKE TO BRING TO THE FORE
THAT HELP US RING THAT A HAND
BECAUSE IT IS NOT. IT'S NOT
GOING AWAY IT SEEMS TO BE
GETTING WORSE ESPECIALLY WITH
THE US. THE SYNTHETIC OPIOID
FENTANYL BEING LIFESTYLE I'M
KIND OF. IN OUR PUTTING PUTTING
PUT INTO SOME OF THE VERY
IMPORTANT DRUGS THAT HELP WITH
PAIN MANAGEMENT HAS SEVERAL.
SOLO I'D LIKE TO HEAR FROM ALL
OF YOU ON THIS BECAUSE IT'S
BEEN A VERY VERY IMPORTANT
ISSUE FOR ME AND DURING MY
SENATE TOP. TRIM HERE THANK YOU
SENATOR LET'S GO IN THE SAME
ORDER IF THAT'S OKAY- DOCTORS
DOCTOR. GOOD IDEA DO YOU WANT
TO START AND THEN WE'LL GO TO A
DOCTOR MAHMOUD. AND DOCTOR TO
WORK IF YOU WANT TO ANSWER. YES
MARTIN SURE SENT RATES I THINK
IT'S AN EXTRA. OF THIS AND YOU
MANAGE DAHLE THE- OUR- ACTIONS
RETAIN KERR. OF COURSE WE DID
WAS MY AGE THAT THE Q. ARE IS
MANDATE POSITIONS TO SEE A
GREAT DEPRESSION IS GOOD- THE
MEDICARE FROM OUR DAHLE. SO
GREATER MY PRESCRIPTION AND-
AND THEN THE YOU MAY THAT THE
SORT OF THE PROJECT WE
FOLLOWING HUNDRED PLUS PEOPLE
WHO BARBARA GOING TO BE A GOOD
PART ABOUT DAYS. YEAH I WAS
DEPARTMENTS I WAS UNDER WE
CENTER TO OUR. YOUR ARE KNOWN
OF THE ACTUALLY TAKING ACTION
SO HE- WHO DO NOT FOLLOW. IT
MANAGEMENT. TO PAY MANAGE GUIDE
OF WHAT FORMER BY. VICE AREN'T
GOING TO MAKE ALSO SO THERE ARE
GOING TO THE NEW TO FOLLOW. AND
IF YOU LOOK ARE AT BE
PRESCRIPTION DRUG. DOES ARE
INCREASED. RIGHT NOW OUR BUSY
HIS AMERICAN THAT THESE IDEAS
USE. UNFORTUNATELY VERY LOT OF
THROUGH MEXICO THROUGH THE
LEGAL FOR. ELITE FOR HER THIS
CALL THROUGH AND BE DANGER
REGARD THESE. YOU BE TWICE AS
AS MARK ARE COULD BE HAN TIME
AS POWERFUL AND MARK. HALL WAS.
SO SIMPLE FOR TO KNOW ALL BLACK
STRING OFF FROM ILLEGALS
ANOTHER DECADE SO YOU KIND OF
THERE FOR. I THAT I ACT PRESENT
THE BORDER EVEN WITH THE D. THE
CITY HALL THEY CAN HELP US I'M
BACK NEEDS. BURGER STATE AND
LOCAL DOT. WHO WHO WERE
TOGETHER THE TAKE OF THE GIRL
THANK ISSUE BY AS FAR AS THE
FIRST DRUGS I THINK WE ARE THE
RIGHT. WE STILL HAVE A WAYS TO
GO OUR NETWORK WE WILL WE WANT
TO CONTINUE TO GO THERE AND IF
WE NEED ANY IN THE LEGISLATURE
TO ENHANCEMENTS WILL COME TO
YOU. THANK YOU SO MUCH MORE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU AND I SEE
WHAT THE DOCTOR REMOVED WHAT
YOU WANT TO ADD TO THAT AND
THEN DOCTOR DOOR POINT YOU WANT
TO ADD TO THAT THEY WILL. IF
OTHER QUESTIONS COME WE'LL GO
IN REVERS ORDER SO THAT TO US.
SO THAT THE BURDEN DOES NOT
FALL- ON DR GET AN IDEA OF
COMPLETELY SO- DOCTOR MOVE GO
AHEAD. AND IT IS THANK YOU I.
TRULY BELIEVE THIS IS THE MOST
BURNING YOU SHOW NOT IN JUST
CALIFORNIA. IN THE WHOLE
COUNTRY. WHAT YOU'RE SEEING
EVERY DAY IT IS JUST THAT. IS
HEARTENING- BOUTIQUE IS VERY
SERIOUSLY IN LOSS BOARD MEETING
WE INVITED DAY- ONE NATIONAL
FIGURE ON PAIN MANAGEMENT TO
MAKE SURE EVEN OTHER BOARD
MEMBERS. ARE WELL EDUCATED
ABOUT PAIN MANAGEMENT. DOCTOR
GOOD IDEA OF THAT- SAID WELL.
THAT THE PROBLEM IS TWO WAYS
NUMBER ONE IS PRESCRIPTION
DRUGS AND OTHER NONPRESCRIPTION
THE CALLED STREET DRUG WHAT
THIS DISTRICT RUGS- I THINK
GUILDS DAD. SYSTEM WHERE WE CAN
CHECK IS PATIENTS TAKING FROM
WITH MANY HOW MANY OF THE
POSITIONS OF PROVIDERS THAT CAN
MANAGEMENT SO WE CAN KEEP AN
EYE ON THAT. AND DEATH
CERTIFICATE PROGRAM DEFINITELY
HAS GIVEN US- MORE LEEWAY. TO
KEEP A HOLD ON THAT BUT- I
THINK THE PROBLEM IS MUCH
BIGGER THAN JUST THESE COUPLE
OF PROGRAM I THINK WE NEED TO
GET ON BOARD COMMUNITY AND HAVE
SOME EDUCATION PROGRAM AND THE
CHILDREN WERE TRYING TO GET A
DOCTOR THE TOTAL PEOPLE WHO DO
THE PAIN MANAGEMENT. EVEN MORE
AGGRESSIVELY AND I THINK THERE
IS A AND- A IN MANAGEMENT
REQUIREMENT FOR ALL THE
CALIFORNIANS ESPECIALLY PEOPLE
WHO ARE JUST DOING THE PAIN
MANAGEMENT OR ANYTHING ELSE
THEY NEED TO HAVE A MORE
AGGRESSIVE TRAINING. AND THEY
NEED TO PINPOINT THOSE PEOPLE.
AND IN WELL AHEAD OF TIME
BECAUSE- LOT OF PEOPLE WHO GET
ADDICTED. TO THE PAIN
MANAGEMENT OF PAIN DRUGS-
USUALLY ON THE PRESCRIPTION
DRUGS THEY HAVE SOME KIND OF
PROBLEM WE JUST SURGERY OF
FRACTURED OR SOMETHING LIKE
THAT OFF OF THE TO GET ON THAT.
AND ULTIMATELY THEY GOT ON THE
STREET DOT SO I THINK PROBLEM
IS VERY CRITICAL SKILLS IS A
VERY GOOD JOB EXAMPLE DEATH
CERTIFICATE IS REALLY GOING.
COMMUNITY EDUCATION IS REALLY
GOING. TO BE THE ID- TEACHING
ON BOARD. AND ALL OF THE
ORGANIZATION WHO. ARE PLAYING
PARTY COMMITTEE. SHOULD ALSO BE
IN LAW. AND IT SHOULD BE
ADDRESSED ONE OF THE LEAD. BUT
I ALSO TO GATHER WITH
PRESCRIPTION DRUG PROBLEM IS AT
LEAST. BACK TOWARD IF NOT
GETTING WORSE. THANK YOU YOUR
THANK YOU DR THORPE ANYTHING TO
ADD- THE ONLY THING I WOULD ADD
IS THAT WE ARE AS A BOARD WE
ARE ACTUALLY IN THE BOARD
MEETING. TOMORROW FRIDAY IN
PART OF WHAT WE'RE DOING
TOMORROW ON FRIDAYS WERE
ACTUALLY CONSIDERING- UPDATED
SET OF PRESCRIBING GUIDELINES-
ASKING BASS I THINK THE LAST
TIME WE UPDATED THE GUIDELINES
IN TWO THOUSAND FOURTEEN AND SO
WORK- THANK YOU SEE THAT GO
FORWARD. THE BOARD HAS ALSO
TAKEN A- A PROACTIVE STANCE IN
THIS IN THAT. THERE WERE- THERE
WAS. SOME THE BOARD ON. DRUGS
ARE PRESCRIBING AND- HOW TO HOW
TO FACILITATE- THAT COMBINATION
EDUCATE PATIENTS EDUCATING
EDUCATING PHYSICIANS ON. THE
TRY AND PREEMPT AND NOT
CONTINUE TO TURNTHAT THE SHIP
I THINK WE HAVE MADE A LOT OF
PROGRESS- THERE IS SIGNIFICANT
IMPROVEMENT I'M ONE THING WOULD
SAY AS A CAUTION IS THAT. ARE
YOU GUYS TAKING CARE OF A
NUMBER OF PEOPLE WHO ARE IN
PAIN WHO HAVE. BEEN REQUIRING-
COMPLEX APPROACH. BOTH IN THE
ROLE OF CLINIC PRIMARILY THE
ROLE OF BUT ALL IN MY PRIVATE
PRACTICE AND CURRENTLY WERE IN
DANGER OF IT I'LL BE MAKING ITS
SOUL- SO SOCIALLY DISTASTEFUL
FOR THESE PEOPLE TO BE TO GO TO
THE PHARMACY AND CAN PICK UP A
PRESCRIPTION. THAT IS IT WE'RE
WE'RE IN DANGER OF ACTUALLY
HARMING SOME PEOPLE WHO REALLY
HAVE NO OTHER ALTERNATIVES AND-
MEDICATION FOR ANY KIND OF
QUALITY OF LIFE AND BE ABLE TO
DO THEIR ACTIVITIES OF DAILY
LIVING AND FUNCTION AS A
FUNCTIONING ADULT SO I WOULD
JUST SAY THAT YOU KNOW CLEARLY
RUNNING VERY GOOD PASS AYE AYE
MY GOAL IS TO TRY TO. ENSURE
THAT WE ARE- DOING ALL THESE
THINGS TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
WRONG PEOPLE DON'T GET THE
MEDICATIONS. BUT STILL THE
PEOPLE WHO NEED THEM ARE NOT-
THE DISCOURAGED BECAUSE THEY
ARE MEETING UP THESE
CONVOCATIONS. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU ALL ALL OF YOU FOR THE
RESPONSE ON THAT AND CERTAINLY
I TOTALLY AGREE DOCTOR FOR WE
NEED A BALANCE BECAUSE PAIN
MANAGEMENT IS STILL VERY
IMPORTANT TO QUALITY OF LIFE
ABSOLUTELY THAT PEOPLE WHO NEED
THAT CANNOT CERTAINLY GET IT IS
JUST KEEPING IT IN THE RIGHT
HANDS AND THE PEOPLE WHO ARE
PERHAPS OVERPRESCRIBING FOR THE
WRONG REASONS AND THEY GET
BETTER EDUCATION SO THAT SOME
VERY GOOD NEWS THAT YOU HAVE A
NEW SET OF GUIDELINES AND WHEN
YOU CAN SHARE A LITTLE SIDE. I
WOULD LIKE TO SEE SOME OF THOSE
BECAUSE WE HAVE A SIMILAR
LEGISLATION COMING THROUGH AND
IF YOU HAVE IDEAS THAT MIGHT
HELP US RATHER THAN REGULATION
I MEAN LEGISLATION MAYBE I
DON'T THINK WITH SOME OF THE
REGULATIONS- WOULD BE VERY
HELPFUL BUT THANKS AGAIN AND
I'LL I'LL I'LL TURN IT OVER TO
MY COLLEAGUES BUT TO ALL OF YOU
LIKE AGAIN I'LL CONGRATULATE
YOU AND THANK YOU GREAT
APPRECIATION FOR STEPPING FOR.
ONBOARD BEHIND NOT AN EASY
SERVICE YOU KNOW THAT YOU HAVE
A LOT OF THE CHALLENGES AND
CERTAINLY ARE YOU PEOPLE
LETTING YOU AND PEOPLE SOME
LIKE SOME DON'T LIKE YOU VERY
MUCH THAT TRUMP THE OUTSIDE
PART OF THE JOB SO THANK YOU
AGAIN AND I WILL BE SUPPORTING
YOUNG OP YOU WERE. APPOINTMENTS
THANK YOU THANK YOU SENATOR
BATES I'M GONNA START WITH YOU
MR MAJORITY LEADER. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR ON. I WOULD AGREE
WITH MICHAEL- CENTER SAYING
IT'S NOT A EASY SIR LIFE YOU
ALL FOR- YOU WILLING JUST TO
STEP UP IN. A DOCTOR THORPE BY
INSPIRED BY YOUR COMMENT THAT
YOU LOVE BEING A DOCTOR. IT'S A
GOOD THING. WE'RE IN A
SITUATION WHERE YOU KNOW IN
CALIFORNIA IN THIS GREAT STATE
OF CALIFORNIA THERE'S ONLY A
HANDFUL OF US. THAT ARE ELECTED
TO CREATE THE LEGISLATURE IN A
SMALLER HANDFUL WHICH IN THE
EXECUTIVE BRANCH OF THE
CONSTITUTIONAL OFFICERS SO IN
ORDER TO RUN THIS GREAT STATE.
WE DELEGATE RESPONSIBILITY
WE'VE COME UP WITH A WAY TO
DELEGATE RESPONSIBILITY TO
FOLKS WHO WILL STEP UP. AND
FALLEN MOST INSTANCES LIKE YOU
ARE SUBSTANTIALLY VOLUNTEERING
YOUR TIME TO HELP US. TO HAVE
HAVE A LAYER BETWEEN. THE
GOVERNMENT AND- AND A GROUP OF
FOLKS THAT ARE EXPERTS THE
GREAT CHALLENGE THAT WE FACE
WITH RESPECT THE DEPARTMENT
CONSUMER AFFAIRS. AND THE
CHALLENGE THAT WE FACE WITH
YOUR BOARD AND WHETHER IT'S-
ARCHITECTURE PHARMACISTS OR
WHATEVER. IT IS THAT- WE WERE
TRYING TO AS WAS INDICATED- TO
OFFER SOME LEVEL OF CONSUMER
PROTECTION. THERE'S A TENSION
THAT EXISTS BETWEEN GETTING THE
EXPERTISE ON THE ONE HAND EACH
OF YOUR EXPERTS IN YOUR FIELD.
AND THE BALANCE WHERE IT'S NOT
PROTECTIONISM OF THE INDUSTRY
OR THE PROFESSION AND HAS A
LEVEL OF SENSITIVITY. TO THE
CONSUMERS. AND SO THE REASON I
THINK THAT SENATOR BATES TALKED
ABOUT HER IT'S NOT EASY SERVE
BECAUSE IN THIS AREA OF PUBLIC
POLICY IS QUITE DIFFICULT. I
HAVE A COUPLE OF QUESTIONS IN
THAT REGARD. KERN IN TERMS OF
PROTECTING CONSUMERS. AS WE DO
WITH THAT DELICATE BALANCE
WHICH IS SO IMPORTANT TO US
WHICH ARE JUST A HANDFUL OF
ELECTED FOLKS. WHO ARE THE ONES
WHO ARE ULTIMATELY RESPONSIBLE
TO THE PUBLIC- AND WE DELEGATE
THAT AUTHORITY YOU. AND I WANNA
START WITH A- DOCTOR. UGH GOING
INTO THAT DAY HAVE- WHO'S BEEN
ON THE BOARD FOR TEN YEARS. I'M
INFORMED. THAT THE AVERAGE.
TIME FROM THE RECIPIENT OF A
COMPLAINT. FROM A DOCTOR
THROUGH THE INVESTIGATION TO
THE ISSUANCE OF FORMAL
DISCIPLINE. IS NINE HUNDRED
DAYS. THE UNDERSTAND THEIR
SERIES OF EXCUSES AND PROCESS
SEASON COMPLEXITIES I SERVED ON
THE BOARD OF PHARMACY SOME
THIRTY FIVE YEARS AGO. YOU HAVE
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL WILL
DETERMINE GENERAL'S A LAWYER
AND I UNDERSTAND SOME OF THOSE
CHALLENGES. BUT HERE YOU BEEN
ON THIS BOARD FOR TEN YEARS
SAID YOUR TESTIMONY. AND I
WANNA GET YOUR THOUGHTS AS TO
WHY THAT'S THE CASE THIS
CERTAINLY IS A SAID YOU IN THE
INTERVIEW HAVING A PATIENT
WAITING IN YOUR WAITING ROOM
FOR NINE- DAYS WOULD NOT BE
DEEMED AS SATISFACTORY
EXPERIENCE. WE NEED TO HAVE
TRUST IN THE GOVERNMENT WE NEED
TO HAVE THE PUBLIC HAVE TRUST
IN OUR PROCESS AND WHEN
SOMETHING TAKES SO LONG IT
CERTAINLY RAISES THE QUESTION
ABOUT WHAT'S GOING ON SO
QUESTION IS YOUR THOUGHTS ABOUT
WHAT'S GONE BEFORE. AND ALSO IF
YOU SEE ANY ROAD MAPS FORWARD
TO SHORTEN THAT TIME SO WE CAN
BE MORE RESPECTFUL TO N. AND
RESPONSIVE. TO THE PEOPLE THAT
WE ALL REPRESENT. SO THAT WORK
TO THE DOCTOR GOING ON AT. THE
GENERAL YEAH BY. YEAH HE'S BEEN.
FOR HIS ORDERS FOR VERY I AGREE
YOUR DAD I GIVEN LIKE MY
CHRISTIAN GREY MY VERY RULES
NINE. A CREATED BY STEVE
SOMEBODY JUST THEY CAN BE BE
SEEN. SO YOU USE ON A ON THERE
ARE NOW EVEN THOUGH ARE NOT
GROWN UP ALL THE SNOW 470% THE
COMPANY THAT WITHIN BODIES ALL
WITHIN. ONE YEAR. I KNOW YOU
YOU. COMPLY AND LEGAL CASE THE
PERSON OF CASES FROM. SIXTY
SEVENTEEN SO. EIGHTEEN NINETY
SIX FOR FEW DAYS 18% COOPER.
EARNED SEVENTY NAY IT'S FIVE
POINT. EIGHT FOR. I'M BEATING
EASTERN NINE PERSON SO DO HAVE
A FROM- LIKE. NOT NINE HUNDRED
DAYS BUT- IT'S COMPLEX FRAUD-
WILL FROM THE MANY COMES. TO H.
Q. YOU DID YOU SAW. COULD BE
OPERATED SO TURNING THIS- THE-
I KNOW I SHOULD LARGER THEIR
MARKET. SO FOR EXAMPLE PROCESS
WHICH GO THROUGH AND WE ARE.
GOING TO LOOKING HOW DO YOU
IMPROVE. THIS YOU BE LOOKING
BACK TO WHEREAS SO THINGS- TO
MAKE THE PROCESS AGENTS ONE OF
WE. BURGER BAKER AS AND-
BEDROOM AND WILL YOU BETWEEN
EXTREME ON MY OR SO THAT CAN
MOVE. ATTRIBUTES HI LEVEL THE
FUN FOR. ALL AND GO- DO YOU FOR
AND THE HE AND PHYSICIAN DOES
NOT. ADDRESS FOR TO THE MEDICAL
RIGHT IN TIME AND THOUSAND.
THOUSAND PER DAY FOR ALL TO TEN
DOLLARS ALSO ASKING THE COST
REIMBURSEMENT SO THERE IS A
COST REIMBURSEMENT THE
ATTORNEYS DON'T. TO REALLY TAKE
THESE CASES SO WE'RE ASKING A
LOT OF THINGS WE NEED YOUR
HELP. OUR GOAL IS TO SHORTEN
YOUR. AS AS MUCH AS POSSIBLE.
THANK YOU SIR A MANAGER FORMER
CO PLAY YEAH WAS GOING TO ASK
THE ISSUE BUT THE OPEN BUT I
THINK THAT'S PROPERLY ANSWERED
I THIS IS BASE. FOR BUT THIS IS
TOO DARK THORPE. A TOOTH. SO
CALIFORNIA. BUREAU'S OF THAT
LATINO AND AFRICAN AMERICAN
DOCTORS ARE MORE LIKELY TO HAVE
COMPLAINTS INVESTIGATIONS AND
DISCIPLINARY ACTIONS AGAINST
THEM. HOW ARE YOU OR HOW'S THE
BOARD. ENSURING THAT AFRICAN
AMERICAN AND LATINO DOCTORS ARE
NOT BEING UNAIRLY PUNISHED IN
THIS PROCESS AND I KNOW. THE
DISTANCE IN THE BILL IMPLICIT
BIAS TRAINING IT WAS REFERENCE
TO THE QUESTION. BUT IF YOU CAN
DRILL A LITTLE DEEPER ON THAT
TO BE ABLE TO GIVE US
CONFIDENCE. THAT THE PROCESS IS
FAIR. THANK YOU DOCTOR. THANK
YOUCENTERS WERE. YES BEEN ON
THE BOARD FOR- EIGHTEEN MONTHS
IT SEEMS SHORTER THAN THAT
SOMEHOW BUT- THAT'S WHAT IT'S
ABOUT. AND YOU KNOW IS PART OF
THAT INITIATION PART OF THAT-
TRAINING TO BE ON THE BOARD-
IMPLICIT BIAS TRAINING WAS PART
OF THAT- BEFORE. YOU KNOW
BEFORE WE COULD PROCEED WITH
THE- THE OLD RECALL OF COURSE-
WE GOT A BAD COLD IDEA OF BOARD
TRAINING ON IMPLICIT BIAS
OCCURRED BECAUSE OF THE
PRESIDENT THE EAGLES STATE
MEDICAL ASSOCIATION EIGHT
ASSOCIATION OF. PHYSICIANS OF
COLOR- CAME TO US AND SAID LOOK
THERE'S A WE'RE CONCERNED ABOUT
THIS AND WE LISTEN TO HER AND
WE DON'T HAVE. TAKEN OUT A
COUPLE OF THINGS THAT WOULD BE
A CLUE TO THE REVIEWERS AS TO
WHAT THE BACKGROUND OF THE
PHYSICIAN IS- SUCH AS THEIR WE
DON'T LIST OF PEOPLE SCHOOL
ANYMORE OR THE TRAINING
PROGRAMS OF THE WARRANT BEFORE
OR DID THE TRADE PROGRAMS THEY
WORK THE CDVA. PART THANKS SO I
THINK THE A- THE OF PEOPLE
THERE ARE THE BOARD. CURRENTLY
ARE. FOCUSED ON THE IDEA OF.
EQUANIMITY AND EQUALITY IN
TERMS OF NOT DISADVANTAGING ANY.
ANYONE FOR THAT MATTER TO YOU
WHETHER IT'S PHYSICIAN OR
PATIENT FOR THAT MATTER BUT- I
THINK THERE IS- YOU KNOW
THERE'S ALWAYS MORE WE CAN DO
OF COURSE- BUT CERTAINLY WE
WANT TO BE OPEN TO ANY ANY
OPPORTUNITIES WE HAVE BUT I DO
BELIEVE THAT THE THAT THERE IS
A REAL FOCUS ON ON TRYING TO.
ENSURE THAT- DECISIONS OF COLOR
NOT ON. OUR INAPPROPRIATE LEAD-
DISCIPLINED THANK YOU SO MUCH.
IS THAT ALL ARE YOU SURE OKAY
BUT A LITTLE OKAY WE WOMEN
WOMEN RE DIRECT AFTER MR VICE
CHAIRMAN. THANK YOU MAYOR PRO
TEM AND I WANT TO COMMEND YOU
SENATOR HERTZBERG HAS QUITE
ELOQUENT. LAYING OUT JUST HOW
DIFFICULT THESE JOBS ARE- SO WE
WANT TO CONGRATULATE ALL THREE
OF YOU ON YOUR APPOINTMENT- I
JUST I JUST I HAVE ACTUALLY A
FEW QUESTIONS SO- BACK IN
DECEMBER AND IT IS VERY
DIFFICULT. ZOOM CALL WITH THE
COUPLE FROM MY DISTRICT WHO
LOST A CHILD AND ULTIMATELY
ENDED UP FILING A COMPLAINT
WITH THE WITH THE MEDICAL BOARD
NO NO I CAN GO TO A LOT OF
DETAILS HERE BECAUSE I KNOW
LATER IN THIS YEAR WE'RE HAVING
SUNSET REVIEW THE MEDICAL BOARD
MAYBE- I WILL DO IT AT THAT
TIME. BUT I DO WANT TO RAISE A
NUMBER OF. QUESTIONS AND BASED
UPON THAT CONVERSATION AND LIKE
TO GET YOUR GUISES RESPONSE.
THE FIRST ONE HOW CAN THE BOARD
IMPROVE THE COMPLAINT PROCESS
TO ALLOW FOR REAL TIME STATUS
UPDATES OF THE COMPLAINT. AND
PROVIDE A PRIMARY CONTACT ALONG
WITH CONTACT INFORMATION. I
DON'T I DON'T SEE A WHOEVER
WANTS TO. I DON'T MIND HERE
FROM ALL THREE TO BE HONEST
WITH YOU BUT YOU KNOW I KNOW
THIS TIME TIME CONCERNED SO
MAYBE. ONE OF YOU TAKE THAT ONE
WOULD BE GREAT MISTER MAHMOUD
LOOKS LIKE HE'S- RECORD ONE
BECAUSE I DON'T OF WORK OUT OF
THEM OTHER THINGS- THAT IS A
REAL CONCERN THAT'S WHAT I SAID
IN MY OPENING STATEMENT TO AND
THAT IS. FOLLOWED RELAUNCH
CONCERN ON THE BEHALF OF THE
MONTH. AND WE NEED TO DO MORE
WORK ALTHOUGH WE HAVE AN
IMPROVING. EDUCATE PEOPLE
EDUCATE CONSUMERS CALIFORNIANS.
IF THERE'S A PROBLEM IF THERE'S
AN ISSUE HOW QUICKLY THEY CAN
REACH. OUT TO BOARD. AND THIS
SHOULDBE IN THE SYSTEM I THINK
IS A SYSTEM IN PLACE BUT I
THINK RESPONSE TIMES SLOWER.
HOW QUICKLY BOARD CAN WORK ON
THAT COMPLAIN OF RIGHT THIS
SHOULD BE A TIME LIMIT. THAT
BOARD GET BACK FOR THE FAMILY.
UNEXPECTED THE CONSUMER. HARPER
THAT NUMBER IS. AND THAT THE
SHOULD HAVE READ YOU MENTION
YOU'RE PROFITABLY LIVE UP IT
MEANS THAT ON A WEEKLY ON A- BI
WEEKLY BASIS GIVEN THE UPDATE
WHAT IS HAPPENING WHEN WE GOT.
THAT WOULD NOT ONLY SATISFY THE
CONSUMER THAT IS ALSO IS GOING
TO INCREASE THE TRUST IN THE
CONSUMER YES THE SYSTEM IS
WORKING PEOPLE ARE WORKING AND
ARE ALSO ALERTED THE BOARD
MEMBERS. AND THEY WILL KEEP AN
EYE ON THE THING YES AND ALSO
STAFF OF THE BOARD I THINK STEP
INSTRUMENT AS A VITAL TO
CONSTITUTIONAL BOARDING GREAT
BUT DO NEED TO STAY ON ALERT
OKAY YOU'LL BE LOOKING SYSTEM
WE GOT IMPORTANT SOMEBODY'S-
BROTHER SISTER MOTHER FATHER
SON OR DAUGHTER OF A NEIGHBOR.
HAD JUST MISSED HAVE HAPPENED
AND WE'RE NOT GETTING AND IF WE
WILL WAIT FOR MONTHS AND YEARS.
SOMEBODY MIGHT HAVE A SEAT
ANSWER SO WE NEED TO REALLY GET
MORE RELAXED AND- MEANS THERE
SHOULD BE NO TIME FOR YOUR SET
ON BACK AND- MY PLAN IS TO. AND
REALLY IT JUST MEETING OUR NEXT
MEETING OF THE BOARD TO MOVEUP
THIS THING AND I HAVE SOME
HOMEWORK DONE AND- IT- BEING
ILLEGAL A- SAN. PROCESS IN BURN
SO. PEOPLE HAVE TRUST IN BOOK.
THANK YOU. FOR YOUR COMMENTS
WILL TO ON ON THE- YOU KNOW
THAT THE- IS VERY TO THE
PROCESS IS SO. THERE'S A LOT OF
THINGS THAT THE MEDICAL BOARD
STAFF DON'T HAVE ANY CONTROL
OVER- THEY DON'T REALLY HAVE
ANY CONTROL OR ANY UPDATES FROM
EACH YOU ARE YOU WHO'S DOING
THE INVESTIGATION THEY THEY
DON'T ALWAYS HAVE UP TODAY
REPORTS ON WHAT. THE THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL'S OFFICE IS
DOING- IF IT GOES TO THE
MINISTRY OF LAW JUDGE THEN
THAT'S EVEN MORE SO. EVEN
THOUGH WE WERE WE CAN BE VERY
TRANSPARENT ABOUT UPDATING FROM
OUR STAFF AND HAVING A CONTACT
PERSON THE STAFF TO UPDATE. THE
COMPLAINT. IT IT MADE BE VERY.
BECAUSE A LOT OF WE DON'T WE
DON'T KNOW OURSELVES WHAT'S
HAPPENING WITH THAT COMPLAINT
AND WOULD HAVE TO. YOU KNOW SO
WE I THINK BUILDING IN ABOUT
MORE INTEGRATED- WORKING
RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN THESE
DEPARTMENTS AT THE MEDICAL
BOARD DEPENDS ON. BUT DOESN'T
REALLY HAVE ANY ADMINISTRATIVE
CONTROL OVER ISN'T IT A
SIGNIFICANT PART OF
STREAMLINING THIS PROCESS. AND
THAT MAY BE TRUE BUT I THINK
EVEN GETTING BACK TO THE FAMILY
SAYING WE DON'T HAVE AN UPDATE
THIS WEEK I THINK I THINK WOULD
BE HELPFUL IN TERMS OF-
BUILDING CONFIDENCE AND TRUST.
SO THIS IS FOR DOCTOR COULD NOT
ADD- WANT TO FOLLOW UP ON- WANT
TO SENATOR HERTZBERG'S QUESTION
SO- HE ASKED YOU ABOUT THE TIME
LINE AND I FEEL LIKE YOU'VE
YOU'VE ANSWERED THAT. SO IN
TERMS OF COMMUNICATIONS FOR THE
INVESTIGATIONS- THE COUPLE THAT.
I MET WITH- THERE V. VICTIMS
THIS AND THEY WERE NEVER
INTERVIEWED AT ALL REGARDING
THE SUBMITTAL THE COMPLAINT. IS
THAT IS THAT STANDARD PROCEDURE
NOT YET DOT INTERVIEW THOSE AT
A FILE AND IT AND IF AND IF SO
WHY- THANK YOU FOR ASKING- NO
IT'S NOT STANDARD PROCEDURE
ACTUALLY THE STAFF
INVESTIGATORS. DURING AN
INTERVIEW I'M NOT SURE WHAT
HAPPENED HERE I THINK WE COULD
TO ASK. BY THREE BILLION
TRIVIAL- AT THE FAMILIES AND
ALSO ON B. AND B. UPDATES
THAT'S ONE OF THE THINGS WE'RE
ASKING IN THIS SUNSET THERE. WE
GET THIS CONTINUOUS- UPDATES
FROM THE H. DELAY YOU'LL HAS
BEEN DISTRIBUTION IS GOING ON
SO THAT THEY MAHLER STAFF CAN
INFORM THE FAMILIES THERE TO
GAYS SO. OUR GOAL IS TO KEEP
EVERYBODY INFORMED AND
ABSOLUTELY IT'S NOT ANY THERE
IS NO PLACE. AND SOMEBODY
SUFFERS- FOR THE STAFF NOT
CONTRIBUTED. FAMILY MEMBERS.
OKAY THANK YOU THEN I FRONT OF-
I DON'T THINK TAKE A LONG SAID
I DO LIKE TO HEAR FROM FROM ALL
THREE OF. SO TO THOUSAND A- THE
LEAD PASS THE PACE RIGHT TO
KNOW ACT WHICH REQUIRED THE
BOARD TO ADD A PART TO A
PROBATION SALARY TO THE PROFILE
PAGES OF PHYSICIANS ON
PROBATION FOR ACTS OF SERIOUS
MISCONDUCT IN YOUR OPINION TO
THOSE ADDITION DO THOSE
ADDITIONAL EFFORTS NEED TO BE
MADE. TO ADDITIONAL EFFORTS
NEED TO BE MADE TO ENSURE
PATIENTS ARE AWARE OF PHYSICIAN
MISCONDUCT OR DISCIPLINARY
ACTION I EAT USE OF A NON
DISCLOSURE AGREEMENT I
APPRECIATE- BRIEF ANSWERS FROM
ALL THREE OF YOU THANK YOU DR
THORPE WHY DON'T YOU START AND
THEN WE'LL GO TO A DOCTOR CAN
ON INDIA OF AND THEN-
DOCUMENTED. THANK YOU- YES WE
CAN OKAY- YEAH I THINK THOSE
THOSE ARE BRINGING THAT
REGULATION THAT THAT
REQUIREMENT- IT IS EXTREMELY
IMPORTANT- I BELIEVE THOSE WERE.
SPECIALLY DESIGNED FOR PEOPLE
WHO FOR PHYSICIANS WHO WERE
INVOLVED IN ANY KIND OF SEXUAL
MISCONDUCT OR WERE USING ANY
KIND OF- SOLUTIONS AN
INAPPROPRIATELY- IT IS
PHYSICALLY IN THOSE CASES WERE
THESE WERE THOUGHT IT FELT TO
BE SIGNIFICANT POTENTIAL HARM
FOR PATIENTS. IF THEY WISH THEY
WOULD HAVE KNOWN THAT THEY
MIGHT THEY WOULD CERTAINLY
CHOSE ANOTHER DOCTOR- I THANK I
DO. YOU KNOW I UNDERSTAND WHERE
YOU'RE COMING FROM WITH THIS HI
I AM A LITTLE BIT CONCERNED
ABOUT THE UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES OF. REQUIRING
EVERY PROBATIONARY DR TO BE
COMMITTED TO THE AFTER DEATH
DISCLOSE ACT TO THEIR- TO THEIR
PATIENTS NOT THAT I HATE NOT
THE PATIENT SHOULD HAVE THE
ACCESS THEY DO IF THEY GO ON
THE MEDICAL MORE WEBSITE THAT'S
CLEARLY OUTLINED IN THE MEDICAL
OR WEBSITE- BUT UP FRONT WHEN
SOMEBODY IS- ACTUALLY
ESTABLISHING A RELATIONSHIP
WITH YOU. IT IS VERY CHILLING.
WHO TO SOME PEOPLE- TO SEE WHAT
WHAT'S WHAT'S GOING ON WATER
WHAT'S YOUR PROBATION ABOUT I'M
NOT SAYING THAT IT'S NOT A- BAD
IDEA THAT SHOULD BE CONSIDERED
WHAT I AM SAYING I THINK WE'VE
GOT TO BE AREFUL ABOUT. WHAT
THE CONSEQUENCES MIGHT BE OF
DOING THAT. AND THANK YOU.
THEY'RE GETTING MORE AND THE
OTHER TWO. AND THEN I'M DONE AT
THAT POINT IN APPROACH AND
THAT'S FINE DR YES GO AHEAD-
THANK YOU FOR REAL SO WE
ACTUALLY WE WORKED QUITE GOOD
BASED ON NATION'S NOTIFICATION
FROM THE PROBATIONARY POSITION
STATE SENATOR HILL AND THE
ASSEMBLY HERE AND HE DID REALLY
COME OFF THE. DISTRIBUTION
WHICH IS. THE GROUP TRANCERS
ACTUALLY DOCTOR TO GET THEM ON
ALL ORDERS TELL THEM WHAT OF
ALL. FOR THE REST OF THE
PROGRAM IS ALREADY ON LIST. AND
READ THE ORDER. WHICH VERSION
CAN GET A- VACANCY THE DOCTORS
RIGHT THERE WE ARE GOING CAN GO
VISION ACTUALLY ELEGANT. DURING
THE DOWNLOAD THE APP ON GOOGLE
CURRENCY. AFTER ADEQUATE
SENATOR BOB CORKER FOR A
PERMANENT HAVE PROBATION FOR
REALLY DRY GO UNDER THE
INFLUENCE DIED. BUT YOU'RE NOT
GOING TO DO WITH FISHING GEAR
BURKE HAD THAT SO FAR BACK IN
THE SEEN SO. VERY. IT'S ALWAYS
LITTLE BOY WONDER WE AS WE NEED
TO MORE WILL COME TO YOU. I
THINK THE IS THE IDEA IS THE
BIG AT YOU AWARD TO. AS FAR AS
IT IS CALLED THIS IS ONLY BOTH
THE KIND. WHICH HAS THAT RARE
VERY DOC SUFFERS DEGREE OFTEN.
ON HAVE TO. IMPOSE NOT IN THE
RIGHT NOT YOU PASSION CRITICAL
TO SEE THE- OUR THERE ARE YEAH.
I THEY'RE WIDELY ON. THANK YOU.
YES I THINK THE LOWER IS THAT
AIM TOOL WORK ON. ONLY A THINK
ABOUT THIRTEEN HOUSING A
SEVENTY THOUSAND IN THE END IF
HAVE DOWNLOADED GAS FOG SO OF
FIFTY TO SEVENTY POLITICS ARE
OF FORTY MILLION PEOPLE IN THE
SMALL SO WE NEED TO MORE PEOPLE
MAYBE IN A DOCTOR'S OFFICE
WHICH OR SOMETHING THAT OKAY
THERE'S MOBILE APP AVAILABLE
CAN GET THE INFO NOT OF PEOPLE
DON'T TO COME TO A LOT OF
PEOPLE DON'T KNOW TO. BUT IN
EVERY HAS ONE NOW SO THEY CAN
GET FROM THE MOBILE APP AND
THAT WOULD BE LOT EASIER TO BE
FISHING IS DRIVING A FINDING A
NEW DOCTOR THEY CAN GET ALL THE
ACCESS AND- CALIFORNIA IS ON
THE FOREFRONT TO MAKE OR WHY
DOES WHO ARE COMMITTING BIGGER
CRIMES. LIKE SEXUAL HARASSMENT
LIKE. IT'S JUST NEWS. AND DOES
WHO. IN SOME VIDEO THAT'S- DATA
NOT SUPPOSED TO. NOTIFY THE
THAT. AND- I EVERYTHING IS ON
THE ROPES- IF BAY IF THAT CAN
PROMOTED- THEN WE CAN TO THE
NEXT STEP THE BOB NORTHEAST BE
DONE I AM A PLUG TRUSTED.
EVERYBODY WHO WANTS TO COME SEE
A DOCTOR HONESTLY THAT IS THE
MOST SEGREGATION STRIP AND
PATIENTS SHOULD KNOW EVERYTHING
ABOUT DR NOT ABOUT HIS PRIVATE
LIFE BUT ABOUT WHAT HE'S DOING
PROFESSIONALLY AND WHAT HE HAD
DONE IN THE PAST AND BECAUSE
THEY HAVE A LIFE AND DEATH.
HELLO MY NAME DENIS THEY HAVE
ALL THE RIGHT TO GO OVER THERE
AND I'M FIVE EIGHT IT. WAS THAT
WE CAN ACHIEVE WE CAN WE WANT
THE NEXT STEP BUT IF WE CAN
ACHIEVE THE ONE WHICH IS VERY
EASY YOU WANT THE MORE DETAILS
I THINK WOULD BE HARDER THE
FIRST ONE THE ONE WHICH WHEN
YOU TRY TO PUSH AND- ASSEMBLY
GRAHAM EVERY SHARE ANSWER THANK
YOU ALL FOR YOUR WILLINGNESS TO
SERVE AND TAKING THAT APPROACH
AND FOR THE OPPORTUNITY. THANK.
YOU VERY MUCH- CENTER LAYERED.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MA'AM
CHAIR. AND THANK TO THE THREE.
FOR BEING TODAY AND WILLING TO
SERVE. WE HAVE IN FRONT OF A
THREE VACANCIES TODAY AND
THEY'RE ALL AND PHYSICIAN
CATEGORIES. AND THEN THERE ARE
THREE ACTUAL VACNCIES AND
THEY'RE ALL OF THE PUBLIC
CATEGORY AND I JUST WANT TO
NOTE THAT THE GOVERNOR FIELD
ONE OF FROM YESTERDAY AT AND
THAT'S GREAT PROGRESS AND JUST
WE SHOULD ACKNOWLEDGE THAT
EVERYBODY HAS THEIR ROLE
PLIGHT. OF BASED ON THEIR
CATEGORY BUT I THINK MY
COLLEAGUES HAVE DONE A GREAT
JOB AT THE GRANULAR LEVEL
WHETHER IT'S OPIOIDS OR
DIVERSITY. OR RESPONSE TIME AND
I THINK I WOULD LIKE O ASK
EACH OF YOU A MORE GLOBAL
QUESTION THAT PULLS IT ALL
TOGETHER WHICH IS THAT I THINK
THERE'S THE CONCERN. THAT THE
MEDICAL BOARD HAS TO BE AN
HONEST BROKER THAT IS NOT
CAPTURED IN SOME WAY BY THE
INDUSTRY. AND SO HOW WOULD EACH
OF YOU SPEAK TO THAT CONCERN
AND HOW YOU WOULD ARGUE THAT
THAT'S NOT THE CASE WITH REGARD
TO YOUR SERVICE TO YOUR
POTENTIAL SERVICE AND I DON'T
I'M SORRY MADAM CHAIR I DON'T
KNOW WHAT ORDER WILL GO AGAIN
RIGHT NOW DR THORPE DO YOU WANT
TO. GO AHEAD AND START AND THEN
WE'LL GO TO DR- AGAIN. IDEA OF
AND DOCTOR MOVE. THANK YOU
MATTER- I WOULD SAY THAT THE
NEW YORK A I HEALTH HAD ON YOU
KNOW TO MY CAREER I'VE BEEN
ACTIVE IN THE CALIFORNIA
MEDICAL ASSOCIATION IS LOW I
I'M I'M PROUD OF MY CAREER
THERE I'VE DONE IT I'VE DONE A
GREAT JOB IN MANY WAYS THEY'RE
PROMOTING PATIENT SAFETY IN
THAT. POSITION AS WELL BUT I
THE IDEA THAT SOMEHOW. I AM NOW
A WHOLE- FOREVER YOU KNOW KIND
OF. UNDER THE INFLUENCE OF THE
CALIFORNIA MEDICAL ASSOCIATION.
IS NOT- NOT TRUE HEY DON'T TALK
TO THEM REGULARLY AND THEY
DON'T TALK TO ME REGULARLY. AND
MY HE- MY ROLE IS AS AN
ADVOCATE FOR CONSUMERS IT IS
REALLY TIED WITH MY ROLE AS A
PRIMARY CARE DOCTOR. AND MY
ETHICS AS A PRIMARY CARE DOCTOR
IS NOT MY HAY. IS NOT BECAUSE
I'M JUST EIGHTY YOU KNOW I I'M
A- I'M A DOCTOR I'M GONNA- I
MEAN I'VE BEEN INVOLVED IN. IN
HOSPITAL PEER REVIEW SINCE THE
TIME I ARE HERE IN FOR THE LAST
THREE EIGHT YEARS PROBABLY
AFTER WAS APPOINTED THE MEDICAL
STAFF. HAVE BEEN INVOLVED IN
DIFFICULT CONVERSATIONS WITH
DOCTORS FROM FROM THAT TIME ON
ALL THE WAY THROUGH TO TODAY AS.
A LEADER- MEDICAL GROUP AS A-
MEDICAL DIRECTOR ROLE HEALTH
CLINIC THERE ARE. THAT ARISE.
AND YES EVEN CMA THEIR PROBLEMS
ARISE AND HAVING THOSE
CONVERSATIONS WAS. ORDERED
SOMETIME SOON VERY DIFFICULT.
SO THERE'S A DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN. LOBBYING FOR A BILL
AND ACTUALLY ADVOCATING FOR
CONSUMERS. TODAY AND THUS WHERE
I WOULD SEE THE DIFFERENCES I.
I CAN TELL YOU THAT MY AGE MY
FOCUS IS ON SERVING THE MEDICAL
WARD. AND ITS ITS PRIORITIES
AND CONSUMER PROTECTION. AND I
AM NOT ASHAMED OF THAT EITHER
I'M. HAPPY TO BE ABLE TO DO
THAT. THANK YOU THANK YOU.
DOCTOR GOING ON A DEATH- THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR ARE YOU ARE
GOING TO LOG. THANKS IN LIFE-
AS I MENTIONED ACTED MY ENTIRE
CAREER WAS SPENT ARE YOU COUNTY
HOSPITAL. ZERO TRAINING
DOCTORS- I WAS EVEN I EVEN TOOK
ON TO CREATE A AND B. MEDICAL
SCHOOL OR BY RAISING FUNDS
NEVER TOOK A SALARY FOR ME
YEAH. MY THING IS THIS MY
COMMUNITY HAS BEEN SO GOOD TO
ME I'M JUST. WATCHING YOUR BACK
BUT AGAIN. AND THE- MY ROLES IN
THE RIVER IS CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OR NATIONAL LEVEL
IT IS ALL OF THE ADDED VALUE.
TO THE BEST POSSIBLE HEALTHCARE
WHEN I TOOK THE OLD ON THE
MEDICAL BOARD MY JOB WAS NOT TO
SEE. NOCTURIA IN MAY NOT TO MY
HOSPITAL NOT TO MY GROUP ARE
NOT TODAY DOCTORS MY JOB IS
ACTUALLY. TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
DOCTORS ARE NOT AWAITING
HIGHEST QUALITY OF CARE ARE YOU
THERE ARE DISCIPLINE ARE YOU
HAVE A DATE HERE THANKS FOR THE
THANKS THAT'S WHAT THE MEDIA
AND PROVIDES THE BEST POSSIBLE
CARE FOR CALIFORNIA CONSUMERS
SAW I ABSOLUTELY HAVE NO
PROBLEM. I KNOW SOMEONE BECAUSE
ADVOCATES MIGHT HAVE A PROBLEM
THEY THINK IT IS WORK I DON'T
BECAUSE I'VE DONE MULTIPLE
ROLES BY DOCTOR BURKE MENTIONED
AS CHIEF OF SURGERY I THINK OF
MANY OF THE- PEOPLE ARE YOUR
MANAGER ACTUALLY- DAHLE GLIDE
CORNER POINT DON'T THEY'RE
GOING TO GET SCARED. I WAS A
TRAINER- OF DOCTORS WERE DON'T
DO THEM THERE DO IS THE
MISTAKES THAT ARE MAKING
CHARACTER BECAUSE BE THE
PROGRAM. THERE GONNA HAVE AN
ISSUE BURKE MARBLE RESTORED
BEST POSSIBLE CURE FOR DAYS-
THE ARE SAID TO HAVE COMES.
THANK. THANK YOU DR MAHMOUD. SO
MY NAMEON CERTAIN GET INTO MY
YOU TO YEARS OFF MEDIC PRACTICE
IN CALFORNIA. A LITTLE BIT
PRACTITIONER I HAVE NEVER
CHARGE DIVISION WHO DID NOT
HAVE ANY. A NUMBER ISN'T.
BECAUSE I BELIEVE HELPING KEEP.
I GO. IS TO FOR. THAN JUST
SITTING THE OFFICE A HOST.
HELPING THEM TO GET SOME TIME
TO ME THAT COMPANIES ARE NOT
AUTHORIZED TO I HAVE HAD
SEVERAL FIVE WITH SOME OF THE
IDEA. I HAVE BEEN SO TIMES
OFFERED TO ON BOARD OF THAT
SOME THE NIGHT AND I TURNED.
BUT ALREADY- MIGHT. LIE PASSION
A TO HELP. WHATEVER READ IT
WOULD HAVE MY GOAL IS TO HELP
YOU RATHER I'M DOING DISTINCT
THAN OUR CHIEF OF STOPPING
HOUSE. AND ARE FEDERALIZING FOR
THE WHO ARE NOT THE PROPER WHAT
READ I'M SITTING THE TOWN HALL
AND TALKING AGAINST THOSE
PEOPLE WHO ARE NOT DOING THAT I
DIRECTORS STANDING WITH THE
PEOPLE AND- I. AND ASSURE YOU
THAT NOTHING WITH OTHER SAID IN
MY OPENING STATEMENT NOTHING
WILL COME IN MY WAY. WHICH WILL
HINDER ME TO PROTECT CONSUMERS
RIGHTS AND TO PROTECT
CALIFORNIANS AND THAT IS MY
WHOLE GOAL AND THAT IS MY FIRST
AND FOREMOST MISSION AND THAT
IS THE MISSION OF MEDICAL BOARD
AND THAT SHOULD BE THE NATIONAL
MEDICAL. AND I'M I WOULD BE
HAPPY TO- MAKE YOU PROUD IF I
AM CONFIRMED THAT- I WILL DO
THE RIGHT THING AS- THE- AS A
HUMANIST. ARE ALL WILL TRY TO
FIGHT FOR THE RIGHTS OF THE
PEOPLE AND REALIZE THE PEOPLE.
THANK YOU THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
APPRECIATE THE ANSWERS TO THAT
QUESTION THANK YOU VERY MUCH I
APPRECIATE VERY MUCH MY
COLLEAGUES IN THE QUESTIONS
THAT THEY'VE ANSWERED- I THINK
THIS IS- A REALLY IMPORTANT
DISCUSSION- YOU KNOW I READ ALL
OF THE LETTERS THAT WE RECEIVED
IN SUPPORT AND THE OBVIOUSLY
THE- OPPOSITION AND THE SUPPORT
AND- NO DOUBT WHEN WE GO TO
PUBLIC. COMMENT WE'RE GOING TO
HEAR A LOT OF PEOPLE WHO ARE ON
THE PHONE OR HERE IN SUPPORT
AND WE'RE GOING TO HEAR
COMMENTS FROM PEOPLE WHO WERE
IN OPPOSITION. I THINK THE
RULES COMMITTEE HAD A LITTLE
BIT OF A PREVIEW OF THAT WHEN
WE TOOK UP THE APPOINTMENT OF
THE- I DIRECTOR OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF CONSUMER AFFAIRS
BECAUSE- THAT DIRECTORS OF
FORMER. EXECUTIVE TO THE
MEDICAL BOARD SO WE HAD A
PREVIEW OF SOME OF THE CONCERNS
WHICH IS PROBABLY THE NATURE OF
THE CONVERSATION TODAY. I GUESS
AND I THINK I WAS GONNA.
BASICALLY I ASK YOU ABOUT THE
BALANCE OF- THE PRIMARY MISSION
OF THE MEDICAL BOARD. FIVE AND
HOW YOU BALANCE THAT WITH- YOUR
JOB AS PHYSICIANS ARE AND YOU
HAVE TO LOOK AT THE- YOUR PEERS
WHO MAY END UP BEFORE YOU IN
TERMS OF SOME OF THE COMPLAINTS
BUT I THINK MY COLLEAGUES HAVE
ASK OUR- A GOOD NUMBER OF
QUESTIONS ABOUT THAT. WHAT I
WOULD ASK YOU IS DO YOU FEEL
LIKE YOU ACTUALLY HAVE THE
RESOURCES YOU NEED TO DO
APPROPRIATE INVESTIGATIONS WHEN
I LOOK AT- THE RUN DOWN I'VE
BEEN AND TO MY COLLEAGUE THE
MAJORITY LEADER'S QUESTION
ABOUT THE NUMBER OF DAYS AND-
AND HOW LONG IT TAKES TO
INVESTIGATE DO YOU FEEL LIKE
THE BOARD HAS. ADEQUATE
RESOURCES FOR THE EXPERTISE IN
LEVEL OF SKILL OF YOUR
INVESTIGATORS AND THEN- AS
THOSE CASES PROCEED FORWARD I
TAKE- GIVE OR TAKE I WILL TRY
TO LOOK AT SOME OF THE NUMBERS.
AB ELEVEN THOUSAND OR SO
COMPLAINTS YOU OVERSEE THE
LICENSES OF MORE THAN A HUNDRED
SIXTY THOUSAND. POSITIONS AND
WHEN YOU LOOK AT THOSE
COMPLAINTS HOW THEY PERCEIVE
THROUGH THE SYSTEM YOU REALLY
DON'T SEE A LOT OF THOSE UNTIL
UNTIL THEY REACH A LEVEL THAT
THEY COME. TO YOUR PANELS- DO
YOU FEEL LIKE THAT THE BOARD
HAS THE- EXPERTISE TO BE ABLE
TO ADEQUATELY. HAVE THE
INVESTIGATIONS- BE DONE
THOROUGHLY WHEN YOU SEE THOSE
CASES COME BEFORE YOU UP
AGAINST MAYBE. MEDICAL EXPERTS
OF THE DEFENDANTS WHO COME
BEFORE YOU CAN YOU JUST EACH OF
YOU AND I'LL START WITH YOU DR
THORPE. WELL ACTUALLY DR AGAIN
ON A DAY OF YOU HAVE BEEN ON
THE BOARD FOR TEN YEARS SO. LET
ME START WITH YOU- BECAUSE
YOU'VE BEEN THERE LONGER I
WOULD JUST ASK DO YOU FEEL LIKE
YOU HAVE ADEQUATE RESOURCES TO
DO THE KIND OF INVESTIGATION.
THROUGH TO THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL'S OFFICE. BEFORE THEY
COME TO YOU. ARE RUMORED CHAIR
OUR- RESOURCES FIRST WHEN I
DON'T TALK ABOUT WOULD BE THE
BILL'S. ARE WE ARE ASKING IN
THE SUNSET LEGISLATIVE PASSED
THE INCREASE THE DEALERS TO
SELL ON ONE THOUSAND ONE
HUNDRED FIFTY DOLLARS DOLLAR
LICENSE FEE GOING FROM SEVEN
EIGHTY THREE IT'S A SIGNIFICANT
INCREASE BUT OUR COST WENT UP
WITH BOTH H. P- YOU'LL AND- AND
DID YOU SELL WHOSE AGES OFFICE
WHEN THE BY 40% SO THERE IS A
SIGNIFICANT INCREASE IN THERE
SO WE DO WE DO WHEN OF THOSE.
TO THE SUNSET. CARE LEGISLATION
COMES FONG- AS FAR AS- THE PART
NAY ARE D. I. D. LEVEL. WE'RE
ALSO ASK. YOU TO HELP US TO.
ALL OF HOURS TO GET. B. R. RT
TH GRADE AND UP. DATES THESE
ARE BEING BY TRICKS IMPORTANT.
FOR OUR STAFF TO MAKE SURE THAT
THEY INFORM. ON A INFORMED THE-
ASIAN CENTER FOR. ARE GOING TO
COME STRAIGHT AMERICANS. I
THINK THIS IS RELATED STRATEGY
THE COMBINATION BOARD THEIR
YOUNG PHYSICIANS AND- PUBLIC
MEMBERS SO I QUITE A NUMBER OF
TIMES ARE YOU I EXPLAINED TO
PEOPLE AS- AS A TEACHER- FOR A
FORTY YEARS TRAINING GIRL
PEOPLE I CAN EXPLAIN. MAJORITY
OF THE CASES PROVIDED TO MY
FAMILY MEMBERS. ARE USUALLY.
MAJORITY OF THE TIME. I ALL
RIGHT ALONG WITH THE OTHER
FOODS ARE THE ONE WHO ARE PUSH
FOR DISCIPLINE. COMPARED TO OUR
DAILY JAY CAME UP WITH OUR
WATER STIPULATION OUR OWN STAFF
PROVIDED SO. LITTLE THAT WOULD
BIGGEST RESOURCE NEARLY AS OUR
NUMBER ONE IS OUT FINANCES
NUMBER TO USED IT WILL BE A
PART OF OUR STAFF TO GET THERE
AND GET. BORED BORED. IF YOU
KNOW YOUR NAY HE SOPHISTRY HE
SEEMS VERY BEING INVESTIGATION
IS ATTENDING YOUR PARTNER FIRM
ARTIFICIAL ROCKET SCIENCE
BECAUSE- IN THIS AGE RETIRED
THINGS. ARE CHRONIC. EVEN
THOUGH WE HAVE THE PERFECT
PRIVACY I THINK SHOULD BE ABLE
TO GET. THANK YOU DR THORPE LET
ME ASK YOU NEXT. THANK YOU. ON
DOG DOG HAS JUST HIT ON THE L.
THE THERE'S A REALLY THERE'S A
STRUCTURAL. WITH THE- STUFF OF
MOTHER WARD- WE- WELL THE- OUR
REACH IN TERMS OF REVENUE ARE
BASED ON LICENSING FEES AND WE
ARE SORT OF HELD CAPTIVE BY-
AGENCIES WE DON'T HAVE ANY
CONTROL OVER RECENTLY- I'M-
INTERESTING THE DIFFERENT
NOTCHING THAT ARE NOT
APPROPRIATE UNDERSTAND WE DON'T
HAVE ANY CONTROL OVER THE NEXT-
FEES FROM THE H. U. I. U. NH
AND THE INVESTIGATION UNIT. AT
ALSO FEATURE RETURNING
GENERAL'S OFFICE AND THAT IS-
YOU KNOW THERE'S A STRUCTURAL
DEFICIT RIGHT NOW WE WILL BE
BANKRUPT IN ABOUT EIGHTEEN
MONTHS AND WE ONLY HAVE A- TWO
MONTH- BY FOR REALLY. ALL RIGHT
NOW SO. THE MEDICAL BOARD. THEN
THERE IS A IN DEPTH NEED TO
INCREASE. BUT THERE ALSO NEEDS
TO BE SOME OTHER THINGS DONE
WITHIN THE STRUCTURE
FINANCIALLY OF THE BOARD SO
THAT THESE STRUCTURAL PROBLEMS
ARE ALLEVIATE IT AND- CALPERS
AND THAT THERE'S EIGHT THE
ABILITY OF THE MEDICAL BOARD TO
HAVE THE FINANCIAL RESOURCES
NEEDED TO COMPLETE TO CONTINUE
TO. PROVIDE GOOD QUALITY OF
INVESTIGATIONS AND DISCIPLINARY
ACTIONS YOU MENTIONED SOMETHING
ABOUT- OUR CONSULTANTS AND-
THERE IS I THINK IT'S A REAL
NEED TO ENCOURAGE- AREN'T. YOU
KNOW GOOD QUALITY DOCTORS TO BE
CONSULTANTS AND THE DIFFICULTY
IS THAT THERE'RE THEY ARE PAID
OF COURSE BUT IT'S NOT IT'S
VERY IT'S VERY YEAH HI AM SET.
TIME- IT'S VERY. IT DOES A LOT
OF GIVE ME SPENT IN REVIEWING.
IN WAITING FOR RECORDS COME AND
SO- BUT IN THE PROCESS OF
REVIEWING RECORDS REVIEWING THE
STANDARDS CARE THERE'S A LOT OF
WORK BEING DONE BY THE
CONSULTANTS AND- UNFORTUNATELY.
YOU KNOW WE WE'RE IT'S A IT'S A
VOLUNTARY POOL THERE'S NO
THERE'S NO MANDATE THAT PEOPLE%
HAVE TO BE CONSULTANTS- WITH A
LIMITED POOL TO DRAW FROM.
WOULD BE BETTER IF WE HADN'T
MORE CONSULTANTS THAT WE COULD.
DO WE COULD ACCESS YES WORK AND
POSSIBLY INCREASING THE
RESOURCES WILL- WILL ACCOMPLISH
THAT AS WELL BUT- I THINK THE
BIGGER ISSUES REALLY ARE
ADDRESSING THE STRUCTURAL.
PROBLEMS WITH THE WAY THE
FINANCES ARE ARE MADE- SET UP
IN THE MEDICAL BOARD UNDERSTOOD
DR MAHMOUD ANYTHING YOU WOULD
LIKE TO ADD TO WHAT. EITHER
HAVE SAID. WELL I THINK OF THE
BODY SOMETHING ONLY BECAUSE
THEY DAYS AND DOUBLE AND WEBER.
IF YOU'LL JUST SUMMER SIXTY
DAYS AND- INFUSING. AND COST
SHARE FROM THE RESPONDENTS
SPEND THAT THE CASE. WOULD BE
VERY HELPFUL- I WANTED TO COME
UP AND REALLY CORD PROBLEM IS
MONEY. YOU NEED TO HAVE
RESOURCES THAT THAT IS SOURCES
ARE BARRED BY A FINANCES. IF.
YOU HIDE IN INVEST. AND YOUR
OPINION SIR AMOUNT AND IF YOU
CAN- CANNOT KEEP IT DOCKED OF
THE- INDUSTRY. THAT
INVESTIGATORS. YOU'RE DOING
LEARN THINGS ON YOU. AND THEN
YOU HAVE TO START FROM THE NEW
PERSON IF YOU KEEP THEM AT IT.
CERTAINLY THEY WERE NOT. ANY
REST WHO DOING HIS JOB AND PLUS
A YEAR IF IS THERE A THIRD YEAR
IS WOULD BE LOCKED OUT OF. AND
RELIABLE QUALITY. PAINTING THAT
YOU HAVE EXPERT OPINIONS
MEDICAL VOTE AGAINST US BUT
WHEN HE AND A- LOWER LEVEL OF
COST MADE AS DEFENDANT ON THE
SPOT IS GOING TO COST. FIVE
TIMES AND OBVIOUSLY THOSE
PEOPLE ARE GOING TO BE SPENDING
A LOT THAT'S WHY
SOMEBODY WILL LOSE IT YES IT'S-
STILL REALLY BOTTOM LINE IS.
MORE RESOURCES AND FINANCIAL
RESOURCES EVERYTHING ELSE CAN
BE ADDRESSED IF WE CAN ADJUST
THAT AND I THINK OF. THIS IS A
READY TIMELY- ACTION BEING
COMING AND- SENSITIVE YOU WHICH
WILL COME TO YOU AND HOPEFULLY.
THAT WILL HELP US. DO SOME GOOD
RIGHT THANK YOU DR I WOULD
THINK- YOU KNOW IT WAS IN
TRYING TO GET TO. WHAT YOU'RE
HANDED AS A BOARD TO REVIEW
WHEN YOU ARE DEALING WITH AN
INVESTIGATION. MEDICAL EXPERTS
YOU CAN BE AT YOU KNOW IF THE
DEFENDANT HAS MORE RESOURCES-
YOU YOU'VE GOT AN IMBALANCE OF
A SITUATION THERE. BEFORE
SOMETHING IS PUT BEFORE YOU TO
MAKE A DETERMINATION YOU'RE-
YOU'RE GONNA I MEAN GRANTED
THAT'S THE BENEFIT. HAVE AT THE
SAME TIME IF YOU DON'T HAVE THE
RIGHT LEGAL EXPERTISE AN
INVESTIGATIVE RESOURCES- I
MEAN. YOU KNOW WE ALL FACE THAT
WHEN I WAS AT A CITY COUNCIL
AND WE HAD CLOSED SESSION TO
DEAL WITH LITIGATION. OUR CITY-ATTORNEYS WERE SOMETIMES OUT
MANEUVERED- AS I LOOK AT OUR
ATTORNEY. SO I I'M JUST I'M
JUST- YES AS TO WHETHER THERE
IS A FORM OF COST RECOVERY THAT
WOULD ALLOW YOU BETTER
EXPERTISE BUT I'LL LEAVE THAT
FOR A MINUTE AND JUST- ASK ONE
MORE QUESTION BEFORE WE GO TO
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC AND WE
WILL TAKE A BREAK AT THAT POINT
SO THAT. OUR OUR STENOGRAPHER
CAN. LET HER FINGERS- RELAX A
BIT BUT- YOU HAVE AS A AS A
BODY INTERNAL GUIDELINES FOR
LEVELS OF DISCIPLINE. AND YOU
FOLLOW THOSE GUIDELINES SO
WHETHER YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT I
MEAN I ASSUME I'M GOING TO ASK
YOU ABOUT THAT. YOU HAVE
GUIDELINES FOR- THE TYPE OF
DISCIPLINARY ACTION YOU CAN
TAKE WHETHER SOMEONE IS ON.
PROBATION. FOR THREE FIVE SEVEN
I DON'T KNOW WHAT YOUR
GUIDELINES ARE BUT- HOW OFTEN
DO YOU- I MEAN DO YOU FOLLOW
GUIDELINES AS OUTLINED IN TERMS
OF DISCIPLINARY ACTION. OR DO
YOU HAVE THE ABILITY TO- CHANGE
AND GIVE A LESSER. DISCIPLINARY
ACTION OUTSIDE OF YOUR
GUIDELINES AND DO YOU HAVE A
SENSE OF HOW OFTEN YOU FOLLOW
THOSE GUIDELINES STRICTLY OR
WHETHER YOU. GIVE LESS OF A
DISCIPLINARY ACTION AND DR
MEHMOOD I WILL GO TO YOU FIRST
AND LET YOU START THIS TIME.
THANK YOU I THINK YOU'RE BROAD
DISPLAYING RIGHT IN THE
BEGINNING OF YOUR STATEMENT.
AND WHY WHACKED CHRISTIANS
BRING MORE TO THE BOARD THEN
OTHER PEOPLE BECAUSE
EVERYBODY'S HEALTHCARE. AND
SAME THING IS THE CASE WITH
THAT. ARM MANY TIMES IT HAPPENS
THAT PHYSICIANS BECAUSE MOST OF
THEM ARE PRACTICING AND THEY
KNOW THE PROBLEM EXACTLY AND
THEY ARE ABLE TO PLAY PLAY TO
THE KNEE LIKE MANY PLAY PLAY
MEANS THAT FIND OUT EXACTLY WHY
THIS HAPPENED A- LOT OF TIME WE
COME UP AND BRING YOUR QUESTION
WHY DOT FRESH MEN. ARE THAT IS
THE LAW WHY DOES I GO TO IS
LESS SHOULD BE BECAUSE THIS IS
A MEDICAL THING AND I DON'T
HAPPEN WHEN NOW YOU THINK THAT
THIS IS A NORMAL THING WHICH
HAPPENED NOT NORMAL THING BUT
THIS IS A COMMON THING WHICH
HAPPENED A COMMUNITY. AND IF
YOU START. DEMANDING PEOPLE.
BUT EVERY LITTLE THING THEN
THERE'LL BE A LOT OF PROBLEMS.
THE NEW. BUT IN OUR STATE IS
THAT CONSUMER PROTECTION IS THE
NUMBER ONE MISSION AND GOAL.
AND THE SECOND THING IS
PHYSICIAN ARE OR WHY DOES THE
HAVE ADDITION SHOULD BE IN OUR
MIND. AND SOMETIMES YOU CAN
PLAY A LITTLE BIT WITH THAT AND
YOU CAN COME UP WITH A BETTER
DECISION MOST THE TIME WHEN I
LOOK AT THAT I LOOK AT THE
GUIDELINES AND I TRIED TO
FOLLOW GUIDELINES SO THAT. I'M
NOT TOO MUCH BY ITS BUT
OBVIOUSLY OF BEING BOTH OF
THESE THINGS THAT IS THIS WHAT
IS HAPPENING IS UNUSUAL VERY
UNUSUAL IT IS THE- TALK OF THE
LANGUAGE AND THAT IS JUST AN
ALL UNINTENTIONAL ERROR RATE
SOMEBODY. DIDN'T GET HIRED
SOMEBODY DIDN'T GET NEARLY-
NINE DAMAGED BAG IS GETTING TO
THINK SO THANKS IN MY OPINION
THINGS READY BUT BECAUSE OF
YOUR MEDICAL KNOWLEDGE AND
BECAUSE OF THE ABILITY TO DO
YOU HAVE A STATE SOMETIME AND.
SOMETIME UNDERSTANDABLE. THANK
YOU I. YOUR WHOLE BECAUSE- NEXT
SEE WHAT I DO THANK YOU DOT
THORPE- YEAH I- SO WHAT I THINK
DOCTOR WHO IS SAID IT WHAT WE
KNOW WHAT ALL THAT- I THOUGHT I
WOULD SAY NINETY FIVE TO
NINETY. I WOULD BE A PROBABLY
95% MAYBE 98% OF THE TIME- THE
PANEL WILL FOLLOW THE
RECOMMENDATIONS OF THE- OR THE-
THE MINISTRY LAW JUDGE- YOU
KNOW BECAUSE THEY- THEY'RE MUCH
CLOSER TO THE CASE AND WE ARE
WE REVIEW EVERY CASE- IN DETAIL
BUT- GENERALLY YOU ARE WHEN IT
COMES RIGHT DOWN TO WE
RECOGNIZE THAT THAT'S- THEIR
EXPERTISE I THINK LOOKING BACK
ON I'M JUST LOOKING AT-
DOCUMENTS THAT. WERE PROVIDED
TO ME BY THE STAFF AND IN IN
TWENTY SIXTEEN TWENTY
SEVENTEEN- THIS IS PART OF THE
ADMINISTRATIVE LAW JUDGE CASES.
UNDER EIGHTY ONE DECISIONS THAT
WERE ADOPTED WITHOUT CHANGE UP
SIX DECISIONS THAT WERE- THE
PENALTY REDUCED IN SOME WAY AND
EIGHT TIMES AT THE BOARD VOTED
TO INCREASE THE PENALTY IN SOME
WAY- IN. IN TWENTY TWENTY THERE
WERE FORTY THREE ADMINISTRATIVE
LAW JUDGE ADOPTIONS WITHOUT
CHANGE. AND ONE EACH ONE OF THE
ADMINISTRATIVE LAW JUDGE
DECISIONS WAS. R. DECREASED AND
ONE OF THEM WAS INCREASED SO
IT'S- IT IS NOT VERY OFTEN THAT
WE THAT WE CHANGE IT BUT WE DO
HAVE WE DO FOLLOW THE DISHES
ARE GUIDELINES THAT ARE THAT
ARE ATTACHED TO EVERY CASE.
THANK YOU DOCTOR. DR CONNECTIVE
THERE ARE NONE OF YOUR LINES SO
ACTUALLY THERE AND I THINK I
COULD GO FOR FROM THE MOOD TO-
IS HERE TO STAY COMPLETELY
CLEARLY. WE DO FOLLOW THE
DISAPPOINTED I HAD DIED LAST
MOST OF THE TIME AND ENERGY-
BECAUSE HE USES YOUR JOURNEY
HERE SHE'S A DIRECTOR AND THEY
USUALLY. ARE HE WAS. IF YOU
DESCEND- I RECOMMENDED. HARDER
JERRY FOR US TO SORRY. AND
THERE ARE STILL CASES THIS IS
WHERE CONSCIOUS I'M VERY.
INTERESTING WITH YOUR- TIMES
BOTH LONG. HOW FOR. ON THE-
RATHER THAN WORK PEOPLE BY
STAFF ON THE YOU SAW BY. THEN I
DON'T HAVE OF THE TIME. THE
AGENTS ARE THERE TO CAN A THAT
THROUGH TOO BIG IF YOU DON'T
TAKE A- THESE ARE THE MEETING
FOR IT'S NOT JUST THE CARE SO
YOU GOT TO FOLLOW SO THAT FALL
THE ACTOR YEAH I SAW. WE'RE IF
YOU DO- BOOK THE- B. A. R. YOUR
DECISION. THROUGH THE SUNSET
REVIEW AT OUR I BUSINESSES AND
PROFESSIONS COMMITTEE. COST
RECOVERY PARTICULARLY IF THERE
ARE AGREE JUST CASES WHERE
VIOLATIONS ARE FOUND. I COULD
BE ONE THING TO CONSIDER AND
LOOK AT I. DON'T NEED A
RESPONSE TO THAT I THINK WE CAN
REFER THAT IS MY VICE CHAIRMAN
SAID TO THE SUNSET REVIEW
PROCESS IN TERMS OF TRYING TO
HELP YOU FIGURE OUT. HOW YOU
ARE GOING TO HAVE THE
RESOURCES- THAT YOU NEED AND I
WOULD SAY. THIS BODY IS GOING
TO HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO TALK
TO A POTENTIAL- ATTORNEY
GENERAL APPOINTEE. AT WHICH
POINT WE CAN TALK ABOUT THEIR
ROLE HERE HIS OR HER ROLE. IN
THE ADVOCACY OF CONSUMER
PROTECTION AND HOW TO
PRIORITIZE THAT IN A WAY. THAT
MAKE SURE THAT THERE IS LEGAL
EXPERTISE AVAILABLE TO THE
BOARDS AT THE LEVEL THAT YOU
ARE. MAY NEED. WE'RE GONNA TAKE
OUR COLLEAGUES ARE AND AN
ESTEEMED DOCTORS WE ARE GOING
TO- FIVE MINUTE BREAK. AND THEN
WE WILL COME BACK FOR PUBLIC
TESTIMONY AND THEN WILL
CONCLUDE SO I THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR YOUR PATIENCE I KNOW HOW
BUSY EACH OF YOU ARE. FIVE
MINUTES EVERYONE.
YOU ALL FOR
YOUR PATIENCE IN ALLOWING US TO
TAKE. A BIT OF A BREAK I'M
CALLING THE- COMMITTEE BACK TO
ORDER MY COLLEAGUES ARE HERE.
AND I SEE SENATOR BATES IS ALSO
THERE. WE ARE GOING TO- MOVED
TO PEOPLE ARE MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC WHO ARE HERE TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT AND I'M GONNA GIVE A
REMINDER TO THOSE THAT WILL BE
JOINING US VIA TELECONFERENCE
THAT THE NUMBER TO CALL THE-
PARTICIPANT TOLL FREE NUMBER IS
EIGHT FOUR FOUR. TWO NINE ONE
SIX THREE SIX FOUR THE ACCESS
CODE IS. NINE TWO FOUR ONE FOUR
FIVE EIGHT. WE'RE GONNA START
WITH MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC- A-
WHO ARE HERE IN ROOM THIRTY ONE
NINETY ONE IN SUPPORT. AND
SEEING NO ONE IN ROOM THIRTY
ONE NINETY ONE LET ME GO AHEAD
AND LOOK AT ROOM ONE TWELVE.
OKAY NO ONE IN SUPPORT WE WILL
GO TO MADAME MODERATOR- ON THE
TELECONFERENCE. AND MATAMATA
RAIDER I WILL ASK IF YOU'RE
ABLE TO TELL ME IN ADVANCE HOW
MANY SPEAKERS AND SUPPORT WE
HAVE IN THE QUEUE AND THE KEEP
ME POSTED ON THAT. AND I WOULD
REMIND INDIVIDUALS- TO PLEASE
GIVE US YOUR NAME. WHO YOU ARE
REPRESENTING IF ANYONE AND VERY
BRIEF COMMENTS THANK YOU MADAM
MODERATOR ARE YOU WITH THIS.
YES THANK YOU IF YOU WISH WE
CAN SUPPORT YOU MAY PRESS ONE.
ZERO AT THIS TIME. ONE ZERO AT
THIS TIME AND WE DO HAVE-
TENANT SUPPORT BOBOC BOTH THE
FIRST LINE OF SIXTY GO AHEAD
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
STONE OF STONE ADVOCACY ON BACK
OF THE CALIFORNIA ORTHOPEDIC
ASSOCIATION WE SUPPORT THE
MISSION OF THE MEDICAL BOARD
THE PROTECT HEALTHCARE PATIENTS
THROUGH PROPER LICENSING AND
REGULATION OF PHYSICIANS AND
SURGEONS AND WE BELIEVE THAT
ALL THREE APPOINTEES-
REAPPOINTING DOCTORS WORK AND
GONNA DAB AND APPOINTING TO
MEMBER- WE- THOSE APPOINTMENTS
AND THAT ALL THREE ARE WELL-QUALIFIED TO SERVE ON THE FOR.
AND URGE YOUR AYE THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THANK YOU VERY MUCH
NECK WITNESS. THANK YOU WE WILL
GO TOLD OF THREE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. THANK YOU- MY NAME IS
BRADY HE AND SHE OPERATING TO
LONGMEADOW CENTER IN CAL. I'M
TALKING- THIS OF DOC RICHARD
THORPE. I KNOW TO THE EIGHTEEN
AND- CAL. IN VIEW CAL. THAT THE
CAMP STAR. IT WAS- A TREMENDOUS-
LOCKED IN- ARE COUNTY AND
LOCKED MAY. AT THE EXACTLY
OCCUR ON THE DAY ALL THE MATTER
CAN WITHIN BUTTE COUNTY IN MANY
OTHER CAN HELP WITH THE MEDIC
COMMUNITY OF. WHICH WAS OUT OF
ALL THEIR FACILITIES WENT DOWN
TO OR ABOUT HOT THE IN MY
MEDICAL TO HELP THEIR- AS I
RECEIVED A PHONE FROM THE
THOUGHT HIS. WAS QUICKLY SET UP
YEAH GROUP CRACKED AND SHE- AS
FAST AS HE COULD AND HE NEEDED
HELP. HE WAS FOCUS ON HIS DAY.
THAT LEFT THEIR HOME WITH ANY
OTHER MEN SOME DO TO THE FACT
MAY FIRE. BY THE TECH DAY OF
THE FIRE WE HAVE STAFF A- AND
EXECUTE GETTING THE SHARE ASK
WITHIN FIRE. TO LOAD ALL THE
MEDICAL. OUT OF HIS. JUST UP
DOWN INTO TWO. BY THAT THEY
DATE PRACTICE WAS UP RUNNING.
THE ONE THING THAT I DID
REALIZE. UNTIL THE FIFTH SIXTY
OF THAT OF WHAT THE DRAMATIC
STORY THAT MANY OFTHE
COMMUNITY MEMBERS AND METAL
COMMUNITY AND PARADISE WENT
THROUGH. ALL DOG COURTOIS FOCUS
ON WITH CARE OF HIS STATION
QUICKLY AS FAR. THAT IS THE
DOCTOR TOWARD THAT I KNOW.
THANK YOU. THANK VERY MUCH NEXT
WHICH- THANK YOU AND ARE ONE
WILL COME FROM MY- THIRTY. YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON-
THAT THE ADRIAN WITH THE
MEDICAL- WE WANT TO THAT WE OF.
THE CALL TAKING THE TIME- AND
THAT WE IS THE ACT FOURTH-
CONFIRMATION- STOCK GOT A-
DOCTOR DOOR OPEN MIGHT. THANK
YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT
WEEK. THANK YOU THAT WILL COME
MIND EIGHT. YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HI MY IS CAN CRAP I AM THE CEO
AT HOPE OF THE VALLEY REST
MISSION WHERE WE HAVE. NINE SHE
IN THE SAN VALLEY AND ACTION BY
THE END OF YEAR WILL POOR. AND
I JUST WANT TO THE- EXTRA MY
INCREDIBLE SO FOR MONEY WHO HAS
BEEN NOT JUST A SUPPORT BUT HE
BEEN A FEW OF THE MID. HE WHEN
HE SAID EARLIER THAT HIS IS TO
HELP THE SEARCH. WE SEE IT ALL
THE TIME WHETHER IT'S EVEN
BRING NEIL BRING MEDICAL SO.
HELPING THOSE THAT INJURED IN
THOSE THAT ARE WITH THE SHOW.
HE HAS A HARD FOR THOSE IN SO-
WE FULLY SUPPORT DR MY MOOD- IN
YOUR IN THE BOARD THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT
WITNESS. AT A COMPLIANT THE
THIRD SIX THE LINE OPEN. RIGHT
THANK YOU ON BEHALF OF THE
COLLEGE WILL BE INSTANCE IN
STRONG OF THE COMPANY DOC GOD
FACT MAHMOUD AND DOCTOR THOUGHT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
NEXT WITNESS. THANK YOU COME
THE LINE OF NINE YEAR LINE IS A-
THANK YOU CHAIR TEN BY- CALL ON
BEHALF. OF CHARACTER IDEA
PLASTICS. CAL CHAPTER OF THE
AMERICAN. OF CARDIOLOGY IN THE
K. RHEUMATOL ALLIANCE AND ALL
TRIGGER RUNS OF THE CONTRA. OF
DOC GONNA TALK MY MOOD IN
DOCKET COURT THANK YOU. THANK
YOU FOR MUCH NEXT WITNESS.
METAL FROM LINE POOR NINE LINE
OF THE- A LINE FORTY NINE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN YOU HAVE WITH THEM
YOU. AND WE WILL GO ON A LINE
OF LINE AT TWENTY SIX YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS THIS IS DON
SHOULDN'T ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA SOCIETY OF
DERMATOLOGY AND DERMATOLOGIC
SURGERY- WE CAN DO EXPRESS OUR
SUPPORT FOR ALL THREE DOCTORS
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
NEXT WITNESS PLEASE. THANK YOU
AND THAT'LL COME FROM WIND UP
FORTY SIX THE LINE IS OPEN.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR COMMITTEE
MEMBERS MY NAME IS TIM WILLIAMS
I REPRESENT ADVOCATE HEALTH OF
THE LEAD EXECUTIVE AND GIVEN TO
HIM A COUNTIES TO SPEAK ON
BEHALF OF DR THORPE. PERSONALLY
TO ATTEST TO HIS CHARACTER OF
INTEGRITY COMPASSION CARING
SELFLESS SERVICE TO THE
PATIENTS IN OUR COMMUNITY. I'VE
HAD THE OPPORTUNITY TO WORK
WITH DR THORTON VARIOUS
CAPACITIES OVER THE LAST THREE
YEARS WHEN I FIRST CAME TO
ADMINISTER HEALTH. ACIDIC WE
WERE TOGETHER TO LEADER. DIE
DYNAMIC. DYNAMIC WHERE DOC ARE
WITH MARKET MEDICAL. THREE
AREAS IN PARTICULAR THAT I WANT
TO FOR LEADERS EITHER HAVE THEM
PAY BASED CARE NOT. EKWALL
SERVICE AND SAFETY. FIRST WITH
PATIENT QUALITY DR- WAS AND HOW.
FOR OUR- IN. MEETING PROVIDERS
OF VARIOUS- SPECIAL TO ADD TO
FOR THE CARE EXPERIENCE TO THE
DEGREE. OF ALSO HAVING
DIFFICULT CONVERSATIONS WITH
CLINICIANS AND EVEN ENSURING.
THAT WE TERMINATED SOME HIGHLY
SKILLED POSITIONS BECAUSE OF
CONCERNS AROUND PATIENT SAFETY.
ULTIMATELY WHAT THE CONCERN OF
DELIVERING WORLD CLASS HEALTH
CARE TO OUR PATIENTS. YOU HEARD
BRADY INSTRUMENTAL MEDICAL
SPEAK SIR A LITTLE BIT IN
ADDITION. IN TWENTY EIGHT WITH
THE- IMPAIRED I. NOT LOSING HIS
OWN DOCTOR THORPE PUT PATIENTS
FOR. WITH OUR ADMIN AT. TEAM HE
RALLY PROVIDER AND SOME OF OUR
PAY WHO ARE BY THE- NOT ONLY
ENSURING THEY HAD CRITICAL
MEDIC BUT ALSO CA. TO PRIMARY
CARE BEHAVIOR HEALTH TEAMS AND
TO ENSURE THEIR ULTIMATE SAFETY.
AND FINALLY WITH PATIENTS HAS A
DOCTOR'S STORE HAS A CHAMPION.
A IN BUTTE COUNTY WITH OUR-
MOBILE APP TO. INTO LEAD AN OPI.
TASK FORCE ALSO CO. WITH ARGUED
PA HEALTH. THE ON SOME OF THE
CHAO THAT WE FACED HERE. HE
ENSURE THAT OUR PATIENTS WERE
APPROACH. AND HAD. IN PLACE TO
PAPER THEM AND ALSO WORK TO-
OVERALL POLICIES AND PROVIDER
EDUCATION- TO TRACK COMPLIANCE.
HE WAS ALSO THE CHAIR OF OUR
PATIENT COMPLIANCE REVIEW TO
ENSURE THAT PATIENTS HAD. AN
ADVOCACY FOR THEIR CARE AND
ALSO ON OUR OUTPATIENT CLINICAL
QUALITY COMMITTEE. TO REVIEW
STANDARDS OF CARE. HELLO DOCTOR
THOUGHT NO LONGER SERVICE-
ALONG SIDE US HERE LOCALLY WITH
ADVENTIST HEALTH HIS KNOWLEDGE
AND EXPERIENCE AS A POSITION
ARE THINGS THAT I STILL RELYING
FOR HIS WISDOM. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME AND CONSIDERATION AND
SUPPORT PRODUCTIVE WORK. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. NEXT WITNESS
PLEASE. THANK YOU MADAM. LAST
ON WILL BE COME MY LINE. FORTY
FIVE. ONE FORTY FIVE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. MADAM MADAM PRESIDENT
COMMITTEE MEMBERS EMBRACE
DOUGHERTY HERE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ACADEMY OF FAMILY
PHYSICIANS THE CALIFORNIA
SOCIETY OF ANESTHESIOLOGISTS IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF DR STORE.
MOVED IN COULD NOT HAVE ALL
THREE OF WHOM ARE HAVING FOR
PROTECTION AND PATIENT SAFETY
WELL CALIFORNIA FAMILY
PHYSICIANS AND PHYSICIAN
ANESTHESIOLOGY STRONGLY URGE
YOUR CONFIRMATION OF THEIR
APPOINTMENTS. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU AND WE
HAVE NO ONE FURTHER IN Q. OKAY
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM
MODERATOR WILL BE BACK WITH YOU
IN A FEW MINUTES. SO I HAVING
HEARD FROM PEOPLE IN SUPPORT WE
WILL NOW MOVE TO SPEAKERS IN
OPPOSITION. I WILL START IN
HERE IN ROOM THIRTY ONE NINETY
ONE. AND SEEING NO ONE IN
THIRTY ONE NINETY ONE LET ME
LOOK AT ROOM ONE TWELVE. OKAY
SEEING NO ONE IN ROOM ONE
TWELVE- TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
MADAM MODERATOR I AM COMING
BACK TO YOU. CAN YOU TELL ME
HOW MANY OF. FOLKS WE HAVE
WAITING IN THE QUEUE TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION. YES IF YOU WISH
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION YOU MAY
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME.
AND IT LOOKS LIKE WE HAVE SIX
OF THEM ONE MOMENT WHEN I WOULD
GATHER THEIR INFORMATION OKAY
N. AS WE WAIT I WILL REMIND
WITNESSES TO PROVIDE YOUR NAME
ORGANIZATION IF ANY. POSITION
ON THE APPOINTMENT AND TO SPEAK
SLOWLY AND CLEARLY- SO OUR
STENOGRAPHER CAN HEAR YOU THANK
YOU MADAM MODERATOR. THANK YOU
AND WE'LL GO TO LINE OF TWENTY
FOUR YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO
AND THEIR MEMBERS. ONE OF. MY
LOOK ME UP OR OTHER AND I AM
RECEIVING PROBLEM FOR. DOESN'T
THIRTEEN HUSBAND GOOD WHAT'S
THE BY IT OF GROWTH THANK YOU
DON'T ERRORS BUT WHEN THEY'RE
HE- A GREAT ATHLETE IN THE MARA
ON THERE INTO A- AMPUTEE AT THE
AGE OF. TWO BIGELOW RECORD WELL
MY HUSBAND WOULD REQUIRE
EXPENSIVE INTENSIVE MEDICAL
CARE FOR THE REST OF HIS LIFE
AT THE EXPENSE OF ALL
CALIFORNIA TAXPAYERS. THANK
DOCTOR FOR. EVERYTHING
INCLUDING OUR FUTURE OR HELP
UNFORTUNATELY THE CALIFORNIA
MEDICAL JORDAN BOARD. MADE SURE
THAT WE GOT NO JUSTICE BECAUSE
OVER 95% OF COMPLAINTS ARE
CLOSE WITHOUT ANY SORT OF.
REACTION DURING THIS PROPERTY
WAS ENDING AND THAT DESPITE
BEING A CONSUMER PROTECTION
AGENCY THE CONSUMER IN THE LAST
CONSIDERATION OF THE CALIFORNIA
MEDICAL BOARD EVEN THOUGH STEP
CONSUMERS ACTUAL VICTIMS WILL
HAVE THE MAIN HURT AND EVEN
KILLED AT THE HANDS OF A FEW
COURT DECISIONS. DURING THIS
PROCESS BEIJING IS NOT ONLY
VICTIMIZED BY THE MEDICAL
PROVIDER BUT BY THE VERY SAME
ORGANIZATION THAT IS SUPPOSED
TO DELIVER. A MODICUM OF
JUSTICE. I WOULD LIKE TO THE
DOCTOR ANOTHER OF WHAT. US THE
BOARDMAN. IT IS A VERY SAME AND
I'M NOT SHOWING THE EXPRESS.
STATIONS THE FACE RIGHT NOW. I
THINK HE'S UP. THAT THE SLOW
SCHEME. WITH DEVELOPER FEES
WILL. I WELL AS- BECAUSE IT IS
THE THIRD BUT YOU CAN MORE
CLIENTS. FROM YOUR OF
RESTAURANTS ANOTHER THOUGHT BUT
FROM DEFENSE MEDICAL FOR YOU. I
AM MORE HORRIFIED BY THE
SELECTION OF DOCTOR FOR AMANDA
HAVE PRESIDED OVER THE
CALIFORNIA MEDICAL ASSOCIATION.
HAS BEEN PART OF IT FOR ALMOST
A QUARTER OF A CENTURY BUT IF
DOCTOR START PLEASE THAT THE
CALIFORNIA MEDICAL BOARD IS NOW
A BRANCH OF THE LOBBYING GROUP
THIRTY. THE CALIFORNIA MEDICAL
ASSOCIATION APPOINTING HIM AS A
BOARD MEMBER IT'S LIKE ASKING.
THE RATHER START THE BANK. THE
A CITY IS A- BECAUSE PERFECT
NEED. IT ALLOWS SEVERAL DOCTORS
HARM OVER AND OVER AGAIN.
CALIFORNIANS OF ALL WALKS OF.
BUT AUTHORED BREAK THE MOST.
WHEN THEY- ARE SO THAT THE ONLY
CHOICE. PETER TO UNDER
COMMUNITIES. THE ONLY BIG.
ALLOWED NEGLIGENCE. TO PRACTICE
WITH. OKAY ARE THE ONES THAT
THE BURIED REAL FINANCIAL CLOUT.
UP THERE WILL CARE. BUT YOU
COULD ON THE PHONE TO COME
POSSIBLE. NOT A SINGLE OR
VICTIMS. IN FAVOR THEIR
APPOINTMENT ON THE DOCTOR OF
MEMBER OF MY MEDIC PROFESSION
GROUPS. OBVIOUS ATTEMPT DOT FOR
MORE APOLOGIES BUT THOSE ARE.
BE IN THE OF THEM CORPS AND FOR
CALL BECAUSE OF MEDICAL. AND
ANY PLACE OF THE APPOINTMENT
FOR AND I. YOU TO SEND THANK
YOU. MA'AM THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS PLAY. THANK YOU MEADOW
COME FROM TO EIGHT YOUR IS OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON THAT CHAIR OF
THE COMMITTEE MY NAME IS UNDER
AS AN I'M FROM THE AREA I'M
GONNA COUNTY. I WOULD LIKE TO
FIRST THANK SENATOR WILK FOR
SUPPORTING ME AND MY FAMILY- AS
WELL AS THE COMMITTEE FOR
HEARING US TODAY. I'M HERE
TODAY WITH MY HUSBAND ANTHONY
TO SPEAK ON BEHALF OF OUR
FAMILY TO OPPOSE THE
APPOINTMENT OF DOCTORS MOVED IN
ON A DEAD END TORQUE TO THE
MEDICAL BOARD. WE ARE VICTIMS
OF MEDICAL NEGLIGENCE. MORE
SPECIFICALLY OUR SEVENTEEN YEAR
OLD DAUGHTER JORDAN DIED IN TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN. AS A RESULT
OF EGREGIOUS MEDICAL NEGLIGENCE.
THE CURRENT MEDICAL INJURY
COMPENSATION REFORM ACT OF
NINETEEN SEVENTY FIVE HAS
DEFINED OUR DAUGHTER'S LIFE AS
NOT WORTHY. AND OF HAVING NO
VALUE. THIS LAW DESPITE EFFORTS
HAS REMAINED UNCHANGED FOR OVER
FORTY FIVE YEARS WITH THE HELP
OF THE CALIFORNIA MEDICAL
ASSOCIATION. WHICH THESE
DOCTORS WERE MEMBERS- AND HAVE
CONTINUED TO FIGHT. JORDAN MORE
THAN JUST MISDIAGNOSED SHE
SUFFERED AT THE HANDS OF THE
MEDICAL PROFESSIONALS WE
TRUSTED TO HELP HER. THEY
FAILED THEY FAILED US AND MOST
IMPORTANTLY THEY FAIL JORDAN.
AN ENTIRE CHILDREN'S HOSPITAL
AND THEIR PROVIDERS IGNORED HER
SYMPTOMS. FOR TEST RESULTS AND
LACKED ANY COORDINATED CARE
BETWEEN SPECIALTIES WILL
CONTINUE TO PASS THE BUCK AND
PASS ALONG TO THE NEXT DOCTOR.
MOST OF THE TIME WITHOUT
DIRECTION DIAGNOSIS OR
TREATMENT. AND THE MEDICAL
BOARD DID NOTHING ABOUT IT
AFTER WE FILED COMPLAINTS. IN
OUR OPINION THE APPOINTEES
CONTRIBUTED TO THE SITUATION.
NO THEY WERE NOT INVOLVED IN
HER CARE DIRECTLY AS HE NEVER
TREATED JORDAN BUT THEY HAVE AS
LOBBYIST BOUGHT THE LAWS AND
THEIR FOUNDATION TO ALLOW US
THE ABILITY TO HOLD THOSE WERE
NEGLIGENT ACCOUNTABLE. AND AS
BOARD MEMBERS FAILED TO
INVESTIGATE COMPLAINTS. AS SUCH
WE BELIEVE THE CMA THE MEDICAL
BOARD AND THESE APPOINTEES
CONTRIBUTED TO THE LACK OF
ACCOUNTABILITY FOR
PROFESSIONALS WHO COMMIT
MEDICAL MALPRACTICE. ACTIVE OR
GREGIS NEGLIGENCE AND WE AT THE
PATIENTS OFFER. AFTER JORDAN
DIED WE FILED FORMAL COMPLAINTS
WITH THE MEDICAL BOARD TO DATE
NOT ONE INVESTIGATION HAS TAKEN
PLACE NOT ONE INTERVIEW WITH US
HAS TAKEN PLACE. ALL OF OUR
INVESTIGATIONS BUT ONE WERE
CLOSED WITHOUT ANY RESOLUTION
WITHOUT ANY COMMENTS. WITHOUT
ANY DISCUSSION. WE WERE ADVISED
THE MEDICAL BOARD WOULD LIKELY
NOT INVESTIGATE IF WE WERE IN
CIVIL LITIGATION WHICH WE HAVE
TO PAY FOR OUT OF OUR OWN
POCKET DUE TO THESE APPOINTEES
FIGHT AGAINST ANY ADJUSTMENTS
MICRO. EVERY COMPLAINT. THAT
WAS CLOSED WHAT WITH EXCEPTION
TO ONE THAT ONE I INCLUDED A
MEDICALLY CITED PAPER OUTLINING
OUR COMPLAINTS. NOBODY SHOULD
EVER HAVE TO DO THAT. WE DO
EXPECT THAT THIS COMPLAINT WILL
ALSO BE CLOSED. I WELCOME AND
ENCOURAGE EACH ONE OF THESE
APPOINTEES TO CONTACT ME VIA
SENATOR WORKSHOP IS THAT THEY
WISH TO DISCUSS. IN JANUARY TWO
THOUSAND TWENTY ONE. CBS NEWS
REPORTED ON AN EXCLUSIVE
INVESTIGATION INTO STATE
MEDICAL BOARDS WHICH FOUND THAT
STATE MEDICAL BOARDS
RESPONSIBLE FOR DISCIPLINING
DOCTORS. REPEATEDLY INJURED
THEIR PATIENTS OFTEN FAIL TO
DISCIPLINE THOSE SAME DOCTORS.
FOUR YEARS THESE IMPORTED
APPOINTEES FOUGHT TO ALLOW
PATIENTS HARMED BY MEDICAL
NEGLIGENCE TO OBTAIN JUSTICE IN
THE GLOBAL ARENA PROTECTING
PROVIDERS FROM ACCOUNTABILITY.
NOW THEY WILL SIT ON A MEDICAL
BOARD THAT INVESTIGATES LESS
THAN 2% OF COMPLAINTS SUBMITTED.
POLITICAL APPOINTEES TO THE
MEDICAL BOARD THE MEDICAL BOARD
CHARTER TO ENSURE PATIENT
SAFETY AND TO HOLD DOCTORS
ACCOUNTABLE IT'S A CONFLICT OF
INTEREST. ACTUALLY WHEN THOSE
APPOINTEES HAVE FOR THEIR YEARS
WITH THE CMA FOUGHT ALL
ATTEMPTS TO ALLOW THE PUBLIC TO
HOLD THESE PROVIDERS
ACCOUNTABLE. JORDAN'S IFE WAS
VALUABLE SHE IS WORTHY OF
JUSTICE. I NO LONGER TRUST THE
PROFESSION THE MEDICAL BOARD
NOR THESE APPOINTEES TO PROTECT
PATIENTS. OR TO REPRESENT
PATIENT SAFETY AS SUCH I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOU TO OPPOSE
THE APPOINTMENT TO THE
CALIFORNIA MEDICAL BOARD OF
DIRECTORS SORT COULD NOT ADAPT
AND MAHMOUD. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MA'AM- MADAME MODERATOR
NEXT WITNESS PLEASE. THANK YOU
MEDICAL FROM ONE OF THIRTY
THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR COMMITTEE
MEMBERS GOOD AFTERNOON AND
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO ADDRESS YOU TODAY REGARDING
MY OPPOSITION TO THE
APPOINTMENT OF DR RICHARD STARK
AND THE REAPPOINTMENT OF DOCTOR
GET DR GALGIANI DEATH TO THE
MEDICAL BOARD OF CALIFORNIA. MY
NAME IS TAMMY THANK I'M A BOARD
MEMBER WHAT CONSUMER WATCHDOG
AND I LOOK INTO MACULA
CALIFORNIA. THE MISSION OF THE
MEDICAL BOARD IT'S PATIENT
PROTECTION AND IT IS OUTRAGEOUS
THAT PAST PRESIDENT OF THE
CALIFORNIA MEDICAL ASSOCIATION.
A POLITICAL ORGANIZATION WITH A
LONG RECORD OF ACT. UP
OPPOSITION TO REASONABLE
PROVISION OVERSIGHT ARE EVEN
BEING CONSIDERED FOR THIS
CRITICAL PUBLIC SAFETY POSITION.
MY OPPOSITION TO BE THE POINT
VERY PERSONAL. I LOST MY TWENTY
YEAR OLD SON ALEX RADICAL
CHANGE WHILE IN A LAGUNA BEACH
HOSPITAL HIS DOCTOR ORDERED A
LETHAL COMBINATION OF
MEDICATIONS AND ORDERED THAT
ALEX IS VITAL ONLY BE CHECKED
WHILE HE WAS AWAKE. ALEX WAS
GIVEN THAT TALKS A COCKTAIL OF
DRUGS AND LYFT ON MONITORED FOR
MORE THAN SEVEN HOURS. HE WAS
FOUND DEAD DURING MORNING
ROUNDS AND HE WAS ALREADY IN
REGARD TO. I'M THINKING JUSTICE
AND ACCOUNTABILITY FOR MY SON'S
DEATH I TURNED TO THE COURT BUT
WAS DENIED ACCESS BECAUSE OF AN
OUTDATED LAW ENACTED IN
NINETEEN SEVENTY FIVE. SO I
TURNED TO THE MEDICAL BOARD
TRUSTING THEY WOULD STOP THIS
DANGEROUS DOCTOR FROM HARMING
ANOTHER PATIENT. MEDICAL BOARD
INVESTIGATORS AND ATTORNEYS
ATTORNEY GENERAL PROSECUTORS
RECOMMENDED REVOCATION OR
SUSPENSION OF THE DOCTOR'S
LICENSE. HOWEVER AFTER A FOUR
YEAR COMPLAINT PROCESS A DEAL
WAS MADE WITH THE BOARD AND THE
DOCTOR WAS LET OFF WITH A
PUBLIC REPRIMAND A SLAP ON THE
WRIST. ONE VIOLATED MEDICAL
BOARD GUIDELINES AND TOOK PLACE
UNDER THE PRESIDENCY OF DR
DALLAS THE MONITOR OF. EMILY
LIKE MINE DESERVE A MEDICAL
BOARD WE CONTRAST TO FULFILL
THE BOARD'S MISSION OF PATIENTS
PROTECTION WE DO NOT NEED A
BOARD DRIVEN BY THE CMA WHO
WOULD RATHER PROTECT DANGERS
DOCTORS AND PROTECT PATIENTS.
CURRENTLY THERE IS NO DETERRENT
FOR A DOCTOR'S NEGLIGENCE
EITHER IN THE PARK OR BY THE
MEDICAL BOARD BUT I AM LOOKING
FORWARD TO THE FAIRNESS AFTER
ON THE TWENTY TWENTY TO BALLOTS
WHICH WILL UPDATE THE CAP ON
MEDICAL NEGLIGENCE CASES AND
HELPFUL DOCTORS TO ACCOUNT.
AGAIN THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME I
URGE YOU TO HELP PROTECT
CALIFORNIA'S HEALTH CARE
CONSUMERS AND REJECT THE
APPOINTMENT OF DR STORK AND GET
ON THE DANCE. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MA'AM- NEXT WITNESS MET
MADAM MODERATOR. THANK YOUNG
MEDICAL PHONE LINE OF THIRTY
FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN. YEAH
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO SPEAK. HELLO MY NAME IS ALSO
A VERY. NOW I WOULD LIKE TO
PROVIDE A STATEMENT OPPOSING
THE APPOINTMENT OF DR THORPE
AND DOCTOR CONSOLIDATE TO THE
MEDICAL BOARD. I'M ALSO
SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF MY SECTOR
SILVA IT WAS A RESEARCH
SCIENTIST FOCUSED ON RARE
GENETIC DISEASES IN CHILDREN.
HE FOR A VERY HORRIFIC AND
PREVENTABLE MEDICAL ERRORS AT
YOUR. HOSPITAL ENDED HER LIFE.
BASICALLY I'M POSITION FIVE OR
SOMETHING CANADA THE MEDICAL
AND GET PHONE HAVE BEEN. WEEK
BY THE CALIFORNIA MEDICAL THE
FIFTY LOBBYING AT. APPOINTING
ANOTHER FORMER. OF THE TNA WILL
ONLY STRENGTHEN THE CNH AND
CLIMBED OVER THE MEDICAL BOARD
AND HINDER MUCH NEEDED REFORM.
WE SIMPLY DO NOT NEED ANOTHER
LEADER FROM THE CNA ON THE
MEDICAL BOARD. IF ANYTHING THE
MEDICAL BOARD NEEDS MORE
INDEPENDENT VOICES PARTICULARLY
THOSE. FROM THE CATION
APPLICANTS FIVE. I NOT. HOWEVER
I CAN FROM A AT THE- FIND AND
AFTER AND I HAVE WORKED AS A-
IN BANKER. I UNDERSTAND THE
CHALLENGES BALANCING BUSINESS
NEEDS WITH OVERSIGHT AND HOW
EXPENSIVE GOVERNMENT
REGULATIONS CAN CRIPPLE AN
ORGANISATION OR INDUSTRY.
HOWEVER I'VE ALSO SEEN THE UGLY
SIDE OF MEDICINE WHEN INDUSTRY
FAILED TO COLUSA DOWN AND WHEN
THE VISION PLACE THEIR
LIVELIHOOD. OVER. THE CARE OF
THEIR PATIENTS. UNFORTUNATELY
O'CLOCK AFTER TO PICK THE RIGHT.
TRANSPORTATION CARE THE CNA
BLOCK REFORM THAT WOULD UPSET
THAT MANY PATIENTS AND CAL YOU
COULD MY. BLOCKED ALL
ABORIGINAL CHáVEZ OF POWER IN
ANY MEETING WAY. THE FEMALE
HELPED A CO IN CALIFORNIA WITH
HIS THAT. GO ON. WITHOUT ANY. I
HAD CONDITIONS POLITICALLY
MEDICAL TO HIDE THEIR STATE.
HIS VISION HAVE BEEN AND THAT I
STOP QUESTIONS THE PRE. OREGON
WITH. I HAD EVEN PRESSURED TOOK
HOLD THE CALL WITHOUT BEING IN
FOR. THAT AFTER BACKING FOR
DIVISION LIKE WHAT. NOT WITH
LEGAL AND YET IT STILL HAPPENED.
I LOST MY I TURN TO LEGAL
SYSTEM THE CURRENT MEDICAL NOT
LAW SHOULD BE EARLIER ACCESS TO
JUST. I DIDN'T HURTING
OVERSIGHT PEOPLE LIKE THE
MEDICAL. BUT THEN BY HOW BY AND
IN ADEQUATE THEY'RE IMPACTED WE
ARE THE MEDICAL BOARD DISMISSED
I COULD WITH ACTION. THE
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH RISKS PART
OF MY COULD NOT BOARD BUT I
NEVER A. HI AGAIN THROUGH MY TO
KEEP IT ABILITY FOR MY DEATH I
HAVE BEEN TOLD THAT. BOARD IF
THE WHOLE. IF YOU HOME BY
APPOINTING DOOR AND DON DONNA
TO THE MEDICAL BOARD. YOU AYE
FINANCE THE FIRST QUO. THE
BANKS THEIR AND IT HAS BACK
INTO A HEALTHCARE SYSTEM. WE
NEED MORE OBJECTIVE ON THE
BOARD AND NO LEADER OF THE HAD
NAY LET ALONE A CURRENT. CAL
YEAH. THANK YOU MA'AM NEXT
WITNESS. THANK YOU MEADOW FROM
ONE OF FORTY ONE YOUR LINER
OPEN. THANK YOU NAME IS A HUNCH
CAN YOU GO ME I'M SORRY- YOU
REPEAT YOUR NAME I CAN'T YOU
BUT I UNDER. WHAT YOU. ART
AGAIN THEY YOU MY NAME TO. MINE
MY NAME IS HUNCH. THANK YOU-
IBM ACCORDING IN FOR. OF THOSE
TO YOU. ACTORS CAN A DAILY
MULTIPLE. AND DOCTOR. NOW ONE.
I THERE ARE. BOB BURNS. AND WE
NEED TO THEM HOPE ASSURING. THE
RESOLVE MATTERS I'M A THAT THEY
ARE TO IN TODAY. BOB MY CONCERN
IS- ABOUT THE MEDICAL BOARD
BROUGHT THERE ARE AND ACTIVISTS.
MIKE MIKE IS ABOUT MCCARTY
DECENT- INDUCED MEETING SENATOR
ARE BREAST IT DID NINE DAYS TO
COMPLETE PROCESS BUT THESE
DOCTORS THEY HAVE ALREADY BEEN
CONTROL OVER THE PROCESS IT IS
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL AND THE
INVESTIGATORS WHO DESPITE. HOW
LONG WILL IT TAKE AND- AND THAT
THE MEMBERS OF THE MEDICAL
BOARD WILL BE ABLE TO HEAR
THOSE MATTERS ARE NOT- IN THIS
MATTER IF MENTIONED BUT HE
KNOWS AND I EXPECT AND LOOK AT
THE PUNISHED. BY I WORK AT MY
CONCERN IS THE PROSECUTION OF
CALPERS ACTUALLY AMERICANS
CHRISTIANS MUSLIMS ALL DODD
DETECTED IT IS UNDER PROCESS- I
HAVE FOR MY LIFE AT NIGHT WE
HAVE TESTIFIED BEFORE. AND IF
YOU TIMES IN TWO THOUSAND
THIRTEEN- FOR EXAMPLE WE GAVE A
SPEECH BEFORE SENATE SENATOR-
CARPET QUOTE THAT HE WASN'T
ASSEMBLYMEMBERS HE WAS VERY
COMMON TO WORK FOR US- IN THE
PIVOTAL SMART- THE UPRISING THE
MEDICAL BOARD FOR THE NEXT
SCHOOL YEAR- I AM CALLING
PRIMARILY- I HAVE OVER. FIFTEEN
YEARS OF EXPERIENCE WITH OUR
STATE- DENYING RIGHT TO BUY TO
ALMOST ANY DOCTOR DOCTOR FOR
THE MICHIGAN SAN JOAQUIN.
COUNTY ABOUT- I MEAN IT'S BEEN
THIRTEEN AND IT HAS BEEN NOT
ANY HATING NORTH HE TRIED COURT
ANY. FOR A ABOUT MY BOARD- TO
OUR CONCERN IS THE- YOU KNOW
NOT THE PROTECTION OF BUT THE-
OF SELECT INTO THE AND STATE OF.
HELLO CUTTING COUNTY PROVIDE
THAT ACCOUNT HOSPITAL APPLIED
FOR LIFE AND UP TO TWENTY FOUR
MONTHS OF CREDIT TO CHANGE. AND
UP TWO MONTHS THE DENIED THAT
LICENSE AGENT AND THE FOR NOT
COME TWENTY FOUR MONTHS ONCE IT.
SIR LET LET ME LET ME ENTER FOR
SO I JUST WANNA SURE I'M YOUR
IN SICK. OF DODD. I MY- GOOD
ANA DE AND DOCKED THORPE BUT
YOU WILL HAVE CONCERNS ABOUT
OTHER PARTS OF THE PROCESS. WE
HAVE BEEN EXACTLY SO OKAY I
MEAN WHEN I WANTED TO FIND OUT
I WANT I WANNA CAN FIND THAT
THE PUBLIC TESTIMONY TO THE
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION AND I DID
UNDERSTAND YOU SUPPORT THESE
THREE DOCTORS. SO IF YOU CAN
COMBINE YOUR BROMANCE. WELL THE
CHANGES THAT THE GOVERNMENT CAN
GET BACK HOME AND ASA. RIGHT
THE CRISIS BUT THE INSTRUCTORS
ABOUT THE HEY YOU KNOW WHAT
DAVID WHO WHO WHO WHO IS WHO IS
AUTHORIZED. TO SCHEDULE BY
HITTING- SO ALL I'M SAYING IS
BACK UP. THE YOU LIKE BACKUP
BURKE NINE. ABOUT THE OTHER
AMERICA THEY DON'T HAVE CONTROL
OVER THE- OKAY TO GET THE
PORTIONS THAT THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL'S AND AGAINST IT THEY
ARE CONTROLLING- LIFE AND
IDENTIFIED SUPPORT PEOPLE. I
UNDERSTAND. IF WE IF WE IF WE
HAVE PROBLEMS THE DA AND
ATTORNEY FOR BACK TO BACK WITH
A FESTIVE I THE LOCAL HOSPITAL
WHEN WE GO TO SO THAT
OFFICIALLY. OVER HERE SHE SHE
RECEIVED- YOU KNOW STIPULATION
SIGN POST CONCERNS ARE I. NEED
TO I NEED TO INTERRUPT YOU
AGAIN I WANT TO CONFIRM FIRM
YOU THIS IS IT YOU ARE SPEAKING
IN SUPPORT AND THAT IS GOOD I
APPRECIATE THAT OTHER THINGS
SEEM NOT TO BE RELATED. TO THIS
A CONFIRMATION SO I WOULD- I
THANK YOU FOR YOUR SUPPORT AND
REGISTERING YOUR SUPPORT WE
HEARD THE OTHER COMMENTS
RELATED TO INVESTIGATORS THE
AG'S OFFICE WE WILL. WE WILL
ADDRESS THOSE ISSUES IN A
DIFFERENT FORMAT THROUGH- THE
CONFIRMATION OF THE NEXT
ATTORNEY GENERAL SHOULD WE GET
THAT OPPORTUNITY SO FOR NOW. I
THANK YOU FOR THAT AND- MANTA
MODERATOR I WOULD ASK. YOU TO
GO TO THE NEXT WITNESS THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. AND THAT IT
WILL COME FROM THE LINE OF.
YOUR LINE IS THE- THANK YOU.
WHEN IS MERRY ALREADY AND I'M
THE SAFETY. ADVOCATES OTHER CAL.
I'D FIRST LIKE TO POINT OUT
THAT IN THE LAST EIGHTEEN
MONTHS THE DISCIPLINARY RATE
FOR THE MEDICAL BOARD UNDER
DOCTORS CAN ON THE JOB AND POOR
BECAUSE FALL INTO JUST THREE
POINT FIVE PERCENT. THIS IS THE
LOWEST IT'S BEEN FOR A LONG
TIME- I AM AGAINST THE
CONFIRMATION OF DOCTORS THERE'S
ANOTHER DOZEN RICHARD THORPE IS
BOARD MEMBERS OF THE MEDICAL
BOARD OF CALIFORNIA. BOTH HAVE
AN INHERENT CONFLICT OF
INTEREST SINCE BOTH HAVE BEEN
PRESIDENT OF THE DOCTOR LOBBY
GROUP THE CALIFORNIA MEDICAL
ASSOCIATION. THIS GROUP PUTS
THE FINANCIAL INTEREST OF
DOCTORS OF THE PATIENT SAFETY
IN CALIFORNIA. IF YOU MAY HAVE
BEEN AGAINST EACH AND EVERY
PATIENT SAFETY ISSUE AND
PROPOSITION ON CALIFORNIA
BALLOTS FOR NUMBER OF YEARS. DR
CANNELLA JEFF HAS PERSONALLY
FINANCED WITH THE EMMY AWARD
THAT GIVES ONE THOUSAND DOLLARS
EACH YEAR TO A DOCTOR WHO
BRINGS IN THE MOST NEW MEMBERS.
BOTH DOCTORS GOING ON A
DIFFERENT FLOOR MAINTAIN ACTIVE
MEMBERSHIP IN THE FAMILY FILE
ON THE MEDICAL BOARD WHICH IS A
CHANGE CONFLICT OF INTEREST OUR
DOCTOR CORP- EARLIER TODAY ALSO
WAS NOT COMPLETELY HONEST. WHEN
HE SAID HE WAS AGAINST THE FREE
UP WHAT HE SAID HE VOTED FOR
THE FREE INCREASED WHEN THEY
INITIALLY BROUGHT THAT. UP WHEN
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR- CAN. OF
PERCH MEYER IT ALL HE AND DR
GONNA DO WORK- VERY MUCH
AGAINST FEE INCREASE GENERATED
VERY THAT THEY NOT. IT THE ONLY
DECIDED TO VOTE IT WHEN IT
BECAME. OBVIOUS THE ONLY ULTRA.
WAS AMERICA BOARD GOING
INTENTIONAL THE STATE. O. DOT
YOU CAN ONLY GIVE ALSO GAVE THE
IMPRESSION THAT HE WAS FOR THE
APPROPRIATIONS. CURRENTLY LAW
OUT OF YOU KNOW WHAT FIFTH OF
TWO THOUSAND. HE ACTUALLY VOTED
AGAINST IT AND THE FOLLOWING
YEAR WE ALSO WORK. ON OTHER
VERSIONS. ARE SO HE ONLY VOTED.
AGAINST OF THE BOARD ONLY
DECIDED TO BACK THE PATIENT
RIGHT TO KNOW BILL. WHEN IT
BECAME OBVIOUS THAT IT WAS
UNTENABLE SITUATION FOLLOWING
THE CASE THROUGH. THE VERY-
PUBLIC HATES IS THE DOCTOR
LARRY NASSAR AND DR GEORGE TEN
MILLIGRAMS. THERE ACTUALLY
THOUGHT PIECES. YOUR
COMPLICATED TRUSTING DOCTOR
BEEN ON THE OF BLOOD FROM FOR I
URGE YOU TO BE THE COMPANY. I
DON'T RECALL BECOME OF DOCTOR.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
TIME. THANK YOU VERY MUCH- NEXT
WITNESS. THANK YOU MEDICAL FROM
NINE THIRTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HI MY NAME IS ERIC
ANDERSON I'M A CONSTITUENT OF
SENATOR HERTZBERG IN THE LOS
ANGELES AREA I DIDN'T REALIZE
WOULD BE LIMITED TIME MIGHT BUT
I DID SEND A LETTER NEARLY A
YEAR AGO SO PLEASE READ THAT. I
WILL JUST HIGHLIGHT SOME NOTES
I MADE DURING THE HEARING
BEFORE I REACH MY PREPARED
STATEMENT I NEED TO CORRECT
SOME OF THE MISINFORMATION
THESE DOCTORS AFFECT YOU.
BECAUSE THEY'VE BEEN LATIN
TRUTHFUL WITH YOU AND THAT
ALONE IS ENOUGH TO KEEP THEM
FROM SERVING ON THE BOARD. ONE
THE MEDICAL BOARD FOLLOW THEIR
OWN GUIDELINES PROBABLY LESS
THAN 25% OF THE TIME WE HAVE
THE EVIDENCE PROVING THAT THESE
APPLICANTS WERE NOT TRUTHFUL
WITH YOU ABOUT THAT. YOU IT IS
NOT THE STANDARD OF PROCEDURE
TO INTERVIEW COMPLAINT I FILED
A NUMBER OF COMPLAINTS ON
BEHALF OF MY FAMILY AND OTHER
VICTIMS AND KNOW FOR A FACT
THAT THEY ALMOST NEVER
INTERVIEW A COMPLAINANT. BEFORE
THEY CLOSE THE COMPLAINT THEY
ONLY INTERVIEW IT IF IT MOVES
ON TO THE NEXT LEVEL I'M SORRY
TO HEAR THAT SENATOR BATES MADE
UP OUR MIND OR HEARING THE
PUBLIC SPEAK THAT IS OF GREAT
CONCERN TO ME. MY FAMILY HAS
FALLEN VICTIM TO MEDICAL ERRORS
THREE TIMES SINCE TWO THOUSAND
AND THREE AND ALL OF MY
COMPLAINTS HAVE BEEN CLOSED
WITHOUT INVESTIGATION. AND I
NOW VOLUNTEER FULL TIME AS A
PATIENT SAFETY ADVOCATE IN
HONOR OF MY SISTER'S DEATH. I
CO RUN THE NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATION CALLED THE PATIENT
BACK THE LEAGUE CARE IN THE SAN
FERNANDO VALLEY WE SPENT THE
LEGISLATURE REPORT FOR THE
SUNSET REVIEW IN TWENTY
FOURTEEN CALLED THE MEDICAL
FARCE THE CALIFORNIA WHICH WENT
LARGELY IGNORED AND WE WILL BE
PROVIDING YOU MORE INFORMATION
FOR THE NEXT FUNDS THAT REVIEW.
YOU MAY NOT KNOW THE SPECIFIC
BUT LESS THAN ONE THIRD OF
CALIFORNIA'S DOCTORS USED TO BE
MEMBERS OF THE CALIFORNIA
MEDICAL ASSOCIATION AND OTHER
THIRD OF OUR MEMBERS A PORTION
OF THOSE ARE MANDATED TO BE
MEMBERS BY THEIR LOCAL MEDICAL
SOCIETY. THE CMA WE'LL A LOT OF
MONEY AND POLITICAL POWER IN
THE STATE EVEN THOUGH MOST
DOCTORS DON'T EVEN BELONG. A
FEW YEARS BACK WHEN SENATOR
JERRY HILL WAS BRINGING FORTH
IS OFF THE BILL THAT REQUIRES
DOCTORS ON PROBATION TO INFORM
THEIR PATIENTS ABOUT STATUS.
THE CMA WAS VERY BOTH LOCAL A
OPPOSITE. TO IT. AND LIKEWISE
THE DEATH GONNA DE WHO WAS. AS
THE PRESENT OF THE MEADOW BOARD
TIME WHAT ALSO VOCAL NOT IN THE-
OF THE LARGEST. THERE'S OF
ONLINE OF HIM IN OPPOSITION.
GONNA DEATH ALSO DONATES A LOT
OF MONEY TO THE CALIFORNIA
MEDICAL ASSOCIATION WHEN I TOLD
THE MEDICAL BOARD ABOUT MY
PERSONAL MEDICAL NEGLIGENCE
VERY. DETAILED GONNA DEATH THAT
TO ME ON AN ELEVATOR RIDE
TOGETHER BUT I SHOULD KNOW
BETTER THAN TO. GO TO AOUT DR.
AFTER PICKING MY JAW UP OFF THE
FLOOR I REALIZE THAT HE HAS NO
CLUE ABOUT HOW REAL VICTIMS ARE
SUFFERING. WITH THE SYSTEM AND
A LOT OF PEOPLE DON'T GET TO
PICK AND CHOOSE THEIR DOCTORS.
ONE OF THE DOCTORS THAT WAS
AFFILIATED WITH CONTAMINATING
OR OF BEING KNOWN AS DR HARI
REDDI WHO SEXUALLY ASSAULTED A
FOURTEEN YEAR OLD GIRL. DEB'S
FIRST BEAUTY ON THE MEDICAL
BOARD WHAT THE FED ON A PANEL
THAT RESTORED. THAT SEX
OFFENDERS LICENSE. READY IF THE
BROTHER IN LAW OF. READY OF PER
HELPED WHO WENT ON TO DONATE
FORTY MILLION DOLLARS TO DEATH
NEW MEDICAL SCHOOL. I AM
IMPLORING. COULD NOT CONFIRM
THE EMPLOYEE APPOINTEE. WE NEED
A REAL PATIENT ADVOCATE SERVING
ON THE MEDICAL BOARD NOT BY
DOCTORS. A NUMBER OF OUR
ADVOCATES HAVE PUT IN
APPLICATIONS TO SERVE ON THE
MEDICAL BOARD. AND THEY WON'T
EVEN CONSIDER US. WE ARE TRYING
TO WORK WITH THE MEDICAL BOARD
TO FIX ALL OF ITS PROBLEMS BUT
WHEN OUR GOVERNMENT KEEPS
STACKING THE BOARD WITH
NOMINEES LIKE THIS. IT MAKES IT
NEARLY IMPOSSIBLE. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER ANDERSON AYE
NEXT WITNESS PLEASE. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR OUR LAST WITNESS
WILL COME FROM ONE OF UP. FIFTY
ONE. MADAM CHAIR THIS IS
RANDALL HAGER I APOLOGIZE FOR
APPEARING OUT OF ORDER I HAVE
THE SUPPORT ON BEHALF OF THE
PSYCHIATRIC PHYSICIANS ALLIANCE
OF CALIFORNIA FOR ALL THREE
POSITIONS. A SURPRISE FOR US
EITHER BY REPUTATION OR THROUGH
PERSONAL AND PROFESSIONAL
CONTACT NO EACH OF THESE
INDIVIDUAL DOCTORS FOR THE HIGH
CHARACTER THEIR PROFESSIONALISM
THEIR DEDICATION TO PATIENT
SAFETY. AND WE COMMEND THEM TO
YOUR SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK
YOU SO FOR THE RECORD THAT WAS
A PERSON IN SUPPORT OF THE
APPOINTEES. ARE THAT WAS THE
LAST WITNESS MADAME MODERATOR.
THAT IS CORRECT MANAGER. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. HI TO ALL OF THE
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC WHO SPOKE
IN SUPPORT AND OPPOSITION. I
WANT TO SAY THANK YOU SOME OF
THOSE ODD COMMENTS WERE.
DIFFICULT FOR US TO HEAR- AND I
EXPRESS MY- SORROW TO YOU ARE.
FOR THAT LET ME BRING IT BACK I
TO THE MEMBERS OF THE OF THE
COMMITTEE TO SEE IF THERE ARE
ADDITIONAL COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS AT THIS TIME FOR MY
COLLEAGUES. MR MAJORITY LEADER
GO AHEAD. THANK YOU THANK YOU
MINUTE BG. YOU AYE I ALLUDED IN
MY OPENING AND- SENATOR. FROM
SANTA CRUZ- ARTICULATED BETTER
THAN I DID AT THE ISSUE OF
TRUST. THE ISSUE BEING AN
HONEST BROKER NOT CAPTURED BY
THE INDUSTRIES WHAT HE SAID-
MISTER LAYERED. AND WHAT WE
HEARD I THINK- IN THE TONE
WORDS AND TEMPERAMENT OF THE
FOLKS THAT WERE OPPOSING- WAS
THAT ISSUE KEEP COMING BACK
WHATEVER THE REASON IS IT'S THE
BALANCE THAT WE HAVE TO.
ACHIEVE HERE AND SO AT EIGHT IN
THE MOST- HUMAN WAYS POSSIBLE
YOU KNOW WHERE YOU WHERE THERE
WAS RECOMMENDATIONS OF THE LIKE
LOOK IT'S HARD AYE AYE WE HAVE
BEFORE HERE WOULD THAT THE
PROFESSIONALS MAKE
RECOMMENDATIONS TO US. AND
SOMETIMES YOU DON'T AGREE AND
THAT'S OK THAT'S OUR JUDGMENT
THAT'S OUR JOB BUT IN ORDER TO
INSPIRE TRUST IN THE PROCESS WE
HAVE TO DO EXTRAORDINARY DUE
DILIGENCE TO MAKE SURE THAT
PEOPLE UNDERSTAND THAT WE HAVE
A RATIONAL BASIS FOR
DISAGREEING WITH SOME OF THE
PROFESSIONALS THAT WITH RESPECT
TO THE RECOMMENDATIONS THAT
THEY MAKE BEFORE THIS COMMITTEE.
AND SO TO HEAR JUST VERY
BRIEFLY EACH OF YOU AS YOU.
PROCESS THE UPON THE FOLKS THAT
SPOKE HERE. AND THIS THEME OF
TRUST. AND THIS IS A LARGER
ISSUE THAT WE'VE BEEN FACING
FOR MANY YEARS AS I SAID IN THE
OPENING. AND TO KIND OF GET
YOUR INSIGHTS AND YOUR
REACTIONS TO. I TO THE
SPECIFICS OF THEIR TESTIMONY.
BUT TO THE UNDERLYING
FRAMEWORK- THAT MR LATER TALKED
ABOUT. OF BEING HONEST BROKERS
ARE NOT CAPTURED BY THE
INDUSTRY. AND WHEN OUR JOB IS
TO INSPIRE CONFIDENCE. IF YOU
START WITH THE WHERE ONCE THERE.
OUR DOCTOR CAN ON A DEVIL LET'S
START WITH YOU THE LONGEST
SERVING MEMBER WILL GO TO DR
THORPE AND THEN LASTLY TO DR
MAHMOUD. I THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR- SENATOR I WANT YOUR TO
LOOK LIKE MY ENTIRE LIFE STORY.
ARE VERY VERY PLEASED WHERE I
WORK. WATER HAVE DONE
UNDERWATER HAVE BEEN ON THE
BOARD AND I HAVE BEING TRUTHFUL
I KNOW PEOPLE HAVE AN ISSUE
WITH. ARE YOU HOLDING SOME
LEADERSHIP PORTION OF WORK
FORWARD THIRTEEN YEARS AGO I
UNDERSTAND THAT. BAR GRAPH
BENSON PERFECT WHAT ARE YOU
DOING THE MEDICAL FOR. M. AS
PEOPLE HAVE ISSUES WHEN WE
DISCIPLINE OUR DOCTOR IN THE
MEDICAL STAFF OR IN THE IN MY
OWN DEPARTMENT SOLD MARC I'M
LOOKING NOW FOR IS ALL OF THESE
I LOOKED AT MY ENTIRE CAREER IS.
WORKS BEST FOR THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA OUR BACKS BECAUSE
THAT'S THE WAY I WAS TRAINED.
ARTIE'S PLANNED PARALYZED-
WHAT'S GOOD FOR MEDICATIONS SO
YOU'RE FREE IF SOMEBODY WAS
BACK TO THE PHYSICIANS I'M
PRETTY TOUGH ON HIM. SO ARE YOU
ARE YOU. I UNDERSTAND THIS OF
THE SOME OF THEM ARE PRETTY
ANGRY AND I'M GLAD HE'S COMING
ON US BECAUSE WE WERE THERE.
ARE CINEMA SOLICITATION. OFTEN
TRIED TO BURGER DOCTORS BUT
ALSO THE SAME ASSOCIATION ALSO
WARRANTS THE BEST PART WE'RE
LOOKING FOR ALL CALIFORNIANS
SO. I DON'T TAKE IT PERSONAL. I
ACTUALLY. COMMENTS AND DO
DEVICE I CAN DO. REALLY LAST
THANK YOU. CHARISMATIC A
MEASURE PUSH IT GOES TO ON
DOCTOR YOU KNOW I THINK HE WAS
IN WITH. MICRO IS THE
HISTOLOGICAL IN WITH- LIABILITY
BACK AND FORTH- THE TO MY
GRANDMA'S SEE ARE A I THINK
IT'S AN OUNCE YEAH MICRA- AND
SO OFTEN YOU JUST TEACH PRESS
CAUSES SOME OF THESE ISSUES
WHERE SOME OF THE FOLKS THE
TESTIFIED WERE FRUSTRATED ABOUT
THE LIMITATIONS ON OF LIABILITY
OF THE E. BECAUSE OF MICRA IN
YOUR ROLE IN MY CAREER A FEW
COULD YOU SHARE SOME THOUGHTS
AND TO TRY TO INSPIRE PEOPLE OF
CONFIDENCE THAT YOUR AFFAIR. A
PERSON WITH REGARD TO DEALING
WITH THE MICRO ISSUE. I JUST
WANNA HEAR FROM YOU THANK YOU
SO MUCH SIR. THE QUESTION IS MY-
IN- THE FIGHTING AGAIN START TO
DEFEAT PROP FORTY SIX IN TWO
THOUSAND FOURTEEN- AND THE
ISSUE WAS IN PART RELATED TO
MICRO BUT IT WAS ALSO TIED IN
WITH A COUPLE OF OTHER THINGS
WHICH WERE REALLY. NOT READY
FOR PRIME TIME THE CURES
DATABASE FOR INSTANCE AT THAT
TIME WASN'T. EXACTLY THE CURES-
ADMINISTRATOR ADMITTED THAT IF
WE WERE TO EIGHT MAKE IT
MANDATORY FOR EVERY DOCTOR IN
THE STATE HE USE THAT DATABASE
LIKE WE DO TODAY AND WE
ENCOURAGE IT WE TEACHER AND AT.
BOTH YOU AND I MEAN I TEACHER
NOW I'VE USED IT. I WOULD
USUALLY TWENTY FOURTEEN BUT IT-WASN'T READY FOR THE KIND O
PRIMETIME STUFF THAT THEY WERE.
ASKING BIG THE LEGISLATOR THE
INITIATIVE TO DO. SO THEY THE
OPPOSITION TO THE BALLOT
INITIATIVE WAS THE WHOLE THING
IT WASN'T JUST. BE CONCERNED
ABOUT THE MALPRACTICE CAP-
SPEAKING YOU KNOW SO I THINK
THERE'S- THERE IS A UP- YOU
KNOW THIS THIS IDEA THAT
SOMEHOW BECAUSE I WAS INVOLVED
IN THAT- FIGHT TO TRY TO-
OVERCOME A POORLY CRAFTED BILL.
SOME ARE NOT- I'M NOT GONNA
LEADERSHIP CAPABILITIES OR THE
ASPECTS TO SERVE ON THIS
MEDICAL BOARD IS AN ERROR IT IS
NOT RIGHT. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
INSIGHTS AND MICROPHYLLA PUSHES.
DID YOU WANT MISTER MAHMOUD TO
SPEAK TO YOUR QUESTION YEAH
THAT WOULD BE GOOD THANK YOU SO
MUCH A MINIATURE MISSED A
DOCUMENT. YES I BELIEVE HE
WOULD REPEAT BY SAMANTHA BEFORE
IT HAVE NOTHING TO HIDE ARE YOU
HAVE NO VESTED INTEREST IN THE
NEW RENTALS. I AM BUILDING DID
TO. PROTECT AND- FIGHT FOR THE
CALIFORNIANS AND CONSUMERS AND-
I DON'T THINK SO MANY PEOPLE
HAVE ANY. CONCERN AND NEED TO
BE VERY HONEST MAYBE I'M NEWER
AND THEY HAVEN'T SEEN BUT- I.
D. HELLO MY LATEST START UP
FUNDING PEOPLE. AND EVERY STEP
AND NOW ALL OF THEM STAND UP
AND CALIFORNIANS AND CONSUMERS
WOULD BE MY TOP PRIORITY. AND
THEIR PROTECTION THIS SAFETY
IS- GOAL OF. MY LIFE AND I'LL
CONTINUE TO DO THAT TO. WHAT
I'VE BEEN DOING- ON A LOCAL
BASIS HERE IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA AND STATE WIDE AND-
HOPING TO MAKE. SOME DIFFERENCE
IN PEOPLE'S LIVES IN CALIFORNIA.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. OTHER
COLLEAGUE. ANYTHING FURTHER.
OKAY MR OF VICE CHAIRMAN. THANK
YOU MAYOR PRO TEM. SO ONE OF
THE PEOPLE IN OPPOSITION SURE
THAT 95% OF ALL CASES ARE
CLOSED WITHOUT ANY ACTION- IT
IS THAT IS THAT ACCURATE
INFORMATION. OF ANY ANYONE YEAH.
ALTHOUGH I DON'T BELIEVE THAT
THAT IS AN ACCURATE STATEMENT
THE NUMBERS ARE MORE- INDEED
THE DISCIPLINE RATE IS MORE
LIKE- 8% OF THE OF THE
COMPLAINTS ARE BELIEVE RATHER
IS NOT A BIG DIFFERENCE MINUTES
TRUE THAT IN ITS 8% VERSUS 5%
BUT THAT'S BECAUSE A MORE
ACCURATE PERCENTAGE GOOD I KNOW
BUT I'M NOT SURE OF THAT
APPROACH AND WIND- THESE
NOMINATIONS ARE COMING TO THE
FLOOR BUT I'M I LIKE TO MAYBE
SEE THE LAST FOUR FIVE YEARS-
SOME KIND OF YOU KNOW MATRIX
OF- I CASES AND THEN- BUT
SOMETHING ELSE. A NUMBER OF
PEOPLE BROUGHT UP I ACTUALLY
ASKED A QUESTION I WISH I COULD
REMEMBER WHICH DOCTOR ANSWERED
IT. BUT NUMBER PEOPLE BROUGHT
UP THAT THESE CASES ARE CLOSE
WITHOUT EVER HER INTERVIEWING
THE CLAIM IT SO. I'D LIKE TO
KNOW WHAT AGAIN IS THAT IS THAT
STANDARD- PROCEDURES AND SO IF
IT IS AN OBVIOUSLY WAS VIOLATED
IN THE CASES THAT WE HEARD
TODAY. WOULD ANYONE LIKE TO THE
TO THE TO THE DIRT ON THE BOARD
THE LONGEST WAIT I WOULD
APPRECIATE. FROM CARRILLO SAID
THAT'S NOT THE STANDARD
PROCEDURE ACTUALLY THE
INVESTIGATOR IS SUPPOSED TO
TALK TO THE- NUMBER OF THE
PATIENTS OR THEIR FAMILY
MEMBERS AND GET THEIR
PERSPECTIVE SO THANKS. THAT'S
NOT TRUE THEY DID NOT- I THINK
THAT'S A VIOLATION. OKAY THANK
YOU. THIRTY THORPE. YOU KNOW
HONESTLY- I DON'T KNOW AND- I
SEE THAT WE HAVE BEEN ON THE
BOARD FOR EIGHTEEN MONTHS BUT I
AM WE'LL GET THOSE AT THE LEVEL
THAT I GET INFORMATION I EIGHT
I HONESTLY JUST DON'T KNOW IF
THAT'S THE CASE. ALL RIGHT
THANK YOU SIR. THANK YOU- I-
THINK THERE'S A LITTLE BIT OF
INFORMATION THAT WE CAN MAKE
THE REQUEST OF. OF STAFF RULES
COMMITTEE STAFF TO FOLLOW UP- I
WOULD ASK IS ARE ALL OF THESE
NUMBERS RELATED TO THE NUMBER
OF CASES. INVESTIGATED BUT BEEN
GO TO THE NEXT LEVEL THE NEXT
LEVEL THE PERCENTAGES IT IS ALL
OF THIS PUBLIC INFORMATION ARE.
CAN CAN ANY OF YOU DOCTOR COULD
NOT A DEV IT IS THIS AVAILABLE
TO THE PUBLIC READILY- YES
HURRICANE SIX. IT'S PRESENTED
TO THE BOARD MEETING AND
EXHIBIT A BIRD DOG. K. THANK
YOU. TOM I DO THINK I WOULD
LIKE SOME CLARITY FROM THE
MEDICAL BOARD STAFF RELATED TO
THE ISSUE OF WHETHER OR- WHEN
THERE IS AN INVESTIGATION THE
COMPLAINT AND IS. ARE ABLE TO
BE CONSULTED OR HAVE AN
INTERVIEW AND SO- TO MY STAFF
WHO I KNOW WE'RE LISTENING
BETWEEN NOW AND SHOULD THESE
APPOINTMENTS COME TO THE FLOOR
DEPENDING UPON THE OUTCOME
TODAY I WOULD LIKE TO KNOW THE
RESPONSE TO THAT SO IF WE CAN
GET THAT INFORMATION. I THINK
WHAT WE HAVE BEFORE US CLEARLY.
THESE APPOINTMENTS ARE ARE VERY
CRITICAL APPOINTMENTS OUTSIDE
TO CONSUMERS AND TO THE PUBLIC.
AND CLEARLY- YOU KNOW WE HEARD
FROM SOME PEOPLE TODAY AND-
IT'S HARD FOR US IN THE
POSITION THAT WE'RE IN AND WE
DON'T DEAL WITH THESE CASES ON
A WEEKLY BASIS YOU'RE PART OF
PANELS YOU HEAR. YOU GIVE OF
YOUR TIME AND- CLEARLY WE'VE
HEARD FROM PEOPLE IN SUPPORT
AND WE HAVE HEARD FROM. MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC WHO HAVE NOT HAD
THE BEST RESULT. FOR THEIR
FAMILY MEMBERS AND THAT'S
ALWAYS VERY DIFFICULT AND HARD
TO HEAR- ON MY DAD- SO IT MAKES
IT DIFFICULT FOR US- WILL BE
HERE PROBABLY THOSE WHO ARE
MOST ARE AGGRIEVED BUT- I THINK
THAT THERE IS SOME. REALLY
IMPORTANT PIECE HERE ABOUT THE
PUBLIC'S TRUST TO THE TO THE
POINT OF THE TRUST THAT THE
PUBLIC HAS TO PLACE AND CLEARLY
YOUR VOLUNTEERS YOU ON'T YOU
DON'T NEED TO SERVE YOU
OBVIOUSLY HAVE BUSY LIVES SO I
APPRECIATE THAT IT IS A VERY
SERIOUS RESPONSIBILITY TO SERVE
IN ADDITION TO EVERYTHING ELSE
YOU DO. BUT IT IS AN
EXPECTATION AND SO IT IS HARD
FOR US TO HEAR FROM PEOPLE WHO
FEEL LIKE THE SYSTEM HAS NOT-
SERVE THEM WELL ALL OUR OUR
ADDRESS THEIR CONCERNS AND- YOU
KNOW THEY'RE NOT IN THE
POSITION TO JUDGE THAT'S WHY.
THERE IS A LEGAL SYSTEM THAT
ALLOWS THEM TO DO THAT THAT'S
WHY THERE ARE OTHER PROTECTIONS
AND INSTITUTIONS IN PLACE LIKE
THIS AND SO. THAT OUR PUBLIC
TRUST PEACE IS VERY IMPORTANT I
THINK YOU KNOW I WOULD LIKE-
THIS IS BEEN ONE OF THE MORE-
IN DEPTH. RULES COMMITTEE
HEARINGS IN TERMS OF THE
CONVERSATION- CLEARLY WE'VE HAD
SOME DIFFICULT WHAT'S IN THE
PAST BUT THIS ONE HAS BEEN.
MORE SO I ACTUALLY. WOULD LIKE
EACH OF YOU TO CLOSE TO GIVE ME
SOME CLOSING COMMENTS ON YOUR
COMMITMENT TO THE PUBLIC AND
YOUR ABILITY TO BALANCE THESE
RESPONSIBILITIES THAT YOU HAVE.
IT WOULD- AND THEN WILL YOU I
WILL MOVE FOR A MOTION AND I
WILL TAKE SEPARATE MOTIONS ON
ALL THREE JUST BECAUSE THERE
WERE PEOPLE WHO. MADE COMMENTS
IN SUPPORT OF SOME NOT ALL AS A
GROUP SO I THINK IT WOULD BE
BETTER TO JUST TAKE EACH MOTION
SEPARATELY WHEN WE GET THERE
BUT- DOCTOR GONNA DEVIL OF ME
START WITH YOU TO MAKE
CONCLUDING COMMENTS THAT I'LL
GO TO DR THORPE AND THEN TO DR.
MAHMOUD AND I APPRECIATE YOUR
PATIENCE AND TOM BUT I DO THINK
THIS IS IMPORTANT- TO MURDER
CHAIR ARE OUR YEARLY. I
ANSWERED YOUR CALL SINCE I
ACTUALLY ARE COMMENTED ON THE
WALK MY MISSION IN LIFE FEES
ARE INCLUDING FROM EVERYTHING
FROM PUBLIC HOSPITAL MINOR
ROLLING SEEING THERE WERE SMALL
MY MISSION OF THE CULTURE OF
SAN MARINO COMMITTEE MEDICAL
CENTER WITH TAKING CARE FOR- MY
NOTIFICATIONS IS A LOT BIGGER
MISSION OR FORTY YEARS. I'M
MIAMI THEN I MOVED TO THIS
COMMUNITY FORTY YEARS AGO FORTY
ONE YEARS AGO MY WIFE AND I
MORE THAN ONE SMALL SUBCOMPACT
CAR IS COMMUNITY HAS BEEN SO
BURKE I WAS ABLE TO GET MY
GROUP I WAS ABLE TO CONVINCE
THE CONTACTS ONLINE YOU KNOW.
IN SPITE OF THE ENTIRE
OPPOSITION FROM THE ENTIRE.
HOSPITAL INDUSTRY L. A. COUNTY.
BAKER OF THE PEOPLE. AND SO ON
MISSION IS NOT GOING TO CHANGE.
WHAT THE WORLD WOULD THE HIGH
SCORE. CARE FOR ALL THE
PATIENTS CANCER. AND MEDICAL
BOARD PARTY S. PART IT IS HARD
WHERE I WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT.
THE SUB STERN DAHLE. ARE
ENROLLED ARE YOU HAVE A GOOD
DAY. OUR YEAH WE- THE.
EDUCATIONAL AND THEN TRY OF SO
THAT YOU ACTUALLY PROVE. FROM
SOUTH STE DOCTORS TO FOR IN
CALIFORNIA THAT'S THE WE DON'T
THREE YOURSELF TRAINING OUR GO
A LICENSE ALL MY MISSION ONE
CHANGE ORDER WE'RE GOOD TRULY
APPRECIATE THEM VERY YOUR YOUR
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK. YOU
DOCTOR. DR THORPE. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR- I WILL JUST
REAFFIRM WHAT I SAID EARLIER
AND THAT IS- MY AGE- MY ROLE IN
THE MEDICAL BOARD IS THAT OF A
CONSUMER ADVOCATE. AND PATIENT
PROTECTION. THERE IS LONG THERE
IS NO WAY THAT I HE WILL BE-
YOU ARE DETERRED FROM THAT'S
WHAT THAT'S BEEN MY HE HAS BEEN
MY PATTERN OF ACTION FOR THE
FORTY YEARS I'VE BEEN A
PRACTICE IS ADVOCATE FOR
PATIENTS- I DO THINK THAT THERE
IS A- THERE IS A- BALANCE TO BE
HAD- ACTION IS IMPROVE IS
EXTREMELY IMPORTANT AND NEEDS
TO BE THE PRIORITY. BUT WITHOUT
A WITHOUT A PROFESSION. IT'S
GOING TO BE MUCH WORSE FOR
CONSUMERS IF YOU DON'T HAVE A
PROFESSION IT IS FUNCTIONING AT
THE HIGHEST LEVEL AND I- I
THINK IT'S IMPORTANT TO HAVE
THAT. DONE BALANCE AS WELL AS
AN BUT I ATE MY- I'VE SAID
BEFORE THAT I HATE I HATE
HOUSE- I FEEL LIKE I AM.
UNTRUSTWORTHY I DON'T COME IN
WITH BY US I AB I'M WILLING TO
PROTECT CONSUMERS. AND NOT
PROJECT HARMFUL DOCTORS AND-
THE REAL ISSUE IS CAN YOU TRUST
ME HI I REALIZE YOU DON'T KNOW
ME- YOU DON'T KNOW YOU LIKE TO
PEOPLE THAT SPOKE ON MY BEHALF
IN MY COMMUNITY. BUT I WILL
TELL YOU I WILL PLEDGE YOUR
GOAL I WILL. SPEAK TO YOU THAT
MY- YOU MIGHT THAT I WILL. A
DEDICATED TO PATIENT PROTECTION.
THANK YOU DR- DR MAHMOUD. THE
PLUS AND FOREMOST END THE SOLE
JOB ADMISSION OF MEDICAL BOARD
IS UNDER MY PROTECTION AND
SAFETY OF OUR- CALIFORNIANS AND
DELIVER DOT. WORDS LOS. HERE
STANDARDS TO CALIFORNIANS- HOW
CAN COULD NOT BE DELIVERED. IN
A- I CLASS LEVEL UNLESS THERE'S
AN ACCOUNTABILITY. AND I THINK
I AM I'M NOT I'M I'M I THINK
I'M SURE THAT I WOULD BE READY
TO MAKE ANY ACCOUNTABILITY
THERE IS ANY BREACH IN
HEALTHCARE DELIVERY AT ANY
LEVEL. AND AS I SAID BEFORE AND
I E. ECKEL- SEVERAL OTHER
SENATORS ARE CONCERNED ABOUT IS
THE- AT THINGS ARE NOT
HAPPENING IN TIMELY FASHION AND
THAT DOCTOR FRUSTRATE ME
EQUALLY AS SO MANY PEOPLE ARE
FRUSTRATED AND- WE NEED TO MAKE
SOME MOVES OBVIOUSLY THERE ARE
A- CHALLENGES AND THERE ARE. NO
TRYING TO. BUT I THINK WE NEED
TO MOVE BEYOND THAT AND WE HAVE
TO SHOW A THREATENED AND I'M
PRETTY SURE ONCE YOU FOR THE
PLAN THAT MEDICAL WARD IS THE-
WOMAN IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION
PEOPLE WHO TRUST US. AND MY
GOAL WILL BE TO ONCE I GET
CONFRONTED TO WORK AGGRESSIVELY
ON BAGHDAD. PEOPLE'S VOICES ARE
HEARD PEOPLE'S CONCERNS ARE
HEARD AND NOT ONLY HOGAN HEARD
TIMELY AND RESPONSIVE GIVEN
TIMELY AND PEOPLE WHO ARE
RESPONSIBLE FIRER THEY'RE HOME
ATER- DISCIPLINES TIMELY SO
THAT WE CAN. CONTINUE TO LEAD
THE HEALTHCARE DELIVERY IN.
CALIFORNIA AS OF OUR STANDARD.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU DOT.
MENTOR THANK AT ONE YES. YOU
KNOW HOW ARMED I JUST I KNOW IF
IT'S A HE IN THE SKY BUT I
THINK IN THE LARGER
RESPONSIBILITY WE HAVE. IS THAT
YOU KNOW WHETHER IT'S A BOARD
OF PHARMACY BOARD OF
ACCOUNTANCY THE NURSES AND
NURSE PRACTITIONER J. AND
EVERYONE OF THESE BOARDS ARE
REGULATED I'D LOVE TO BE ABLE
TO SEE IF IT'S POSSIBLE HOW
MANY CASES AND IF THERE'S AN
ABERRATION MAY BECAUSE THE
MICRO ISSUE MAY BECAUSE THERE'S
SOME OTHER ISSUE WITH RESPECT
TO THIS BOARD. BUT IS THERE
SOMETHING DIFFERENT IN TERMS OF
ALL GETS HER FORTY ARMY BOARD
THIS FORTY ONE OR SOMETHING
BOARDS ON THE DEPARTMENT
CONSUMER AFFAIRS. A SENATOR OF
COVERAGE TO THE HEAD OF THAT
RIGHT YEAH AND SO TO GET SOME
SENSE IS TO SEE IF THERE'S AN
ABERRATION BECAUSE OF MICRO
BECAUSE OF OTHER ISSUES N. N.
AND- THEY GET TO IN A LARGER
SENSE WHICH WOULD HELP US TO
SEE HOW THIS WORKS AND HOW THE
BOARD IS WORKING IN CONJUNCTION
WITH ALL THE OTHER. CONSUMER
BOARDS TO HAVE SIMILAR
RESPONSIBILITIES JUST DIFFERENT
AREAS OF THE LAW. AND PUBLIC
POLICY. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
NUMBER TOWN A YES- YOU PROBABLY
HAVE YOUR HAND UP. I WILL GO TO
YOUR WE CAN AS A CENTER AND OF
COURSE YOU SENATE ART LORIEN
HIDES DON'T KNOW THE HANDBRAKE
ON ON THIS CAN SO STATE'S
FAILED ME ON THAT TIME GIVE ME
A CHANCE TO GET MY VOICE AND
OFFERS LET ME I SHARE. US SINCE
OF THE ON MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
ON OPPOSING THE PIPELINE THAT'S
WAS DISAPPOINTED THAT I
IMMEDIATELY JUMPED OUT WITHOUT
SAYING I WAS GOING TO SUPPORT.
CLEARLY- I WAS AWARE OF- IF THE
NEW. YOU THAT THEY ARE BROUGHT
FORWARD IN TERMS PROBABLY MOST.
ON THE TRYING ON THE TIGHT
LEVEL OF TIMELY IN GETTING
AWESOME RESOLUTIONS TO THE
ISSUES THAT THEY BROUGHT
FORWARD. A LOSING A LOVED ONE
ON THROUGH MEDICAL MALPRACTICE
RELIGION MEDICAL MALPRACTICE IS
HORRIFIC. I AND MANY MANY
MEMBERS OF MY- ARE YOU THE
MEDICAL. SO I KNOW THE PASSION
THAT THEY APPROACH THE JOBLESS
THE CARE THAT THEY- YOU KNOW
HOUSE FOR THEIR PATIENTS AND-
DEVOTION I MEAN A LOT OF
SOMEBODY ANSWERING THE PHONE AT
THREE IN THE MORNING TO NOW.
ANSWER A QUESTION FROM THE
SENIOR WHO WANTS TO KNOW WHERE
TO GET A COLD IT SHOT ON THOSE
THINGS ARE HAPPENING HEALTH WE
KNOW. SO I WANT YOU ALL TO KNOW
WHO THEY ARE POSITION IN
PARTICULAR THAT I THINK WHAT WE
HEARD TODAY GIVES RISE TO
LOOKING FOR SOLUTIONS AND THERE
ARE CERTAINLY IN THE
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS IN FRONT OF
US. THAT COULD HELP BOTH SIDES
OF THIS QUESTION WE. WILL BE
GOING THROUGH A ARE. A REVIEW-
YOU. REVIEW I BELIEVE THAT
HAPPEN SAN JUAN OF OUR
COMMITTEE BILL CENTER. HOW
PERHAPS. WE CAN SIR BRING UP
THIS IN. THAT YOU PROVIDE US
TODAY I KNOW A VERY KEEN FOR
YOU TO DO THE- TO COME. AND
LOOK FOR SOME. IN TERMS OF
RESEARCH. THAT THE BOARD
PERHAPS. FOR MORE TIME JUST. OF
WHETHER THAT. WE ARE READING
THAT WILL SIGN ON THE BURDEN
CROSS. TRAFFIC OR- ENFORCED
INVEST. THAT USED TO BE PRESS
STATUS NO LONGER THE- WHAT'S
THAT HOW. ISSUE AND THE ON THE-
THAT HAVE BEEN BROUGHT UP BY
THE. ABSENT WHAT BUT I THINK WE
NEED TO DIVE TO TAKE LOOK AT
THE BECAUSE ONE AS MANY ONE IS
TOO MANY ARE WILLING YOU LOSE A
ONE AND YOU NOT GET ANY REST.
SO I WILL. MY SUPPORT AS I SAID
IT'S A VERY DIFFICULT SERVER
THAT WE'VE ASKED THE GENTLEMAN-
WHO HAVE INCREDIBLE-
BACKGROUNDS IN EDUCATION AND
DEVOTION FOR MANY YEARS TO
THEIR PATIENTS. ARE FOR THEM TO
BEAR- ALL OF THE- MISTAKES
GOING ON BEFORE THEM AND
PRESENT. ALL WE NEED TO FIND A
PATH- SO THAT THEY CAN CONTINUE
TO. YOU KNOW EXERCISE THEIR
EXPERTISE BUT DO THAT WITH SOME
NOTING THE PARAMETERS THAT THEY
NEED TO SERVE WITH THEM SO I
JUST WANT TO KNOW THAT I ALWAYS
LOOK FOR SOLUTIONS AND JOAN MY
HEART REACHES OUT TO YOU. THOSE
WHO OPPOSE AND PLEASE KNOW THAT
I AM COMMITTED TO SEEK SOME
SOLUTIONS THAT THIS CAN'T
HAPPEN ALSO EASILY TO ANY
OTHERS THAT COME FORWARD WITH
COMPLAINTS. ON THE MALPRACTICE
ISSUES SO WITH THEIR
INDIVIDUAL- PHYSICIANS OR
HEALTH PROVIDERS ACROSS THE
BOARD. THANK YOU FOR THAT
OPPORTUNITY HARPER MY REMARKS.
SENATOR THANK YOU MR VICE
CHAIRMAN. BREAKING DOWN PROTEIN
REALLY QUICK- FIRST OF ALL I
THINK. BEING A MEMBER OF THE
CMA THAT THAT THAT'S A STRAW
MAN ARGUMENT THAT DOESN'T THAT
DOESN'T CARRY ANY WEIGHT FOR ME
TO ME THAT TELLS ME THAT THESE
ARE PEOPLE WHO ARE DEDICATED.
TO THEIR PROFESSION AND WANT TO
BE INVOLVED HAVING SAID THAT WE
CAN'T HAVE THE SUNSET REVIEW-
IS SOON ENOUGH AS FAR AS I'M
CONCERNED ON THIS BOARD. SO IT
IS. OUR I'M- PEREKOP THAT IS
NOW. WITH THESE INTO. BUT MAY
AS CENTER HER. YOU'LL OUT A
JUST. AND WE REALLY NEED TO
TAKE A LOOK AT THE- BECAUSE YOU
KNOW YOU KNOW. HAPPEN BUT
PEOPLE DO TO JOHN. AND YOU KNOW
BASIC- AND I WANT TO SEE MORE
DATA SO I APPRECIATE APPROACH
HIM ASKING FOR THAT BECAUSE THE
AND THAT'LL BE REALLY HELPFUL
AND- I APPRECIATE EVERYBODY'S
OUT PARTICIPATING TODAY. AND
WAS VERY ENLIGHTENING HEARING
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MR VICE
CHAIRMAN- I WILL BEFORE I ASK
FOR MOTIONS A COUPLE THINGS. I
DO FULLY INTEND TO HAVE A
CONVERSATION WITH THE TERROR OF
BEING P. RELATED TO THE SUNSET
REVIEW AND THESE OUTSTANDING
QUESTIONS THAT HAVE COME UP.
THAT WE WILL MAKE SURE AND GET-
CORRESPONDENCE TO BOTH THE
MEDICAL BOARD. DIRECTOR AS WELL
AS COPYING THE CHAIR OF BMP
REGARDLESS OF HOW A
RECOMMENDATION COMES OUT OF
THIS BODY TODAY FOR. APPOINTEES
GOING TO THE FULL SENATE FOR
CONFIRMATION THAT IS WHERE THE
CONFIRMATION HAPPENS. SO I WILL
DO THAT- I DO. I ALSO WANT TO
POINT OUT THAT WE HAVE FOR MORE
MEMBERS HEADING OUR WAY FROM
THE MEDICAL BOARD TO BE
CONFIRMED WITHIN THE NEXT
COUPLE OF MONTHS. SO AND I SAY
THAT TO THE GOOD DOCTORS THAT
ARE. HERE WITH US TODAY BECAUSE
WHAT THAT MEANS IS THERE IS
GOING TO CONTINUE TO BE FOCUS
ON THE MEDICAL BOARD RIGHT NOW.
AND SO IT ISN'T IT ISN'T JUST
R. THREE APPOINTEES TODAY. IT
IS ACTUALLY MORE THAN THAT AND
AS I SAW I THINK YESTERDAY THE
GOVERNOR MADE. A PUBLIC
APPOINTMENT- SO I THINK THAT
THIS IS GOING TO BE AN ONGOING
CONVERSATION BECAUSE WE HAVE
BEEN. APPROACHED BY MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC A SMALL NUMBER OF
FOLKS TODAY BUT- WE HAVE
QUESTIONS WE NEED ANSWERED- I
DO BELIEVE. WE SHOULD MOVE THIS
FORWARD TODAY- I'M NOT CERTAIN
HOW SOON THESE WILL BE ON THE
FLOOR FOR CONFIRMATION. BUT I
WANT TO GIVE NOTICE THAT THE
CONVERSATION IS GOING TO
CONTINUE AND I AGREE WITH YOU
MR VICE CHAIRMAN- PEOPLE'S
INVOLVEMENT IN AN ASSOCIATION
IS ONE FACTOR. BUT PEOPLE GET
INVOLVED BECAUSE THEY WANT TO
BE INVOLVED AND IT'S IN AND SO-
I DO. AGREE WITH YOU ON THAT
FOR CERTAIN ARM. WHO CAN APPLY
TO BE ON BOARDS THROUGH THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE. THE SENATE
HAS AN APPOINTMENT THE ASSEMBLY
HAS AN APPOINTMENT ON THE
ASSEMBLY IN THE SENATE HAVE
PUBLIC APPOINTMENTS. I'M I
WOULD SAY THAT THERE IS A
CONVERSATION THERE ARE FIFTEEN
MEMBERS OF THIS BOARD. EIGHT
WHICH ARE DESIGNATED BY- BY THE
ESTABLISHMENT OF THE BOARD
EIGHT THAT ARE UP FROM THE
MEDICAL ESTABLISHMENT AND SEVEN
THAT OUR PUBLIC. MEMBERS MAYBE
THERE IS A CONVERSATION WE AN
HAVE ABOUT INCREASING THE
NUMBER OF PUBLIC MEMBERS. SO
THAT THEIR AT LEAST EQUAL. OR
MORE THAN GIVEN IT IT IS A
PUBLIC PROTECTION BOARD. AND I
WOULD HOPE THAT YOU WOULD-
SUPPORT THAT AS MEMBERS OF THE
BOARD BECAUSE IT REALLY IS
ABOUT YOUR RELATIONSHIP WITH
THE PUBLIC YOU REPRESENT-
CERTAINLY THE MEDICAL
ESTABLISHMENT IN YOUR ROLES AND
YOU BRING THAT EXPERTISE AS I
SAID BEFORE. BUT THE MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC HAVE TO FEEL THAT
THERE'S BALLOTS ARE AND THEY'RE
THE ONES WHO DECIDE. YOU KNOW
THEY'RE THE ONES WHO DECIDE IF
WE ARE DOING A GOOD JOB OR NOT.
I OFTEN SAY WHEN'S WHEN SOMEONE
WANTS TO POINT OUT YOUR LEADER
I'M LIKE I'M A LEADER. IF
PEOPLE AGREE THAT I AM A LEADER
OTHERWISE I AM NOT A LEADER AND
SO. I JUST WANT TO POINT THAT
OUT IT'S NOT MY DETERMINATION
IT'S YOURS. SO OUT WITH THAT.
I'M GONNA SEPARATE EACH ONE BUT
I HOPE. I APPRECIATE THE
DIALOGUE- GENTLEMAN TODAY I
HOPE YOU TAKE TO HEART SOME OF
WHAT WE SAID- WE TAKE OUR JOB
AS SERIOUSLY AS YOU TAKE YOURS
AND SO. ARE CERTAINLY MORE TO
COME LET ME. ASK IF THERE IS A
MOTION ON ITEM NUMBER TWO
GOVERNOR'S APPOINTEES REQUIRED
TO APPEAR NUMBER B. I'LL START
WITH DOCTOR DEATH GET ON A DAY
OF- FOR A MOTION. MR MAJORITY
LEADER THANK YOU MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
PLEASE TURN ON YOUR MICROPHONES.
BATES I THREE FIVE HERTZBERG HI
AYE LAWYERS AYE I WILL NOT
VOTING WILL NOT VOTING ATKINS
VOTING. IS NOT VOTING THREE TWO
ZERO. I WILL TAKE A MOTION ON
GOVERNOR'S APPOINTEES REQUIRED
TO APPEAR I AM C. S. DR.
SECRETARY FADES FIVE AYE
HERTZBERG AYE BERGHEIM A
LAYERED ON AYE WILK HI I ATKINS.
FIVE CONFIRMED FIVE TWO ZERO. I
WILL TAKE EMOTIONAL GOVERNOR'S
APPOINTEES REQUIRED TO APPEAR
ITEM TWO D. DR RICHARD THORPE
MADAM SECRETARY- I'M SORRY HI I
READ YOUR MIND THANK YOU. FOR
YOUR THANK YOU A MOTION BY THE
MAJORITY LEADER MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL IT'S- FIVE
EIGHT FIVE HERTZBERG FIVE
REFERS ISLAND. RIGHT I WILL NOT
VOTING NOT VOTING ATKINS I CAN
FIVE FOUR TO ZERO. THANK YOU HI
THESE APPOINTMENTS ARE
RECOMMENDED IT WILL PROCEED TO
THE FLOOR AND I WILL
CONGRATULATIONS GENTLEMEN AND I
WILL. PROCEED TO GET THE
INFORMATION THAT I PROMISED YOU
THAT WE WOULD SEEK TO DO. THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR TIME TODAY.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MANAGER AND THE SAND COMMITTEE
THANK YOU. OKAY- LET'S SEE WE
ARE NOW I HEADED INTO-
EXECUTIVE SESSION SO- THIS
MEETING WILL. CONCLUDED WE WILL
GO INTO EXECUTIVE SESSION THANK
YOU COLLEAGUES. THANK YOU.